Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Hello y'all and welcome to Riftbound
Regional Qualifiers in Atlanta, Georgia.
My name is Miss Chim Shim and today, as
you can see, I am here on the floor
interviewing all of the attendees to
show y'all how much fun you're missing
out on. So, first and foremost, I kind
of want to ask you, are you from
Atlanta?
>> I'm not. I'm actually from Boston, so I
had to travel a little ways out here.
>> Oh my gosh. And how do you like
Riftbound being on this side of the
country?
>> Uh, I think it's pretty cool. I think we
get to travel a lot throughout the uh
throughout the country getting to play
Riftbound. So, it's fun to get to to see
different areas of the US when we're
doing this. Yeah,
>> absolutely. And how do you like Atlanta
so far? And watch yourself cuz I'm from
Atlanta.
>> Okay. So, I'm New England born and
raised. Uh my body is just acclimated to
the cold, so I was it was a nice crisp
40° when I left. Uh so coming here was a
little bit toasty, especially in a
sweatshirt.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. Are you from
Atlanta?
>> Um not currently. I used to live around
here, but I'm from Oklahoma today.
>> Okay. Okay. So, did you you had to do a
little bit of traveling to get here?
>> Yeah, not too bad. It was about a 2-hour
flight, direct flight. Wasn't bad.
>> So, how do you feel about Riftbound
coming to Atlanta, Georgia?
>> I think it's awesome. I think it's a
great spot for it. I mean, it Atlanta's
like a super hub city, so I think it's
super easy for everyone to travel to.
Um, and there's a lot of stuff around
here. Obviously, Georgia Aquarium is
amazing. So, I think it's a great spot.
>> Absolutely. I love that. I would like to
ask, are you from Atlanta?
>> No, I'm not. I'm from uh TC.
>> Okay. So, you had to do a little bit of
travel to get here to ATL today,
correct?
>> Yes.
>> And what do you how do you feel about
Riftbound Regionals coming to Atlanta,
coming to the South?
>> Oh, um yeah, this was uh much easier to
get to than um Houston was for me. Uh I
like that they've been all spread out. I
think there's one on the West Coast at
the end of the year, too, for everyone
over there. So, I like how they've been
peppered across the whole country so
far. So, I think that's been great.
>> Absolutely. Have you been enjoying
Atlanta so far? Uh yeah, I had really
really great food so far. Um and it's
just been a blast.
>> I do want to ask you, how do you feel
about Riftbound coming to Atlanta,
Georgia?
>> It's great. It's nice and warm here and
this venue is really nice.
>> Absolutely. And are you from Atlanta?
>> No, I'm based in Seattle.
>> Okay, so you had a little bit of travel
today. Thank you guys so much for
watching and we'll see you soon.
A new set means new places to play. And
I want to talk about the most important
card type in all of Riftbite. It's the
thing you see every single time you sit
down to play a game. It is battlefields.
Here's a couple that I've had my eye on
from Unleashed. Starting with Abandoned
Hall. Now, I know all of the sickos
playing Aurelia and Ezreal out there are
very excited about this one. Raven Bloom
Student, pretty good card. Every single
time you play a spell, it gets a bit
bigger. This is a battlefield that does
that for both players, so you do have to
be a little bit careful. But this is a
great way to add a ton of value to all
your pumps. All of the calm uh legends
going to love this battlefield. All
these kind of spell slingy things like
Ezreal going to love this. Some of the
other decks maybe not so good, but even
things like hex that great, right?
Removal spells can turn the tide of
combat not just by taking out a unit,
but by giving extra might units here as
well. There are a ton of different ways
to use this. And I have to feel like the
types of players that enjoy this kind of
thing are going to be very excited to be
at Abandoned Hall. and it's someone that
has been named by many Raven Blue
students. Not that excited to see this,
at least on the other side of the table.
Moving on, we have a pretty fun one here
that I think people might be happy
exists. It is Rippers Bay. Now, if
you're out there complaining about
Rebuke and units being returned ahead,
how annoying and frustrating it is,
Rippers Bay is maybe a way to help
counteract some of that pressure. When a
unit here is returned to a player's
hand, that player may pay one to channel
one rune exhaust. Now, this works for a
couple other things. If you can return
your own unit to your hand, you can
obviously take advantage of this. But
this is just a nice way to say, "Hey,
stop bouncing my stuff. I'm going to at
least get some value out of it when it
happens." Definitely some new space
here. Kind of interesting one where it
can punish certain types of effects, but
can also be used with other types of
effects. I think Rebuke is on my mind
lately, and I feel like this is
something that people can look at, be
like, you know what, I'm going to give
that a try against all the chaos decks
in my area. Moving on, we have even more
spicy stuff to look at here in
Unleashed. And uh this one is
interesting because I think it has a
bunch of different effects. Amateur
recital. Now we've seen a lot of Lucian
and a lot of Relentless Pursuit uh
recently in Riftbound and it looks
pretty good when you bounce to a
battlefield and get get to bounce back.
This is when you hold here, you may move
a unit at a battlefield to its base. So
a ton of different applications. First
of all, if you're really holding this
side of side down, this is your
battlefield. Your opponent is going to
struggle to keep a single unit on their
other battlefield. So it gives you a
little bit more freedom to try and get
in there and conquer. But you can also
kind of reset your own stuff. Remember
this is when you hold. So units are
already awakened when this happens. So
this, you know, you get your point for
holding. You presumably conquered the
turn before when this started to happen.
You can move that unit and then use it
to reinforce another battlefield. There
are lots of different things you can do
both offensively and defensively. I know
Vex is in the art, so I feel like Vex is
maybe a place where she wants to play.
But I think with hold becoming much more
of a thing we think about in Riftbound
with Unleash, this is a battlefield that
has me really excited because I think
the level one stuff with amateur recital
seems pretty fun, but interacting with
your opponent's cards also seems kind of
wild. So really excited to play this one
and see what people cook up as we move
on to our fourth battlefield here of the
five we have to look at today. This one
is for all of the people that maybe like
things like Vio Mosland, maybe things
like Rock Ball Path, maybe don't like
when their opponents uh get to do fun
stuff. This is Forbidden Waste. This is
kind of the the Punisher battlefield uh
in this set. There's a bunch of
different battlefields like this that
have more negative effects. So, it's
maybe a little less appealing to go
there, whereas a lot of other
battlefields kind of unit make you feel
good for going there. This one's trying
to punish you. And I think Yi especially
is really not going to like this if you
have that deck in your area. While the
unit here is defending alone, it has a
minus two. So that basically just says,
"Yeah, you don't have legend text right
now. Get out of my uh get out of my
game." But I think this is a this is an
interesting one. If you're an aggressive
deck, your opponent's going to struggle
to hold here. If you're a deck that
really a massive bunch of units and move
like, you know, maybe a bunch of tokens
onto a battlefield, this could be a good
option for you here. Uh if you're a deck
that can move units off of other
battlefields, like even if your
opponent's going to put two or three
units here, if you're good at
repositioning them, you can really
punish a single unit that's trying to
hold this. So, forbidding waste, I
always love to highlight these because I
think people too often look at the
battlefields that do all the positive
things and don't necessarily look at the
battlefields that can be bad for your
opponents if you can find ways to
mitigate them. Last but not least, there
was one I'm going to say it. It's for
the chefs. If you're out there in the
kitchen and you're cooking, I don't know
if this is actually going to be good,
but it's certainly going to be fun to
play with. The academy with the golden
hammer statue when you hold here, give
your next spell this turn repeat equal
to its base cost. So, you know, there's
a bunch of good spells that already have
repeat. things like frigid touch, things
like bellow's breath, but what else can
we do with some of this? Well, maybe for
a calm, we can get two on guard for the
price of one. Four might for two energy,
not so bad. Uh maybe we are playing
Kaiso. We want to play something like a
void seeker or hex tech rate. That feels
pretty gross playing two of those for
the price of just paying for another
one. There are so many possible
applications of this. Note that it
doesn't it doesn't matter if the spell
already has repeat. In fact, it's
extraneous. It doesn't actually do
anything. But adding such a powerful
ability word to cards that don't have
it. Yes, the cost is a little tricky
because you do have to hold this
battlefield. But if you're able to hold
it, this could potentially do some
ridiculous things. I mean, it's a lot of
runes to maybe do this, but can you
imagine Lux repeating falling comet draw
only draw one card? That feels bad for
Lux. But killing two things,
singularity, all 12 runes. I'm not
saying it's easy. I didn't say it was
easy, but I'm saying it's going to be
fun. So, there's a few of the
battlefields that I've been looking at.
And unleash. Remember, you always sit
down at a game of rift mount and you
have to look at at least a few
battlefields every single game. So, it's
important to highlight the things that
you're going to see very, very often.
Thanks for tuning in and let me know
what battlefields you're interested in
in this set.
>> Hello and welcome back to Riftbound
Regionals in Atlanta, Georgia. Man, I I
love the breakdown right there. We've
got some interesting battlefields about
to come in through the unleash set that
is releasing soon. Which one is your
favorite? Well, I I love I'm blanking on
the name right now, but the one where
when you hold, you get to move a unit
from a battlefield back to its base.
It's so versatile, but it's also like
kind of fair. It's hard to pull off cuz
you have to hold. It's not like a
conqueror or just be at this
battlefield. So, that one's fun. Um, but
I just love how many of them feel like
direct hate battlefields for certain
meta matchups. Like minus two for a unit
holding here alone or defending here
alone. That's just the anti- one. So,
it's like, oh, you guys just run these
certain battlefields depending on the
matchup. Uh, and I think it's really
cool. Some people like, "Oh, let's pick
battlefields that are good for my deck."
And others are like, "No, let's just
pick battlefields that are annoying for
my opponent to deal with."
>> Absolutely. And maybe that little
frustration there will get them to make
some mess ups, a little slip up. But I
do believe you were talking about
amateurs recital.
>> Amateurs recital. Yes. Thank you.
>> Yes. And no. Yeah, I definitely think
that that looks like a good
>> Who's the one singing, by the way? Do we
have that like in the lore? Vex is on
the right.
>> Yeah. So Vex is on the right. But yeah,
I'm just going to call it like
Saraphene's apprentice because we are
going to get Saraphene soon down the
road. So maybe they're just planting
some some little seeds for for when she
finally
>> Well, clearly they were an amateur based
on the name of the battlefield. So he's
got a lot to learn before they reach
Saraphene level and start in the rune
terror universe. Yeah,
>> exactly. And I mean all of the artwork
I'm I'm sorry I'm a sucker for the
artwork, but all of the artwork on those
battlefields are also really really fun.
We had the Heimerdinger uh statue for
the academy. Um and then for amateurs
recital, you also get that sneak peek of
the Vex on the side there because she's
coming out in this next set. Yeah,
>> very fun.
>> We're getting a lot of ways to repeat
spells. I feel like that there's going
to be a theme. You know, I I built I
don't know if we've shown it yet on
stream, but I built silly decks for
Charmer and Patriot to use and we filmed
them playing my silly decks. They're
just giving me more ammo to make more
silly decks in the future. So, I'm
excited to try that. But, uh, we are
here to talk about the regional itself,
and we actually have an update on some
of the most popular decks. We already
showed this one early, but we're going
to start off with the pre- Rift, uh, or
pre-regional, uh, qualifier that
happened on Friday. Kind of break down
the decks that we saw there. Uh, and oh,
I'm here that we're actually going to
take a look at the day one instead. So,
we're just going to take a look at the
day one, what we have so far today. Uh,
so we can see the popular picks. And I
don't think it's too big of a surprise.
Draven is still the number one. But, um,
Mr. Chim Chim, you had mentioned that,
you know, Kai'Sa rounding out the top
three. A lot of people have been
doubting Kai'Sa. I'm still a believer,
but uh 104 on that uh legend.
>> Yes. No, I think it's very interesting
and I love to see it that the fact that
some of these origin uh legends are
still able to hold their weight to to to
hold a little mark here in uh set two.
So, we're seeing that Kai'Sa, we're
seeing that Master Yi. Now, Master Yi is
a little a little bit lower on the
numbers here, but he was kind of uh payw
wall blocked by uh Provings Grounds, so
not a lot of people had access to the
legend to even be able to play him. But
even more interestingly, we still see
that Victor being played. And I know a
lot of people hate going against that
Victor as he has so much uh recruits
that he makes makes him very annoying to
like deal with. And so I'm I'm glad to
see that these origin legends are still
here to play.
>> Also, I want to highlight the fact that
uh this is different numbers that we saw
for the um pre- Rift or pre-regional
qualifier on Friday. The numbers looked
very different. Like Lucian for example
is much higher on this. 60 Lucian
players. I know it's only 4% of the
field, but there's a lot of legends out
there. So like a lot of these
percentages are low. He's still in the
first page and in the top 10. I think
Lucian was one that I had my eyes on and
then kind of lost faith in. But clearly
a lot of other players here still have
faith in him. And Ari up there at 60 as
well um is one of those ones that again
I think she's going to get even stronger
and unleashed um with things like Vile
coming out that really utilize her
legend ability uh much stronger. But
still cool to see. Annie at 52. I
thought this would be much higher. I'm
just going to say it. I really thought
Annie would have been up in that like
top 10. I guess is this top 10?
>> I can't count notoriously. Either way,
like I thought you pushing top five,
right? Like I thought Annie would be a
much more popular legend than what we're
seeing right here. Uh and I'm hearing
from producers number 10 tied with Rexi.
So I'm going to give Rexi number 10 and
Annie number 11. So that way I'm still
right
in the top 10.
>> And I'm okay with that. especially in
the sense that I think we saw Rexi much
lower on uh Friday's um game as well.
So, uh I'm glad to see that we have more
faith in Rexai here. Uh I do want to see
a Rexai game today. I I I really want to
see somebody pop off on Rexi, show the
Gories how it's going down. But then
we've also got a couple of a couple of
people bringing out some sets, some
Teeos. I know we just we just uh saw
that there, but I'm even more happy to
see that the Garen numbers went up from
3 to 18.
>> Yeah, I mean, there's just more people
playing today than there were on Friday
during the uh regional qualifier, uh the
pre-regional qualifier. Um so, but he's
still the lowest. [laughter] Shout out
the Garrett players out there. Um
there's dozens of them. Dozens
>> there. There is technically a dozen and
then
>> not even dozens actually. There's dozen
plus
>> a dozen plus half a dozen.
>> I guess you have to be 20 and above to
be dozens plural,
>> right? Exactly. But um
>> okay, so this actually the comparison.
This is a really cool stat. I didn't
know that we had access to this one. So
yeah, we can see kind of the difference
in the shakeup. Annie had more uh
percentage based on Friday. Ezreal had
more percentage base. Ari much less
percentage base on Friday. Uh and the
rest are kind of in the same order. uh
essentially in the same order actually.
Um but yeah, you can see that there was
some movement around from Friday to
today.
>> Absolutely. And yeah, you just have to
look at those percentages there because
we do have more people on day one. Um
but I also see that the master went down
in terms of percentage. I'm a little I'm
a little concerned about uh do we not
have faith in the master
testing it out and we're like no it
doesn't feel as good. Let's cut that.
>> Exactly. But I also want to point out
the Lucian going up. There's a lot more
fate there. Um, so yeah, I'm I'm really
excited to see how this unfolds.
>> Victor also going down. Interesting to
see that. And speaking of Victor, I'm
hearing that that's going to be one of
the deck lists coming up for our next
feature match. So, let's take a look at
that. Oh, this is not a feature match
actually. This is just one of the
previews for the Victor deck. So, uh,
let's just chat about kind of what
Victor can do right now and what the the
legend has kind of adapted towards. This
is one of those ones that uh was
slightly hit by the ban list mostly.
We're looking at that dreaming tree.
That was a very popular one for Victor
to run cuz you can like hit and blade
your own unit and then get an extra draw
off of it. You can stupify your own
unit, get an extra draw off of it.
Really anything that targets your own
unit, get an extra draw off of it. Um
but now you don't have access to that
same battlefield. So they've adapted a
little bit and are more focused on just
controlling the field with a lot of
these kind of, you know, across the
board just strong spells. We have the
cold of weeks, the hidden blades, three
imperial decrees. We're seeing a lot of
that going around and even like a
vengeance in this deck list. Um, so the
control victor, it's kind of a nightmare
to play against Mr. Chin because they
have so much removal.
>> They've got so much removal of units of
gears. There's just so much going on. I
totally understand why somebody who is
playing into this Victor would have a
major problem. I mean, vengeance four
cost recycle two and a unit is gone.
Yeah. And I feel like that can deal with
a lot of uh people like the or like the
Ireelia and you just don't get to play
unless you have those uh spells in hand
to deal with it.
>> And I actually really like what the
Victor players have kind of adapted
towards. We saw some of this early on in
Spirit Forge, but the Zing Xiaou Zing
Xiaou was a uh a really cool iteration
on Victor cuz right when Spear Forge
launched, a lot of people were excited
for like, oh, the unitless Victor. And
then people realized, no, some of the
units are really good. This one in
particular, uh it enters ready if you
have two or more other units in your
base. Well, you can turn one make a
recruit. If if you're going second, you
have three runes up. Uh you just turn
one, make a recruit, then turn two, make
a recruit, and play this. And actually,
now that I think about it, you can even
do this when you have the you go in
first with the two energy start. So, you
uh can just get this out with two
recruits, get two points very early on,
play a fast game. It also just helps you
clear battlefields if your spells aren't
enough. Uh and with again Draven kind of
becoming less and less popular. This is
a great way to push through a lot of
like the Azir boards, a lot of the
Ezreal boards, things that uh aren't
going to have as scary of units out
there.
>> Absolutely. You really just kind of have
a little bit of everything with this,
Victor. And you even got style,
especially if you're running this
overnumbered legend. I just want to
shout out the artist here. That is some
amazing.
>> It's so creepy, but in a good way. And
like it looks like a spider like
>> Yeah.
>> Like that is something to be feared,
especially when somebody has these cards
in their deck and you look at that
legend, you're like, "Oh, this person
came here to play."
>> World of the Arcane uh earning the
title. And one other thing on this
specific uh control of Victor deck list
that I like to highlight is the Jace.
Speaking of arcane uh and uh heralding
in the magic in the universe Jace uh
really cool unit. This was one of like
the classic combos in Victor. Even like
Lux was running this. Anything with like
blue yellow cuz when you play him you
can kill a friendly gear and then play a
gear with energy cost no more than seven
from your hand this turn. This was
customuilt for Vanguard's Armory if
we're being honest. I'm sure that it'll
come up in future releases as well as
bigger gears come out. But Vanguard's
Armory is obviously the big combo piece
with it in the control matchup. You just
get even more recruits out there. And
you said that's kind of the name of the
game is just spam the field with all
these, you know, one might recruits and
then do stuff with them. And I think
that's why like the three Imperial
decrees we're starting to see creep up.
Now, all of that said, spent a lot of
time talking about Victor. Important to
note that the percentage is not quite
there. Like the player base isn't fully
behind Victor right now. This is not one
of like the biggest feared decks, but
part of me thinks it could almost have
the similar like Azir effect that we saw
in Leo where like it sneaks up on people
that aren't ready for the matchup that
don't have the right sideboard for it
cuz it dodges a lot of things that a lot
of people play for like the Kaiso match
ups where you're targeting stuff like
not so fast, not as good against Victor
when you have like cold a week or the
imperial decree cuz like you're not
targeting anything. You're just
>> removing stuff that you have to choose
with the cold a week or like crashing in
with your one might guys. So, it can do
a lot of cool removal stuff that not
everyone can sideboard against.
>> With that being said, I kind of want to
ask you if if if I'm new to Riftbound,
what am I fearing as Victor going into a
match?
>> Oh, so if you're the Victor player.
>> Yes.
>> Oh, honestly, I think one of Victor's uh
hardest matchups is the mirror or or any
other blue matchup. Anything they can
play Bellow's Breath. Bellow's Breath is
like one of the most efficient cards you
can play against Victor because you make
a lot of one might units. Bella's breath
clears three at the same location. It
does one damage to three things at the
same location and you can repeat it. So
like let's say you vanguard's armory
make three. Well, you can just clear
that in one turn with the bellow's
breath. So funnily enough, like any
other blue matchup uh is going to be
tough for you, which makes the Victor
mirrors very funny cuz like they're
always just so back and forth. Um
>> that would be the number one I would
say. And then number two would be
probably anything that can bounce around
the board like the Aurelas. Um because
like your big strength is being able to
use like the Imperial decrees uh to get
in and clear out, but Aurelia often will
score and then leave the battlefield. So
they're not going to give you the
opportunity and they're going to have
like gas and zonas. So even if you like
use your cold a weeks and hitting
blades, if the Aellia player knows a
matchup and is patient enough like as
very few Aelia players these days are
just putting out an Aurelia and passing
like
>> you get punished so easily for that. So
you wait to play the Aelia until you
have the defense, you have your own like
defies and stuff like that. Um, so I
would say like the mirror matchup and
Aurelia are the ones if you're new to
playing Victor, if you're new to
Riftbound, like watch out for those and
and really think through the decisions
you're making because those ones you can
either get punished by them or your
removal tools aren't going to be as
effective against them.
>> Absolutely. And I'm sure that's what um
a lot of people are thinking here and
that's probably why.
>> How's a Fiora matchup? You play Fiora,
right? Do you like your Victor matchup?
>> Absolutely. I do love uh playing Fiora
and honestly I haven't played into many
uh victors but as Fiora I have played
into many Azir so but
>> yeah similar
[laughter]
>> a little bit
>> some of the same spells
>> but yeah so um
>> make tokens
>> Fiona normally does well whenever I play
her she does really well into that Azir
I do want to find this matchup that
would be so awesome if we get a Fiora
Victor match Fior. Well, I mean, we just
need to get you a Fiora magic. We've
been grinding Fiora.
>> Fiora, [screaming]
come out.
>> Maybe one day they'll pass us.
>> I'm hoping. But, um, I think we've got
some top cards.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Production telling us we got
>> Look here.
>> Okay. So, these are the most popular
cards. And this is zero surprises. Zero
surprises for me. The number of decks
that they are in. This is not the number
of cards seen. That top two. This tells
a story, Reagan, [laughter]
>> because Ferris 4runner is the in in my
opinion the strongest individual red
card.
>> Absolutely.
>> It's up there with Kai'Sa. It's kind of
an argument depending on the deck, but
like Ferris Fora just just
pound-for-pound what it does. It's such
an efficient unit cuz it's essentially
six energy and a recycle cost to
represent 12 might of stats cuz you have
six on the unit and then total six on
the two mech tokens that you create on
death. So, what do you do about that?
You don't kill it. you just bounce it
back to hand with the rebuke. So, I feel
like these two cards are really shaping
the meta on their own. And uh it's no
surprise to me that they're both at the
top.
>> Yeah, it's pretty handinand there,
honestly, when you put it that way. But
I also think a hard bargain being at the
top makes a lot of sense. Yep. It's uh
it's so costly that you have to pay to
not allow something to go through. Yeah,
a lot of the counter spells that and
defy. Fun fact, I actually ran the
numbers u before the event just cuz I
was bored and had some time and I was
curious. Defy h actually I'm going to
play a little game here. How many spells
currently in the game do you think Defy
can counter? What percentage of spells
currently in the game are defiable?
>> Uh let's go 75%.
>> Very close.
>> It's 78.
>> Oh wow.
>> 78% of all spells are defiable.
>> Oh my god,
>> that's a pretty strong spell. that
covers a lot. Now, the trade-off is a
lot of the spells it doesn't counter are
very good, right?
>> Um, but it it covers a large amount of
the field. So, no surprise to see that
up there as well. Um,
>> let's talk about Noxis Hopeful because
if I remember correctly, Noxis Hopeful's
cost decreases if you played a spell
that turn.
>> Uh, any card, it's got Legion keyword.
So, that just means if you played a
card, it costs two less or at least
that's what its legion effect tells you.
So it becomes essentially a two energy
form might. I am interested to see it
that high because personally I had kind
of fallen off the Nox's hopeful hype
train. I I took it out of my Kai'Sa and
did not miss it. Um but I know a lot of
other Kaisers that I've talked to are
like no you're crazy. This is a crazy
good card. A lot of Dravens are still on
it cuz it's a very stat efficient unit
for a a deck like him to run. Even
Annies are still on this card. So a lot
of the red decks are still playing this.
Um another one would be like Rexi. Rexai
loves this card cuz you can play it from
the top for for cheaper. Um, but I I
just feel like stat sticks on units are
becoming less and less prevalent as the
game develops and especially going into
unleash. Like you're looking more for
powerful effects on your units rather
than just stats on your units. So that's
where I kind of fell off on it. I prefer
a more spellheavy approach. But clearly
the the field disagrees with with my
take cuz it is in the top 10.
>> I I don't know. I'm trying to like break
it down in my head, but I can't do the
quick maths. But it looks like there's
just like a lot of red, purple, and
green cards on this display here.
>> Can we count? Are there any that are not
those three? Wait a minute.
>> I think yellow is hard bargain. Is is
>> No, these are all [laughter] these are
all purple, red, yellow. Good cash,
Reagan. I didn't even realize that.
>> That's very funny. Oh, wait. There's
blue. There's blue at the bottom.
Thousand tail watcher. Shout out
Thousand Tail for saving the list. All
right,
>> there we go. Well, let's go ahead and
look at a [music] deck list for this
upcoming match, shall we?
>> I think we're ready to hop in here
shortly. So, thanks for sticking with
us, everybody, while we're getting ready
for our next feature match. Deck list is
in front of us. And wouldn't you know,
we got an Annie.
>> We got an Annie. We were talking about
red and purples. Well, baby, we've got a
red and purple girl. Okay, so we're
seeing that Nox is hopeful three here.
But you know, the talk of the town, that
flash card.
>> Yeah. Shout out to all the local game
stores that received um reprint stock
and and have been uh diving those out to
to gamers around. Um also, shout out to
whoever chefed this list. This is very
interesting to me. the Rexi. Red Rexi
has been sneaking into other decks that
are not Rexi specifically because it um
or at least the way that I've seen it
mostly played in things like Draven is
that it allows any unit that enters play
from outside not not your hand. So like
from the top of your deck, from your
champion zone, it can have accelerate.
So that makes sense to me in like a
Draven list. Interesting that Annie's
running it because I don't really think
of like Annie Stubborn as being
something that's really that useful
accelerated. Yeah, I can get out and get
a point, but like I guess the idea for
this is more things like Ferris 4runner
um creating the the two tokens or like
Rengar reaction speed playing from I
guess that still plays from hands. So
interesting interesting tech card. I I'm
curious how they're going to try and
play it. Um shout out Dana Fischer, the
the chef of this deck. I'm seeing the
name in the top right cuz this is a very
cool kind of like lower to the ground
Annus. A lot of two uh two energy units,
two might units and then just these
cheaper spells which is fairly typical
for Annie. Yeah, it looks like it's not
going to be too costtheavy on some of
these things except for as we were just
talking about the and I always mess up
this name. Ferris
>> Ferris
>> Ferris Ferris I can't roll my RS I just
tried
>> Ferris
that was
>> but yes we're going to be seeing this
card here. So it's we were talking
earlier essentially a 12 might unit.
>> It's just like crazy the math on this
card. Yeah.
>> Yeah. You have the sixmite on the board
and then when you kill it, six might
comes back into the board
>> and Annie as red purple also gets to
play the rebuke. So, we're talking about
that like dichotomy of the meta at the
top most represented cards. Uh Annie is
one of the decks that can play both.
>> Absolutely. I I love to see it. Now, I
do have a question here. Can you rebuke
a mech token?
>> Yes.
>> Play it with a
>> smokes.
>> It never existed. It's just gone. Wow,
that's a sad thing to see. Well, I doubt
we'll be seeing any of that there. Yeah,
>> it's like the art in Rebuke. It's like
actually sucked out, you know. Um, all
right, we're moving on to the next deck
list here
>> is uh it's Aurelia.
>> Our first Ireelia game. I love to see
it. Now, Ireelia is the queen of not
only gear, but just making her fever uh
unit super duper big. Want to protect
her at all costs. She is the queen. Uh,
so we've got some ganking uh, boots of
swiftness. We got the gas, of course.
We've got the znas. Um, and I always
love to see the one and only Stella.
>> Yeah, Stellacorn is the bread and butter
of this deck. Some people will say
Aurelia Fervent is the best card in this
deck. No, no, it's Stellicorn Herder.
Okay,
>> she's the real queen.
>> This is the real unit that you have to
watch out for. You snipe this with
everything. I will blow five runes to
deal with this [laughter] card early on
in the Aurelia match up because it just
gets so out of control if the Celicorn
Herder gets you uh multiple draws. If
this thing survives two turns, it you're
just completely swamped in card
advantage. Your Aurelia will have so
many cards. Now, the danger of Aurelia,
and I'm noticing that this deck list
does not have the treasure hunter. A lot
of Aurelia are opting not for treasure
hunter. It gets swept by bellow's
breath. Uh, it's just really small in
general, so I could just get sniped by a
lot of stuff and it's a little slower. I
still like it because it helps you not
damp, but other Aurelia players are
saying, "No, you just kind of accept
that you're going to go down to a low
rune count at some point in the game and
just play with lower resources and you
just have a big enough Aelia by that
point that it doesn't matter." That is
the test of Aurelia players is how do
they manage their rune resources? Cuz
it's very easy in this deck. the the
legend blade dancer, you have to recycle
a rune in order to ready the unit that
you targeted. And if you're doing that
multiple times, you're recycling
multiple times. You're also hiding your
zonas, you're playing your charms,
you're playing like your Defiant Dances,
a lot of things that will recycle and
then you can just run out of gas.
>> And another thing that I kind of just
want to point out is this tide turner
here. It is a very interesting unit
because when you play it, you can choose
to uh you choose a friendly unit and
then you can move it to its location. So
if you're Ireelia, if your Stella is in
trouble, you've got this low cost, low
might unit that you can kind of just
sacrifice to make sure that you keep
your good units on the board.
>> Yeah, I love using this proactively. You
like send your Celicorn in, get the
draw, play the tide turner, swap spots,
and the Celicorn moved again. So you get
another draw, no longer at a
battlefield, so it's a little safer.
Yeah, Tide Turner is a classic. Uh what
my build of the the Aelia deck actually
looks very different from this one. I
have three Tide Turner. I like this card
that much. I think it's uh it it doesn't
feel that bad just playing it first.
Like you'd rather a G or um you know,
probably the the treasure hunter in my
build, but like still just getting a
unit out, it's fine. But I love two
energy cost units that are good at any
point in the game. You don't mind seeing
this turn one cuz it's just a guy. it
just goes in and scores a point. But you
also don't mind seeing this turn five or
turn 10, you know, like the later the
game goes, it still has uses, which I
think is like the mark of the really
really top tier two uh two energy units
especially. Uh and I think it's no
surprise that Tit Turner was also in the
top 16 most represented cards at the
event,
>> 100%. And another thing is you can hide
that card. So if you really want to do
like a little gotcha, you can do that
with tide turner. So very scor uh scary
game or scary card there. Um but uh I
also want to point out the amount of gas
that uh Ireelia can have in her deck.
You may have something to deal with one
but she's got so many that two in that
deck list with the two zonas. But if you
remember I mean you were also breaking
this down in the previous Draven match.
Annie's got a lot of stuff that bounces.
So like the rebuke say I don't care
about your guardian angel. I don't care
about your zonas. Like it's going back
to hand. So it could be an interesting
matchup.
>> You don't even have to what is it?
Salvage it. You you can just get it out
of there. Get the whole entire unit and
then you have to pay to get that Aurelia
back on the board by exhausting your
[music] your runes.
>> Does have to flex. You also have to pay
to bounce it back. Um and for a couple
of reasons, I slightly favor the Aurelia
in this matchup. I don't know what the
numbers are. Actually, I'd love it if we
could take a look at that. I I have it
from Leo, so once we get into the game,
I I'll look it up here to see what the
win rate was between these decks. Um
because my my head says it should be
slightly Aurelia favorite. The Annie
ways to deal with like what Aurelia is
doing. Um a lot of it's like targeting
and so you're paying that deflect cost
and also Aurelia with things like the um
discipline with the on guard with the
fiant dance. You can get over the ferris
4runners. You can get over a lot of the
stuff that Annie's playing out there.
The question is can Annie play fast
enough? Because a lot of times,
especially with these types of Aurelia
builds, when you're not on the treasure
hunters and you're not on as many lowc
cost units, you kind of see the early
game and you say maybe I'll score like a
point or two in the first like four or
five turns, but you're just really
scaling for that Aurelia to then play
around with that. Um, and if Annie with
like the Kai'Sa and the Noxis hopefuls
and like all these earlier game units,
the the merchants which were in there as
well, maybe the Annie just gets to the
point where you you have so much on the
field already, so many points by that
turn five when Aelia is like I guess
more like turn four when Aelia is coming
out. Um, that's that's a question. And
I'm hearing uh Aurelia had a 59% win
rate. Thank you Production for letting
me know there so I didn't have to look
it up. That is a pretty significant win
rate when you look at like how many
people are playing these decks um at
these events. So yeah, 59% I feel like
that that tracks with my expectation.
>> Absolutely 59% and we know that Ireelia
is just such a popular uh champion and
legend here. Um but yeah, no surprise to
us honestly.
>> A lot of times in these types of
matchups like it can be pretty close if
you both play the same speed. So it's up
to one deck to speed it up. Like if you
have a a losing matchup as the Annie,
like sometimes the only way to really
win that, and I experience this a lot as
a Jinx player. Uh [laughter] so that's
where a lot of this come from. You just
got to play fast. You just got to get in
there and score as much as you can.
Pressure your opponent cuz maybe they
just make a mistake or they mismanage
their resources. Especially easy to do
as the Aurelia.
>> Absolutely. And since we're speeding up
games, let's go ahead and speed up into
this game. And I do want to uh just uh
shout out this uh Annie. She is also
cosplayed as Annie.
>> That is awesome.
>> But a cute little fact here is she is
actually 15 years old, y'all. So, we've
got a young girly pop here in Atlanta,
Georgia, putting it down, holding it
down, not only for the girlies, but for
the youngies as well.
>> A new generation of gamers coming in
here to play Riftbound. Awesome to see.
And in cosplay, too. Like, this has got
to be one of the coolest moments. You're
cosplaying the the champion that you're
playing and you get to be on feature
match. happy that we get to see a
cosplayer. There's a lot of cosplayers
here playing also.
>> There are there's a lot.
>> Uh we've seen some sets and they look
amazing. So, shout out to all of the
cosplayers. As we get started here,
we're looking at our cards, seeing what
we want to mulligan.
And it looks like we're uh the Ireelia
is going to mulligan, too.
>> Aurelia deck has the Aurelia sleeves.
Look at that. To match
>> very Yeah, like the overnumbered legend,
the alt art for the
>> But Dana Fischer has the purple and red.
So it it kind of that's also I like
that.
>> You know what? I I love this.
>> Do you do that? Do you color code your
sleeves with your decks?
>> No, I just use whatever uh Riot gives
me, not going to lie. So I just rock
with that.
>> Okay. Must be nice. All right. Looks
like uh Johannes Fest is
>> I'm not confident on that one.
>> You got it.
>> You know, I said it and then right after
I was like I don't know if that's how
you say it. I'm just going to go
Johannes. Johannes going first here. Has
the uh two runes for the guardian angel.
Pretty good uh Aurelia start. I'd say
this is even ideal. like you're really
happy to just get your G out early and
then probably like a Stellicorn turn two
um if you're feeling confident and uh uh
put the G on it.
>> Absolutely. And we're going to uh go
ahead and exhaust our runes to play out
a Rexai right here early and we're going
to go ahead and channel two on the side
of uh Johan and we're going to draw one.
Looks like we're looking to do a uh
Desert's Call.
>> Okay. Is that is that what we're seeing
there? Yeah, Desert's Call. There we go.
Spells down. That will give us two sand
soldier tokens. Very efficient to turn
two as well. Now, this is where we see
does Dana want to go for the Well, no,
you won't go for the Annie here cuz
you're not going to get any value out of
the spell and the discard.
>> Yeah,
>> again, I was surprised to see that Rexai
in the Annie list. I'm excited to see
what the Dana decides to do with it,
though, because it's such a versatile
card for things like your legend coming
out and also the Ferris 4Runner. And
it's also just not a bad three, you
know, energy, three might. Like, it's
got assault one. Like stats wise, it's
it's not a bad unit on its own.
>> Absolutely. And it looks like it's going
to move in here to go ahead and get the
first point. And we're going to exhaust
two more to start stacking some units
over here.
>> And this is what Annie does best. You
get to play a lot of stuff and still
have a lot of runes up. You're ready to
at the end of every turn. So that is a
Noxful um plus the overzealous fan on
the battlefield with the Rex Eye. So
it's going to be really hard to take
that battlefield now for Johannes. Yeah,
we've only got those two might sand
soldiers on the board as of right now.
Um interested to see what is in his hand
for this next portion. Uh but uh Annie
is sitting pretty with three runes up
for right now. So we're kind of we're
kind of chilling.
>> You can always go in with a sand soldier
and just deal with the Overzel's fan cuz
either it crashes or you just like deal
like they have to kill the Overzel's fan
to then um bounce back to Sand Soldier.
Usually at that point, I think if you're
Dana, you would just accept that or
maybe you have like a spell in hand. Um,
but for a lot of reasons, I still like
it. It's like, yeah, I mean, you're not
doing much with these hand soldiers, so
just like get the interaction out.
That's something I talk about a lot.
I've talked about it earlier on the
stream. Just cuz your opponent has a uh
an answer doesn't mean that you can play
around it. Sometimes you just have to
chew through the answer so they don't
have it anymore.
>> Right. Exactly that. And it looks like
that's what we're thinking on here
through uh Johan. Uh, let's see here. Is
he going to move in with both or just
one? And we're picking up.
>> Both would be surprising unless you have
a defiant dance in hand or like a guard
or a discipline.
>> Oh, JK. We're bringing out the Ireelia
with the five runes exhausted. So, we're
going to see her out early. Uh, I'm
assuming we're going to equip the GM.
Honestly, I don't hate it cuz like uh
the overzealous fan if you target this
that you have to pay the deflect cost
and then the sand soldier still go in
and deal with the Rex eye as long as the
Andy doesn't have anything else. Now,
will we use the Aurelia legend to the
Aurelia? That will give us a lot of
information. Otherwise, you can also
just play the the passive route. I mean,
I keep saying like the ways to get onto
the battlefield. If you're the Aurelia,
sometimes you just want to play patient
and you can just send a sand soldier to
the seat of power and just get a point
and you know, pass there. And it looks
like that might be what Johannes does.
Yeah, I think we're also just going to
go ahead and get the point on the other
battlefield first. So, go ahead and get
that out of the way. And yeah, I'm also
curious to see if we ready here to give
her a little bit more might and also
move her.
>> Does it uh does it add up yet when I was
saying I'm not a very patient player.
I'm always like, "How do you deal with
the battlefield? Get him in there. Get
him off the battlefield." But nope. Uh
Johannes instead saying I'm going to
take the patient route. Not even sending
the sand soldier in to deal with the
overzealous fan. instead just keeping
the resource back at base and not
playing into the Annie three runes that
were up. So now it's over to Dana with
uh that look like seven runes.
>> Yes, we've got seven runes up. We're
shuffling through and we're going to
move the Noxis hopeful here. It looks
like maybe just
as some reinforcement or maybe we want
to Yes, we're going to take out that
sand soldier here on the seat of power.
Go ahead and get rid of that. Yes. And
that's going to be another point for
Dana.
>> And because you conquered Seed of Power
while holding the other battlefield, you
get to draw a card. So Dana, actually,
that was a very efficient turn. Johannes
didn't have anything. I was expecting at
least like an Ong Guard uh or a um
Defiant Dance, but neither one comes
out. So that's just pure card advantage
to Dana. The Annie is taking an early
lead here.
>> I love that. Shout out to my girl Dana.
Okay, period. Looks like a Ferris
4runner based on the runes. And there it
is. It has landed on the seed of power.
Ferris 4runner the bane of the format
right [laughter] now. This card is just
so strong.
>> Yeah, it kind of just takes over. It is
definitely a card to be feared, but also
um she's got quite a lot of units that
are starting to stack on this board.
Iselia going to be able to catch up?
We're going to go ahead and pass over to
Johan.
a lot of runes up. So, the Aurelia gets
an additional might every time you ready
her or target her with an ability. So,
there there's a lot of fun stuff you can
do with that, right? You can send her in
to the sunken temple, conquer, get the
draw, and then like target her with
something, ready her with your legend
passive, move her back, try and target
her again. And I guess at that point you
kind of need like a flash or something
to get the right movement. But like
there's ways to do this that you can
send her in, get the draw, and then also
get her back to the other battlefield
because you want to get her big enough
if the goal is to be aggressive for
Johannes to beat over 10 might plus
three runes uh visible, which
theoretically could be like a hex tech
ray, void seeker, rebuke, can be a lot
of stuff because Johannes obviously
doesn't know the um the deck list that
Dana's rocking right now.
>> Absolutely. So, we still got the three
runes up on the side of Annie
>> and uh yeah, you were talking about
patience one more time.
>> It's a scary thing seeing an Annie with
three runes up.
>> It is. It is. And I mean that's just the
nature of Annie. You always get those
two runes at the end of your turn. Um
but yeah, you were talking about
patience.
>> Oh, Boots of Swiftness is coming out.
Three runes exhausted for that. I'm
curious to see. Do we equip immediately?
>> Yeah, this is another one of one of the
ways you can do it. Looks like two
recycles, which I expect will be the
equip and legend cost to ready. Yep. So,
you target the Urelia with the swifties,
uh, which will give her plus one might,
and then you use your Aurelia legend,
which uh should currently be exhausted,
but looks like they're not doing it
right now. But, Blade Dancer, whenever
you choose a friendly unit, you may
exhaust me to pay the uh power cost and
ready it. So,
>> yep,
>> because it's ready, I'm assuming that
that was paid even though it's not
currently exhausted. And then that not
only targets your rally, but also
readies her. So, she gets the plus two
might total, meaning that she is
currently a 10. That is
>> that's a big on her. And then the plus
one from G and plus two from Swifties.
That is a big girl.
>> That is a big
>> How do you say Gor
>> That's a big ghoul.
>> I'm saying I feel like I'm not saying it
right.
>> You're doing great. You're doing great.
And just like this, Ireelia who is
moving over to start a showdown. And I'm
curious to see what uh our Annie is
going to respond with.
So this is the danger of the Aurelia
matchup is the rebuke is so strong cuz
it just gets through the G. But it's
early enough in the game that it's such
a hard deflect cost. Ooh, looks like
Dana's going to go fishing. Let's see
what we can get with the one exhausted
rune for this stacked deck.
I
>> really like this because whether you
already have the rebuke or not, it's
just an efficient use of your runes
while you have them. Let's see if Dana
has something. I'm looking for things
like rebuke. I'm looking for things like
um Ride the Wind, which can also just
kind of get you out of that and then
move over to the sunken temple.
>> Absolutely. It looks like maybe uh she
passed priority here and we're going to
tap. So that that was already exhausted.
So this is just correcting.
>> Gotcha. Okay. Just wanted to make sure
there.
>> So it's Johannes's priority again and
he's going to ong guard. So initially it
would would have been a crash. Uh and
Dana gave another action window to
Johannes. Interesting that Johannes
didn't go for the on guard right away.
>> Instead waits a little bit.
>> All right. So we've got the plus five,
the plus one, and we're going to flash.
>> That's another good one. It was that or
ride the wind or rebuke. Those are the
big three. Um, and he has so many of
these two energy spells that make full
use of the passive.
>> Yes. And so that's just going to save
those two units so that they don't die.
And then uh we're going to get the point
going over to Johan.
>> And now that means that with a couple
runes up, Johan is actually going to go
for a hidden. And uh this is still, I
think, a pretty good spot for Dana to be
in. You have the sunken temple to draw
with the ferris 4runner and just so many
units. And you didn't um decelerate your
runes at all. you still have all of your
runes available for big swings later.
>> Absolutely. And I think we've got a
hidden card here on that uh seat of
power. So, not sure what could be hidden
here, but you know, interested to see
later. It could be that tide turner that
we were uh talking about earlier. So, if
this does get into trouble, we can just
pop that on up. Well, funnily enough,
the tide turner would only be
reinforcing with two might because you
swap plays with the Urelia and it's
still in the same location.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> So, I'm expecting something like a zonas
potentially as the hitting card there.
But here we go. Ferris for is going into
the sunken temple and that will get an
extra draw for Dana.
>> Love that. So, she's going up to four
points to the three. Just really
stacking points here. moving carefully
and the Rex side looks like she's going
to move over to this Aurelia.
>> So that is a three might plus assault
one so that's four might and we are
playing the Rengar reaction speed can
play to a battlefield that you are
currently attacking.
>> Yes. So uh that is going to be a total
of six might uh coming over to seat of
power.
>> Uh five might from Rex
>> is that five from Rexi. So, so Rex size
3+ 1 is four and Rengar's 3+ 2 is five.
So, it's nine total might that will be
attacking. And there it is. The
>> And there's the zas. Yep.
>> So, you don't even have to waste the the
GA at all. You just get to move back to
base and that zas is going to be
discarded.
>> You'll also be able to take one of these
units with it. The Aurelia was a seven,
so you can take out either one. I would
probably assume the Rexi because they
defend at the same Yeah, they defend the
same strength, but the Rexi is a little
more versatile in what it can do on the
field. And uh yeah, I'm actually so
Dana's scoring points and that's a scary
thing in the Annie match up because
despite the fact Aurelia is already
trying to take control of the board,
Annie doesn't really care what the
current position Dana's in.
>> But the same can be said that Johannes
has kind of the Aurelia setup. You still
have GA on Aurelia and now you're going
to have six runes to play with on your
turn. That's a lot of resources that
Aurelia can play with. It is. I'm not
sure how many cards we have in hand at
the moment, but that tide turner comes
out and we're going to swap positions.
Maybe a little bit here to see if uh we
can bring the Ireelia out to play on the
next uh goround. But then we're going to
move that overzealous fan over to the
seat of power. And we're
>> Yeah. Sorry, what?
>> Oh, I was just going to say we're going
to ready those two runes at the end of
Annie's hand and we're going to pass the
turn.
Interesting to see the Ferris 4runner
hit by the tie turner instead of the
Rengar. Typically, I would think you
save the Rengar because it has assault.
So, it's a little more valuable
attacking than defending. And if Ferris
4Runner dies, you still get the mech
anyway. Um, but Dana, I think, is
playing for more of a long game here
because saving the Ferris to me says,
I'm going to use the six might more
efficiently than the five might of the
Rengar. And I'll still have the death
nail later on to play more of a grindy
game versus the Aurelia. But Aelia is
still going to go in on the tide turner.
>> Yep. And uh she's going to win that
battle. So that's going to be a conquer
for Johan. And then we're drawing. Let's
see what is next in store. I'm trying to
get a peek at that hand there.
>> Yeah, you're usually really good
[laughter] at spotting these. Have you
seen anything?
>> I'm trying to get a peek. No,
everybody's holding their cards so close
to chess. They said, um, Megan, you are
not seeing nothing. So,
>> can we get the table judges? Hey, can
you tell them [laughter] to hold a board
about 6 in? Um, so we're just thinking
here and the fizz comes out. So with
fizz coming out, you have to uh uh
exhaust three and recycle one purple
rune. Uh you are able to play a spell
from your trash.
>> Um with three energy or less
>> with three energy.
>> But still there's a lot of options. I'm
thinking like what does he play? The the
uh Desert's Call is a big one right now.
You won't be able to repeat cost it, but
you could at least just get another unit
out. Um, I think what the other spells
are that Johannes has played.
>> Boots of swiftness is on the board. So
maybe we on guard and we make and I do
see that that was just recycled. Uh,
yeah. So uh, possibly moving that boots
of swiftness uh, Ireelia over and we're
going to gank into the Rengar and the
overzealous fan while keeping that sand
soldier on the sunken temple. This will
surely like force an interaction from
Dana whether it's the overzealous fan or
something in hand because if you just
let this go that's another point to
Johannes and you get the draw from the
seat of power and there's the rebuke
>> and there's the rebuke. We're going to
exhaust two runes and recycle them just
to go ahead and make sure.
>> And also the fleck cost recycle as well.
So rebuke that's an expensive rebuke.
>> Ooh,
>> it looks like Did we defy? We did. We
did.
>> It's not so fast I think. Yeah, it's
tough because Johannes's um trash pile
is currently kind of off screen, but I
think that's a not so fast. So, really,
really heads up play from Dana having
the right resources to deal with.
>> Yes, making sure that she has that hard
bargain. If you really want to counter
something, Boo, you going to have to pay
me. Okay.
>> Hey, look at that. The top three most
represented cards were all on the table
at the same time. [laughter] We had
Ferris, 4Runner, Rebuke, and Hard
Bargain.
>> Yes. No, I love to see it. Obviously,
we're going to see those cards a lot
this weekend. Uh they were like what
over 500 uh instances or over 500 decks.
>> I think over 600 with Ferris World.
>> Yeah, over 600. And there we are. We're
going to see that Noxis hopeful yet
again really stacking these units on the
seed of power. Uh starting to get kind
of heavy also on the sunken temple.
We've exhausted quite a few uh runes.
We've got one left up, but we're going
to again. Noxis hopeful. Dana said, "If
you going to come for me, baby, you
going to have to come correct."
>> Dana has played this very, very well. Uh
I This is a dominant position. Johannes
is going to have to clear both
battlefields with a Fizz, GA, and
Swifties, and you don't even have uh I
guess you have enough to play the
Aurelia like theoretic. No, he's just
going to go. Yeah, I was I was trying to
think through I'm like you can equip to
the Fizz, try and clear one, and then
like play the Aurelia and try and ready
it, but like man, that's an expensive
turn. So, we're going to game number
two. Well done, Dana Fischer picking up
game one in a tough matchup. That's a
59% win rate for the Aurelia.
>> Yeah, honestly, I love to see it. You
know, like you may think because uh
she's so young, maybe she doesn't know
how to play this TCG, but no, she's
proven that she can handle it right now.
And I love to see it. She came out
swinging. Like that wasn't a passive
game for her. She was ready. She pulled
the tippers out.
>> Yeah, she pulled [laughter] everything.
The tippers is literally on the table.
>> That's awesome. Tippers is taking a look
at her hand. Maybe giving some advice of
like a keep that one. Maybe uh maybe
recycle [laughter] that one for game
number two.
>> Isn't that cheating? We need to get that
tippers out of here.
>> Not if we can't prove that it's talking.
I feel like only Annie can hear the
tippers in the lore. So,
>> have you seen her tippers?
>> I I have. It was right there actually.
Yeah, I that one I can't answer yet.
[laughter]
>> Um All right. Zon Warren's up next for
the Annie versus Raven Bloom
Conservatory. Honestly, Annie likes both
of these. Uh Aurelia kind of likes both
these two just cuz the Zon Warren can
help you get towards your gas and your
zonius a little faster, but as we saw
Annie has access to Rebuke um doesn't
really care about those uh you know
death protection gears.
>> I was really interested to see if the
Ireelia player was going to recycle. I
saw that he had two defiant dances in
hand. A not so fast. I think there was a
discipline or a defy. It's one of those.
Uh, but he did end up mullying two and
we're going to tap two immediately and
bring in that tide turner.
>> There he is. And this is what I was
saying like it's not ideal. You have
better um two energy units that you
typically want to play turn one, but it
doesn't feel bad just getting a guy out
there either way. So, uh, and another
red Rex eye. Okay, so Dana showed us
that Rexi you don't even need to use the
ability for it to be an effective card.
Like maybe I was just overlooking the
stat efficient uhness of this. It's just
three energy and overcycle that can
accelerate and has a soul. That's
actually a very versatile card and uh
Dana's just happy to play it going
second.
>> Absolutely. Now we are going to go ahead
and get the first score for the Ireelia.
Um and uh with that tide turner uh
sitting on Raven Bloom, I'm curious to
see is Rexi going to go in or yes, just
conquer the other battlefield a little a
little safer. Not sure what uh
Johan has in store.
>> You can also uh just see more of your
deck as the Annie player and you're not
giving the Aurelia the potential of just
basically drawing a free card with that
rain conservatory. Also, not even
accelerating this Kai'Sa. Typically, I'd
think you accelerate the Kai'Sa, send it
into that tide turner, but with so many
runes already on Johannes's side, Dana
is playing a very patient game here. I
actually like this disrespecting, nope,
it's not my time to swing.
>> We'll wait till later.
>> Absolutely. We're going to get another
hold point for Johan. And uh yeah, as
you said, it's it's a very respectful
like she you can tell she knows when to
play aggressive, but she also knows
like, okay, we see all of these runes up
on the Aurelia side. There's so much
that could be in hand. The defiant
dance, you have the disciplines, you
have the on guards, and that Stella is
finally making her debut. Four runes,
exhausted, and we're going to pass over
to Dana. And now this is a much easier
opportunity for an Andy to say, "Okay,
only two runes available now. I might be
more comfortable to go with it. Before
when it's four, it's like h it's kind of
scary." Um, but at this point, I think
you have a little more confidence to
say, "I'm going to hold for a point and
then can send this Kai into the tide
turner." Doesn't mean that Aurelia won't
have answers. It just means that they
won't have access to as many, especially
if you have something like a hard
bargain for their Defiant Dance or their
Ong Guard.
>> Exactly. And uh curious to see we've
going we're going to exhaust for Oh,
we're exhausting everything. Recycling.
>> Oh,
>> mind spplitter. Lock the freak in. Mind
spplitter comes out to play.
>> Incredibly [snorts] high value card
right now. You play it on Rune Curve.
You get to see every card in Johannes's
hand, which he's been holding on to a
lot. And you get to get rid of any of
the threats. He's going to have to have
multiple threats. It looks like Defiant
Dance. We didn't actually see.
It looks like he was maybe showing them
>> defying. Oh, yeah.
>> Oh, he's reacting with the fy dance.
That makes sense. Okay, so it's a
reaction speed spell. He's going to use
it now in response to the mindslitter's
effect, giving the Kaisa minus two, and
I'm assuming tide turner plus two. And
now we get to see. Okay, so we've got
the not so fast, we've got the defiant
dance, we've got the flash, and we've
got the Vex. Um, a five might unit. But
what are we going to choose, Miss Dana?
>> With two runes up, actually one rune up.
Yeah, I think getting now knowing that
Yiannis only has one defined dance for
the rest of the game makes things very,
very easy for Dana going forward. You're
almost never going to lose combat versus
this. The only problem is that the Kaisa
is not going to be able to clear this
tie turner and the uh the Stellicorn
Herder with the flash still in hand can
basically get two draws guaranteed if
Johannes wants to spend the runes for
it, which basically means one of the
biggest strengths of mind spplitter is
not just the fact you get rid of a card,
but you get information.
>> Yes.
>> And then Stellorn starts doing Stellorn
things. You're like, what happened to
all my information? Like now there's so
many more cards that I don't even know
about anymore. So you kind of lose that
advantage. But I think it's still a good
spot to be in regardless for Dana having
also just a seven might unit. But here
we go
>> leaving the the battlefield to allow the
Celicorn to go in.
>> Yes. And that's going to be another
point over to Johan.
>> This also signals to me because Dana
backs the Rex eye off of the point.
Gives the free point to Johannes.
Johannes can probably operate with
information that Dana doesn't have a lot
to stop Johannes for pushes right now
with the hand. I guess there's no um uh
chaos runes being shown. So things like
Rebuke are definitely offline. Things
like um Ride the Wind are offline. So
maybe that's where Dana's hesitation's
coming in, but um having to play a much
more passive game early as the Annie and
allowing the Aelia to get ahead in
points is really good for the Aurelia.
Like Johannes is now in a very solid
spot.
>> Absolutely. And we're going to see that
Vex come out right now. So we're
exhausting that five uh those five runes
and we're recycling one to pay those
costs. And I think we're going to pass
turn over to Dana. Let's see what she
does here.
>> Keeping the tide turner out at the Raven
Bloom Conservatory to me says Johannes
does not want to save the unit. Wants to
try and get a spell off the top of the
deck by defending. Remember that. Oh,
actually now that think about it, the
flash is still in hand. So you can also
just like if they attack Turner first,
save both and still get the draw. So I
think if you're Dana, you if you read
that play, you need to go in for the
Stellicorn Herter first.
>> And I think that's what we're about to
do. So
>> Dana knew it before I did. Yeah,
exactly. The mind spplitter goes in to
uh Z's warrants and we're going to start
a showdown with the Stella or the and
that's just going to
>> flash will move him back. Yep.
>> Yep.
>> Now, there was the option to leave the
tide turner to try and greed for a spell
cuz like tie turner at this point
doesn't do much for you, but Johannes is
still saying, "Nope, I'm just going to
keep the unit. I'd rather have the
guaranteed card rather than try and fish
for a spell."
>> Absolutely. So that flash is no longer
in the inventory of what we saw during
the mind spawn.
>> Yeah. So is Vex. So like now think about
it. There's like no information.
>> Exactly. So we're moving in that Kai'Sa.
We're going in a little bit blind, but
we're also going in confident cuz
there's no runes up on the side of West.
So there's no response that can really
be done here.
>> Oh, you switched up that time. You
>> I did. I I I really think I'm messing up
his name and I don't want to be
disrespectful. That's why I feel like
Johannes that I I'm pretty confident on
that one.
>> Mr. Fest, [laughter]
>> Mr. Fest,
>> we're gonna have to make sure that
Barrett asks him this time.
>> Yeah,
>> we didn't get the the Thunder or 60
Thunder. [laughter] I forget which one.
That one was round two. But um here's
Annie passing turn. This is a very solid
board state right now. Both battlefields
controlled. Seven might on one, 10 might
on the other. One of which is Ferris
4runner. But the Vex is dangerous. Vex
when she is in combat means that all of
your spells cost one power less and one
energy less to a minimum of one.
Meanwhile, your opponent's spells cost
one more of both categories. So, if Dana
wants to do like a rebuke, you have to
tap all three and then recycle three.
>> That's really painful. Vex cheerless is
a powerhouse of a mid-range unit and
Aurelia can take very very strong
advantage of this. Yeah, that's a scary
thing to do as an Annie is to have to
face this Vex cheerless. Um,
we've got all runes up on Mr. Fest side.
We're we're kind of thinking here of
what
course of action we want to do against
these uh mighty units that are on the
board. And it looks like Stella and Vex
might be taking a trip. Where are we
going? And typically in in states like
this, you kind of want to move the
Celicorn first to get the draw cuz that
gives you more information for how you
want to play the rest of your turret.
So, we're going to threaten the mind
spplitter right now. This is already
enough might to clear the mind
spplitter. Now, will Johannana pass
priority? Cuz if you let this Vex die,
I mean, I guess it served a purpose.
>> And it looks like priority is passed.
We're tapping that three. We're
recycling that one. And we're going to
flash
and the mindsplitter back to our base. I
actually like this from Dana. You're
saving uh a a unit that will get you
advantage in a draw if it conquers and
just a big seven might unit. Sometimes
Aelia can struggle um to like how spend
its resources to get it stuff out on the
field and also have resources then to
fight these big units. The problem right
now is that Johannes has control of one
battlefield, has another unit ready to
go and a lot of runes up. So there's a
chance that Johannes can still make this
work regardless. Yes, it's really
exciting to see. Uh, but also how Dana,
she knew she had that flash in store.
She was kind of just like, "Yeah, come
over here." I'm just going to move these
units back to my base to make sure that
we stay safe and sound.
>> Discard the second Stellicorn for these
on Warren to get another draw. And here
we go. Boots and swifties. This is a big
one cuz we can equip this to Vex. Ready
the Vex. Send the Vex in the ferris
4runner. Dana is tapped out. That will
be seven might on six. And already that
is enough to clear it. And a Vex that
seven might is even scarier especially
with ganking because no battlefield's
safe now.
>> Yeah, exactly. So, uh it looks like we
are going to trigger and yes,
>> Raven Bloom Conservatory did not find a
spell. So, no plus one for Dana, but um
that's a Rexi down.
>> Unfortunate.
And uh it it's okay cuz we're going to
get those two three might mech tokens
played to base. So the might is
essentially still on the board. It's
just not at a battlefield. So that's
going to be another point scored.
Another conquer uh for the Vex. And uh
Mr. Fest has uh a couple of runes still
up. You got to stop laughing at me.
>> I just I I think it's so funny that
we're both just choosing a different
half of the name.
>> Yeah. I'm just I
>> Are you sure it's not Foo?
>> Oh man. I I I truly hope not as we stack
this uh tide turner's uh might on the
Vex down here on the Raven Bloom
Conservatory.
>> Interesting. I guess you know if there's
like a rebuke preemptively before
combat, this means that you at least get
the hold or the the defend uh trigger of
Raven Bloom Conservatory. Uh it's going
to come down a lot to what Johannes has
in hand. The only thing that is still
known from that mindslitter was a not so
fast. I believe that that was also in
hand with the Vex, with the flash, and
with the Defiant Dance that was then
discarded. So, the uh Celicorn has
completely reset the hand, and now Dana
is going to be operating with only one
known piece of information. And boom,
Desert's Call is going to be played. So,
we're going to get those two or the Sand
Soldier played to uh stack some more
might onto the Raven Bloon. Uh but three
uh runes still up on the side of Fes.
So, uh, Dana's going to channel her two
runes, draw for turn, and let's see if
we can clear cuz we've got to clear at
least one.
>> Going to dig a little for a stacked
deck.
Now, we have so much might on the field
right now. I think we can I think just
mathematically, uh, Dana can already
clear the battlefield. It's just going
to come down to what interaction
Johannes has in hand. The problem is
Dana like Johannes could just flash
stuff back. The fact that he committed
so much to Raven Bloom Conservatory
makes me think he's probably not going
to do that. Yeah. Um but uh it's going
to be hard to hold. I like this. Sends
the Kai'Sa into the Cellicorn. Very
efficient use of the Kai'Sa.
>> Yep. And Stella is going to just die.
We're not even going to fight there.
That showdown resolves rather quickly.
So Dana's going to go up to five points
here
>> and
>> trigger the Kai'Sa to draw and then
trigger the ZH. That's correct
sequencing there.
>> Lovely. Love, love a rule follower. Love
that.
>> Just efficiency really cuz like you
always want to see that additional card
before you make the decision of what to
discard with the Zon Warren. So again,
yeah, Dana's played a very clean game.
Both of these players have played very
clean games so far. I haven't noticed
anything that I'm like, "Oh, that was
odd." Uh other than maybe like again the
um the tide turner for the uh affairs
4Runner instead of the Rengar, but
again, we got value out of the Ferris
4Runner. Like it was able to do a lot
later on. So, we are going to exhaust
one rune and we're cleaving.
And it looks like we're going to send
the Rex eye, the mind spplitter, and a
mech token in for a showdown.
>> And I think that Dana targeted the mech
token with the cleave. It looked like
that. Yep, there we go. So, mech tokens
six plus seven on mine spplitter, that's
13 plus four on Rex side, that's 17. We
do have a Oh, okay. So, so he's defended
with the Raven Bloom Conservatory and
just flipped a rebuke. That's a really
strong spell. Focus is now for Dana.
Does Dana want to use anything here with
priority?
Passing it, I think. I just heard Dana
say.
>> And we're going to
recycle one.
>> So, Rebuke would tap two, recycle two.
But, oh, I know. Vex is in combat,
right? I I missed the Vex under the tide
turn. So Vex means that Rebuke is only a
one recycle one and then with three
runes up, you have to zap all three and
recycle one for the hard bargain. Will
Johannes
>> spend two to counter that?
>> Okay, so it looks like we tapped one for
discipline.
>> So the rebuke did not go off. It did get
countered. Yes,
>> but we're still using the Vex ability to
make your spells cheaper. Discipline
went to one energy cost in combat with
Vex. So that's going to give plus two to
that Vex it looks like. And
>> this is 13 on 13.
>> Yeah, these both of these uh all of the
units might just dissipate here.
>> Yeah, Vex is five plus two from boots
plus two from the discipline. That's
nine. And then two on tie turns 11. Two
on the sand soldiers 13. And if my math
was correct earlier, oh wait, no, no, it
was 17. It was only 13 from mind
spplitter and the the mech because of
the uh the cleave. So, it will clear
everything but the mech token. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> Really efficient from Dana there.
>> Yes. So, that's going to be an
additional point for Dana here. And we
need to pick up those boots. Yep. Boots
were made for walking and that's just
what they'll do back to base.
>> I don't think the mech steals them. That
would be very [laughter] funny though.
>> That would be um we
>> What's a mech need with boots? You know.
>> Oh, it looks like we're recycling a rune
and we're hiding a card over on the side
of ZH.
And we're going to ready those two runes
at the end of the turn. Um,
>> hiding.
>> It could be a tie turner. Didn't she
also have a tie turner in?
>> Uh, I would imagine the tie turner would
be hidden the Riven Bloom Conservatory
to try and save the Kai'Sa.
>> Uh, you mean the mech the Kai'Sa is
>> Oh, I see you switch. Yeah, exactly. You
can't swap with the Kai'Sa currently.
But so so that makes me think maybe it's
not unless you're just trying to
reinforce for six might there. But it
could be other things theoretically like
edge of knight. Um two runes ready up.
So you can also go for things like long
sword here. So this vex is being played.
This is a second Oh wait, no. Yeah. No,
this
>> is the second Vex. Yeah. So we're going
to uh t uh exhaust five runes and
recycle one to bring out another Vex.
And we're going to go ahead and ready
her and equip those boots of swiftness.
move in for that mech. And uh we were
looking for a spell, but no luck there.
So that mech token will die. Oh, unless
>> I mean Dana might still have something
else. It's going to be an expensive
spell and combo in it.
>> Yep, that mech token is gone.
>> Now, that was an expensive turn for
Johannes. You have to recycle a power to
play the Vex. You have to recycle a
power to equip the boots. You have to
recycle a power to ready the Vex with
the Aurelia Legend. Three recycled. And
wait, was that a another Oh, we charm.
Ooh.
>> Oh, and switcheroo.
Of [laughter] course, they never expect.
>> Yeah, I knew some switching was about to
be done uh with that hidden card. And so
switching.
>> Oh jeez.
>> So when you use charm, you're making
your opponent the attacker. So you're
defending a Raven Bloom. So you trigger
the Raven Bloom.
>> He just got an on guard right there with
one rune up. Johannes is in a dominating
position right now.
>> That is mad tough. So, we have six
points on the side of Dana, seven points
on the side of Wes, and um it's not over
though cuz we still have Annie Stubborn.
So, uh Dana could play Annie, get the
rebuke back, rebuke the Vex. We know
that there is an out currently in play.
Just known information. Dana has the
ability, but can you get in with two
units to score and win? Yeah, we don't
have enough to like ride the wind on top
of that. I I don't think that Dana can
win this turn, but you can at least deal
with the Vex.
>> Yes. And it looks like she's fishing
through her recycled bin here, right? Or
uh trash bin right now. Uh just kind of
take count of what we've got. And yeah,
that is four runes ex uh exhausted. And
we're going to bring out that Annie.
>> There she is. the namesake, the
cosplayer.
>> Stubborn.
>> Oh.
>> Oh, we're bringing out a stack deck.
We're going fishing.
>> Maybe maybe there wasn't a rebuke
because I know Johannes rebuked and I
know that Dana did game one. Maybe Dana
hasn't rebuked game two.
>> I might have had the wrong read there.
>> Maybe for that rebuke.
>> Yeah, we'll wait to see what Dana does
following up here.
All right, we're moving in to get that
seventh point on the side of Dana and it
looks like that is secured. So, we're
seven to seven now. Um, but it's a very
scary place cuz we do not want this Vex
to hold for that eighth point.
>> And it looks like that's game.
>> Yeah, the fact that uh Dana did not grab
a rebuke makes me think that she just
didn't have one in the into trash. I
think that that was something that was
spilled over my brain from game number
one. And also the fact that Johannes had
played one. Uh, I don't believe Dana had
actually played one in that game cuz
otherwise I think that was the uh the
line you go down there. So, well played
by Johannes bringing us to a game number
three.
>> Yes, I love it. A lot of uh
competitiveness right here. You know,
you're never fully out of a match until
the game ends. So, we're going to game
three. Let's see what happens.
>> Really good battlefields for Dana. Yeah,
>> Arena's greatest going first means that
the game's going to be accelerated,
especially against an Aurelia who I
honestly play Aspirin's climb because I
want the game to go longer as Aelia. You
want time to kind of scale up all of
your gears and such. Um, and Annie wants
to play a faster game. You also get the
Zon Warren, which you were playing game,
too. So, you get a some draw engine and
you get a faster game and you get to go
first. I think Dana is in a really good
spot already just before even a single
card has been played.
>> All right. Right. And it looks like
she's mulligating one. And it looks like
Ireelia is satisfied with the hand. So I
think we're about to get started. We're
channeling two runes and we're drawing
for turn and any two costs. It looks
like yes, the overzealous fan does come
out to play. So we're passing the turn
to fest, channeling three runes, uh
exhausting all three, and we're going to
go ahead and play a boots of swiftness.
So there it will be some ganking here
shortly. We're passing the turn
>> and Johannes and Dana should both be at
one point right now because of arena's
greatest. So we'll get that updated here
shortly on the screen. Um but this will
be then two points for Dana as that
overzealous fan will go into a
battlefield. And again you just go into
the Z warren because arena's greatest
doesn't do anything. You just save that
for maybe Kai'Sa to get draws off of but
you're just happy to loop the Z warren
as much as you can.
>> Absolutely. I think they're getting the
>> the uh points figured out here because
of the uh battlefield.
So, it might just take a second here.
>> So, Arena's Greatest is one of those
ones that you have to declare at the
start of your beginning phase. I clearly
heard Dana do it. I did not hear
Johannes do it. So, there's a chance
that that might be what the judge calls.
It's all speculation. I don't know. I'm
just trying to like gauge it based on
some body language there. And I clearly
saw Dana point to the uh arena's
greatest and I think like move a die on
the side. I did not see the same from
Johannes. So if that's the call that's
tough, but may maybe that's what's
happening.
>> I do remember playing in a nexus night
and somebody was like you have to call
it if you want it. And uh maybe it
wasn't called. That might just be a free
point for Dana possibly going to two
unless she wants to let Fes I guess just
get the point. But I don't even know if
that's something that you'd want to do.
>> Oh, it looks like a little bit of uh
upsetness over on the side of West. I'm
not going to lie. He might just be
missing out on that point.
>> A pressure moment right here. And your
your X1 going X2 will get you to day
two, but I don't think it's going to get
you to a top eight. Um
>> saying out loud all like that stuff.
>> Yeah, that's a little frustrating. I'm I
I'm I bet Diana Diana is in her uh in
her mind like, "Yeah, I got that point."
[laughter]
>> I made I think it's a tough situation
often. Um I mean, it's it's obviously a
different, you know, setup when you're
at like a locals versus Nex the regional
like this is a big
>> especially when you're X1 at the
regional. We're having the judge chat
with Johannes off uh off on cam, I
guess, but off to the side right there.
and uh just a high pressure, high stress
moment for for everybody on the stage
right now. But again, I just want to go
back to the point that Dana's playing
this matchup very well when it is a 59%
win rate for Aurelia based on the Leil
stats. Our producer looked into it. It
was a my gut said it's Aurelia favorite
as well. And I don't think Johannes has
been playing like
>> bad in any way. Nothing he's done has
been like that was confusing or like I
obviously don't know everything in his
hand so I don't know like what exactly I
would do in the in his shoes. But like
it's all made sense to me. Absolutely.
Dana is just playing around it really
well.
>> Yes, you can tell she she she's probably
studied this matchup because there are
so many out here on the field. There's a
lot.
>> Second most popular.
>> So, she probably knows, okay, do I need
to be a little bit more patient here? Do
I need to move in more aggressively?
I've got this, this, this in my hand. I
think I'm free to do whatever I really
want to on this board. And he's playing
that very well.
>> Yeah. And uh again, the patience is
something I always like to highlight
anytime the the players on stage
represent this because there's the human
element to the feature match stream.
That's something that a lot of folks at
home that watch along, they don't m
maybe they don't fully appreciate. I'm
sure a lot of people do appreciate it,
but some might just be like, "Oh, like
why are they doing that?" Or like, "Oh,
why are they doing that?" But then you
have to realize like the lights are on
you, the cameras are on you, like you're
away from the table. It's a much more
quiet environment, which some people
like, some people don't. So it's like a
I think the pressure buildup means that
you see more misplays on feature matches
than you than the the players would do
if they were just playing on the tables.
And that's kind of the give and take.
It's fun to be on feature match, but
it's also a stressful situation. So,
whenever players uh show that they're
patient, that they're taking their time
and that they're actually playing with a
lot of like um you know, respect for the
answers their opponents can have, I
always like to highlight that because I
think that that's something that can be
hard to do. It's easy to lose track of
that when you're in the the stressful
situation, but so far Dana has played a
very calm-headed game
>> and even in this moment seems calm in
the seat right now. So, let's see. Uh
hopefully we'll have an answer soon from
the judges as to what the current game
state is. I'm going to assume Dana will
have one point, Johannes will have zero
when we come back, but I'm not the
judge, so don't take my word for it.
We'll see once we get back into the
game.
>> What I am going to use that angle is to
look at his hand. He had a GA in hand.
So when we do see that Aurelia finally
come out, there will be some protection
on the board.
>> But I want to say because now we are
seeing that it's zero points for
Johannes at this current game state. Uh
just to kind of highlight the tough hole
that he's dug himself into right now cuz
already you're not in a good spot when
you're tied in points at this point in
the game. Um let alone, you know, like
it now being a point behind cuz Dana is
about to score another one here. That's
going to put Dana to two points.
Johannes has no units on the field and
what can try and mount a to come back
but it it it can be tough. Again, the
pressure of the moment can be a lot.
>> Now, it's very crucial as well that he
does not let this little setback here
deter the entire game. He needs to make
sure he locks in, he stays focused
because just because she's up two points
doesn't mean the game is over. The game
is over.
>> You can mount a comeback.
>> Exactly. The game is over at eight
points. Okay. So, there's still six more
that have to be obtained. So, there's
still a possibility. Uh, Boots of
Swiftness already on the board. Like I
said, there is a GA in hand, so it's
possible that some ganking can be done.
Two points can be gotten in uh a single
round if uh time permits. I'm
>> trying to peek at Dana's hand right
there. It looks like there's a flash and
a hard bargain that I saw.
>> Yeah.
>> Can't quite make out the rest. Oh, is
that a switch?
>> There's a switcheroo in there, too.
>> Oh, that card [laughter] is terrifying.
Yes, it
>> let me tell you it is um not so
fastable. You can't uh defy it, but you
can not so fast. Uh and you can hard
bargain which has access to both of. So
um Johannes can still play around it. Um
but man, that card I swear I've won many
locals because I hide it and people are
just forget it exists. They're like
that's not fight or flight. That's
banned now. What could it be? And then
they attack and they're like switcheroo.
Like something about that card. You just
kind of forget it exists. So, we're
going to establish the Aurelia and then
put the Swifties on it, but not ready
it.
>> Exactly. We're just going to pass that
turn over. So, Dana is going to go up to
those three points after we handle those
runes. Draw for turn. And it looks like
we're going to exhaust.
Hearing from production that we're
adding 5 minutes as well for the judge
call. So, um that 1224 on your screen
right now will be a 1720
currently. uh once those five minutes
get added. So, we're going to go for the
accelerate Kai'Sa.
>> Absolutely. We're going to accelerate
that Kai'Sa to go ahead and score on the
other battlefield and we're going to
draw off of that Kai'Sa as well because
when she conquers, she gets to draw one.
We're passing turn. We're going to ready
those two runes for Annie and we're
going to awaken on the side of Fles.
Because of the ready, we get to give
plus one to that Ireelia. And now we're
going to start for real.
>> Now, it's game time. Let's see what
Johannes can do. There's three runes up
for the Annie. Rebuke is still your
enemy, but you have not so fast. You
have hard bargains. Both of which will
stop it. We're going to go into the
overzealous span first with three runes
up from Annie. We're just checking here.
What do we want to do? How do we want to
respond?
>> And it's looking like we are going to
overzealous. Oh. Oh, no. We We passed.
We're gonna flash that back to base.
>> Oh, we're flashing both.
>> I like it because again then you get a
re-trigger the Kaisa Conquer on the
arena's greatest or um yeah, Arena's
greatest or if uh Johannes finds a way
to like gank that Aelli over then you go
on to the zon which is even better.
>> Exactly. So, um we're actually going to
Desert's Call here.
>> We're discarding it with those on
Warren.
>> Oh, we're discarding it. I see. Okay.
>> And we're going to figure out what we
want to do in this situation.
I would like to see uh Ireelia uh
rereadied and moved over to the other
side for those additional points. Kind
of get back into the game here. Yeah.
>> Uh see what Fest is thinking.
>> The one positive of this position
Johannes is in is he has not de
accelerated his runes very much. That's
again one of the big dangers like you
played the Aelia and it survived and he
doesn't have a lot of ways to like deal
with an Aelia just back in base. Um, and
now with a G, the Aelia is going to be
even safer.
>> Let's see if Johannes wants to ready the
Aurelia or if you just hold it at those
on Warren.
>> Yeah, I'm curious to see as well after
attaching that GA. It looks like we're
shuffling through our cards just to
think. Yeah, we're going to get that
counter to go up because we did choose
Ireelia with the GA. So, she does get
that additional might off of that and
we're going to farm in. That's big for
Johannes. They're slowing down the draw
power. The Kai'Sa will die here. Will
not get the draw off the conquer on the
arena's greatest.
>> I mean, Dana is still going to be fine
in points. So, like Johannes hasn't
solved that issue yet. But dealing with
the threats on the board is kind of step
number one.
>> Exactly. So, we're going to pass our
turn after that. So, uh Dana is going to
go ahead and channel those two runes.
Draw for turn. And uh we do have an open
battlefield over here. Does she want to
use that instead? We're going to Oh, is
that a mine spplitter coming out? How
many rooms did we just
>> It looks like it. Yeah, that's seven.
Uh,
>> seven in recycling, too. There it is.
>> Yep, there it is. The mindsplitter does
come out to play. Big might unit. And
then what we're going to do is we're
going to reveal the hand. Yep, we see a
flash. We see a we see a charm. We see a
not so fast. And we get to discard a
card from this hand. strong in here.
>> Yeah. I don't know. I mean, my my gut
says rebuke, but that's a really strong
hand cuz like if if uh Johannes is able
to flip a a green rune here, you can
always like charm and then I guess we
don't have a way to buff the Aurelia
currently, but Aurelia is what, six,
seven, then eight. No, don't do it.
She's eight when she ready. Eight when
she readies on uh at the start of
Johannes's turn. So, just charm is
already enough to deal with the mind
spplitter. Yeah, but it is still the
rebuke. I I feel like that's what I
would do too, but that's tough. That
that that's a scary hand to look at
there. Johannes might still be in this.
>> Yes. And I mean, but now Dana has that
intel. She also has another point here.
And we're hiding a card now. We do know
she had that switcheroo in hand earlier,
so I'm just going to assume that's what
it is. Uh but we're going to pass the
turn and ready two runes.
>> And with the deflect cost on Aurelia,
even if she ganks over and you switch a
Rude, you have to recycle one. And we
see the not so fast in hand.
>> Oh,
>> I think Dana might have a hard bargain,
but like if Johannes sequences this
correctly, which also did flip two green
runes, Johannes's hand is crazy to deal
with this board.
>> Huge RNG right now.
>> I I think if I'm Johannes, I'm probably
just doing the charm right away and just
seeing if Dana tries to stop you with
anything. Um, deal with the mind
spplitter, then try and gank over cuz uh
you don't know what's going on over
there, but then you sell the not so fast
with two green runs. It's so crucial
that Johian look two green runs. No,
he's going to go for the gank first.
>> Okay. I I don't think he's too scared
right now. I think we're looking at
seven might from this Ireelia. No. Is it
eight? It's eight might. That's a plus
two.
>> It should be eight. Yep. And there's the
switcheroo. Pay the deflect cost. Uh
targeting the Aurelia and the Overzel
fan. If this resolves, that means
Aurelia goes to two might and uh the
Overzel fan will go for more. But we're
actually going to flash to dodge it. So,
we're going to flash to dodge that
little switcheroo. We're going to
>> move our unit back to base.
>> I would recycle a purple. Yeah, there.
[laughter]
>> Yeah, those greens are very valuable
right now just in case. Wow.
>> So, we're moving that uh Ireelia back to
base, but we're also keeping tabs on
we're choosing this. So, she's still
getting stronger.
I I'm interesting Johannes did it that
way because now if you send the Aurelia
back in Dana could just overz fans send
it back again and then the charm's not a
threat
but I guess you're not winning on your
next turn anyway and that way Dana is
only up four runes that's kind of scary
but you could like Annie get a
switcheroo
hide the switcheroo like there's there's
a lot of stuff you can do at that point
so or or get back like the flash and
then have flash ready to save the mind
spplitter if like it gets charmed in. So
I actually think that like
>> Johan again the sequencing wise that's
why I like the idea of like charming
first cuz it just guarantees deals with
the mind spplitter and when you're
behind like this you have to deal with
threats on the board because if you let
those threats stay Dana's only going to
get more and more points.
>> Exactly.
>> And if you have the the clean avenue to
just deal with the threat I I like
taking that. But of course Yiannis I now
is in this position. So let's let's see
what Yiannis decides to do from here.
We're getting a bit of thinking here cuz
yeah, I think there's just so many
decisions to keep in mind here. So,
we're actually going to reattack this.
Ireelia is that much bigger. Let's see
what happens.
>> Dana's going to do it. And I'm also
remembering Johannes does have the not
so fast. So, maybe you go for the not so
fast here. Yep, there we go. Okay, so
Johannes actually did have a pretty
clean line. You're not so fast that
you're still at the battlefield. You
still get the point. And then we can
still charm the mind spplitter and that
deals with all the threats. And Dana
still is only at four runes. Johannes is
actually mounting a comeback right now.
>> He might just be cooking in the stew
right now. We're going to
>> Oh, but we knew when there was a hard
bargain and there's no longer enough
runes for Johannes.
>> Yep. So that's going to be the end of
his turn. He is going to pass over to
Dana. Now she only has those four runes
and Ireelia is still on the board. G8 is
equipped to her though, so not too
scary. But maybe we do get that off the
board. Let's see what Dana cooks.
>> It's scary to attack in cuz there it's
five might Aelia, an ong guard or a um
uh a
>> Why am I blanking on the name of the
Aurelia signature spell? Defant dance.
There we go. Either one can deal with
it, but how about this? We're just going
to send in the Rexi with the mind
spplitter. Just guarantee the take here.
Yes. And so we're going to choose to uh
trade VA for the mind spplitter.
>> Yeah. I missed that the uh the boots the
squishy boots were also in the Aurelia
cuz it's kind of like a little off right
now. But yeah, that was a big Aelia.
That was seven might. So
>> Dana will get the point. We'll ready to
>> And here we are. We're going to pass
over to Mr. Fest. We're going to channel
those two runes. We're going to of
course ready the Ireelia. So she's
automatically going up one might. And uh
let's see what we draw from our uh deck
here.
>> So Aurelia is probably going to go into
the Rex eye. I'm usually a fan of do the
thing you know you're always going to do
before you start tapping your runes cuz
your decision tree might change later.
>> So if you just send the Aurelia in
first, you get to see what Dana has
cooking before you make your next call
cuz maybe you just like it gets rebuked.
You want to replay the Aelia, something
like that, right? Um, but the crazy
thing Dana could have and Giannis might
not have an answer for it. Ride the
wind. If you attack this Rex eye and you
Dana ride the winds over to the Z warren
scores and then can hold that's game.
>> Yeah,
>> we go to combat. Oh, Dana does not have
anything. Ooh,
>> and that's going to be the end of Rexi
there. And we are going to get a conquer
point over for Mr. Fest here. Now, do we
ready? Oh, we're going to play a Vex.
We're going to exhaust five recycle one
to play a Vex.
I'm I'm really interested that uh like I
would want to score two points per per
turn by readying my Ireelia, but he's
really conserving those uh runes to uh
not get too low on resources.
>> This is a very intricate game state.
Currently, we are on turn I I don't even
remember exactly. I want to say turn six
or seven for Dana.
>> You're doing this on purpose. not doing
this on purpose.
>> Come on, bro.
>> But we're we're we're deep into the game
and it's still only six to five now and
the runes were getting pretty low. Dana
went down to two at one point. Now up to
five and just kind of establishes the
field. You're just going to go for the
Rex side. The Enox is hopeful. Try and
reestablish a board cuz Dana's in a
position where two conquers will win the
game. But Johannes is kind of in a still
a bit of a hot seat because you have to
spend at least one more turn.
>> Yes.
>> But you do have more resources because
you you hold here. Aurelia can just uh
gank over to the Zon Warren and get that
point and then you have six runes to
play with to make sure that you hold the
points for the next turn.
>> Exactly. Um and I'm curious to see what
we're thinking about doing here. Only
two runes. Yep. We're ganking over for
that additional point. So now we're
we're tied here. We've got that six to
six
>> and it looks like we're discarding that
Defy.
>> To me, that signals there might be
another Defy cuz I would save that Defy
for like a ride the win. That's one of
like the best win conditions for Dana
right now. Although, you know, at this
point,
>> I suppose it's a little less of a win
condition because Johannes at six. So,
you can always just conquer and hold and
and you know,
>> we're closer to that end game. But
still, I think it signals that Yiannis
probably has something else to deal with
these annoying Annie spells.
>> Something up his sleeve. And I think we
might just be leaving those two units on
the board. Maybe
maybe we want to see if she can actually
clear both boards.
We're looking. We're thinking we've got
what? Six Six runes to play with right
now.
six runes on Johannes's side. It'll be
seven at the start of Dana's turn. So
Annie with a Rex eye and an Nox is
hopeful representing essentially eight
total attacking might and seven runes
available.
>> That's that's what Dana's going to be
playing with. But here comes the Fizz.
>> Here comes the Fizz. We're exhausting
three and recycling one. And we're going
to play a spell.
>> Is it the charm?
>> It might be charm.
>> Yep. Just deal with the threats.
Johannes has done a good job so far this
game of dealing with the threats. If
you're this far behind in points against
another deck, like Annie doesn't have
that many units, it's about half of the
deck is units, but like if you can just
make sure that there's never units on
the field, Annie's not going to be able
to score the points. Um, and that's
exactly how Johannes is approaching
this.
>> So, we're moving in that Noxis Hopeful
and we're passing priority and then
she's going to pass it right back, which
means that the Noxis Hopeful is going to
die here and we're passing turn. So, she
has to get one battlefield at least
cleared.
>> Yeah, if you can just clear the one and
then hold it, you're still in a pretty
good spot. The problem is there's a Vex
on one. So, it's scary to go into the
Vex. And if you go into the Aelia Fizz,
well, next turn, Vex gets the Swifty
Boots and can then gank over and still
do Vex things. So, that Vex is going to
be a headache no matter how which way
you slice it.
>> Yep. And we've only got this Rexai on
the board at the M moment. It looks like
we're getting
>> I I see Judge call on the screen, but it
looks like Dana's still playing, so I
don't know how accurate that is.
>> Okay, it's actually looking like Dana's
requesting one. So, there we go. Little
spoiler.
>> All right. Well, let's kind of analyze
this board state cuz it's very close.
It's very close here. We've got the
Fizz. We've got the Airelia uh sitting
on ZH. And we've got the Vex like you
said. visibility.
>> Okay, I want to hear
>> units played anywhere other than
accelerate.
>> Um, is accelerate the additional cost or
does it just enter?
>> So Dana's asking how does the accelerate
work on rec sites? My understanding the
accelerate gives accelerate to the unit
that is their color. Accelerate just as
a tag just means you pay an energy cost
and the color equivalent to the card
you're playing power cost. So, say it's
Annie uh stubborn. Annie stubborn. That
means that you would pay an energy and
recycle a chaos uh rune as well. That
that's a purple power cost. So, you're
not paying the Rex eye accelerate power
cost for the unit you're playing. You're
playing the equivalent accelerate cost
of the unit. So,
>> gotcha. And that just might be what the
judge is explaining here.
Does that make sense?
>> And I think we're just getting the
>> one energy and an addition an additional
energy and an additional
>> correct an additional power of that of
that
>> judges confirming.
>> It's fun. We get to hear the judges
ruling on these things. But uh also self
five. I got a right to [laughter] after
self-reporting that I failed the judge
test when I took it earlier. Uh actually
I didn't do it between rounds. We said
we were going to do that. I still need
to do that. But Annie is going to come
in accelerate.
>> Yes. So Annie comes in, we uh exhaust
for and we recycle two. Um and here we
go. Let's see who we're moving in on. We
have two runes left to play with. Um do
remember that switcheroo is boom.
>> Oh,
>> right there. So we're also going to uh
go ahead and attack into this fizz and
Ireelia.
>> And I think we have to switch actually.
Wait, how much might is this? This is
currently seven attacking in on six for
Aurelia and three for Fizz. And we are
going to switch.
Uh and we're going to target the
Aurelia. So we're paying the deflect
cost. This is all in. This is Annie
going all in right now to clear this
Aurelia. Make sure that this happens.
>> And even then it's scary cuz like a
rebuke on Johannes's side is just game.
>> Yeah. See, uh Fest has three runes up
right now. There is room for a response
here and we're thinking so I do think
that he probably has something that he
wants to play in return.
>> It's looking like Annie is the target
for Switcheroo and the Aurelia which
means that it would be then um 10 might
attacking in on six
>> which would still be able to clear
>> the Rex eye or the Annie like like
Johannes will trade at least one of them
but Dana will get the conquer and then
maybe you hide another switch route.
Problem is like you're going to have two
runes up and they're two red runes. So
you know there's no rebuke Johannes. You
can honestly just let this go. Equip the
swifties to Vex attack over that's
probably game because any spell that
Dana tries to play is going to cost uh
one more.
I think hidden Switcheroo is like the
only thing that Dana could have that
would stop Johannes's next push.
And what a position for Johannes. I
gotta say this game started with Dana
already just Battlefields going first
with Arena's greatest and Zon Warren
from Johannes in a good spot. Johannes
misses the Arena's greatest trigger to
score the point. Judges rule that he
can't keep it go. He can't uh reverse
that and get the point back cuz the turn
had already passed. And then Johannes
fights his way tooth and nail back and
it looks like a defiant dance is coming
down.
>> Oh, and that is going to be the victory
for Mr. Fest.
Yeah, that's a tough spot for the Annie
to be in and it shows why the Aurelia
match up is so strong. Johannes, deep
sigh of relief coming back from a
disastrous start to that game three. I
would love to get uh his [music]
thoughts on that during the interview. I
know it's a tough thing for a player in
the moment. It's a lot of pressure. Uh
but again, that's the human element.
That's why we watch these games is to
see the best play it and also to see
that people make mistakes too. like it
happens and those types of moments, you
have to be able to stay in the game,
bounce back, and Johannes did just that.
>> Absolutely. And I mean, I I I said it
during the the little slip up that
happened there. It's so crucial that he
doesn't let that get a hold of him, mess
up the mental and he stayed in it. He
stayed in it fully and he came out
victorious. So, mental, yes, mental wins
games sometimes, y'all. I will say
massive credit to Dana coming in very
young new generation. This kid's 15
years old.
>> Yeah.
>> Cosplaying Annie, playing the Annie
deck, having fun up on stage. Hopefully
having fun up on stage at least. Uh so
props to Dana. Also played a very good
game of Riftbound. I I again watching
it. I think there was like maybe one
moment that I was like, "Huh, there's
maybe something I would have done
different, but again, that doesn't
necessarily mean that it was the right
call on on my end." Like I still think
data played an incredibly good game and
um really pushed Aurelia to the limit in
a vastly Aurelia favored matchup. 59% is
a statistical like that's notable.
That's a notable win rate for Aurelia.
>> Absolutely. She played a very technical
game, aggressive, patient when she
needed to. We just knew that she knew
that matchup. Um, it's very unfortunate
that the win was not secured, but I
think she should still walk away proud
of how she played
>> and still X2 still has a good chance to
make day two. We have a couple more
rounds after this. X2s will make day two
still. So, you still get a better shot
at prizing. You know, you can keep your
tournament run going. Um, but Johannes
again showing that why I think Aelia is
also one of the decks on everyone's
radar. Like, it's Draven, it's Aurelia.
Those are by far the most two
represented here uh in Atlanta. And it's
for states like that. like you're down
what four points at one point in that
game was still able to fight back. Like
Aurelia can do crazy stuff.
>> Absolutely. She can get super duper
mighty, super duper tanky. Um but I feel
like Ireelia wasn't the only star of
that show. Uh we saw a lot of Vex. Vex
came through a lot making those spells
more expensive, making them cheaper for
the Ireelia player as well.
>> Yeah, I making them cheaper was about
like I'd say 30% of it. the 70% was
making the Annie spell more expensive.
Like rebuke for three and recycle three
is really painful. Let alone the deflect
cost if Aelia is in combat too. And even
just the deflect cost in general, I
think is partly why Aurelia is so good
right now cuz Rebuke we saw was the most
present card in every deck list here in
Atlanta having your ace unit with the
flex that you're pretty much bouncing
around and even if it goes back to hand,
you can play it and get it back on the
board. Um it it's very impactful and we
saw Dana struggling with the runes as
the game went on because down to two
runes on like that sixth seventh turn.
Um I said sixth seventh it doesn't
count. I added a at the end.
>> Okay, I'm going to let you have it. You
said it literally three times during
that match. I really do think he's
baiting me guys.
>> I was It was an accurate representation
of the game.
>> What is it called? Like if it's not rage
baiting, it's 67 baiting. You're 67.
>> No, we're not coining that. We're not
coing that. Okay. Well, uh, you said it
three times during one match. That's
kind of That's kind of
>> You only did it once.
>> And I only did it once because I don't
want to do it every time. That'll be
expected. You know what I'm saying? So,
um, but I I do also want to highlight,
we talked a lot about the tide turner
being a uh a big card for that past
game,
>> but we also saw Switcheroo was also very
very love that card. And I I'm hearing
that we actually have the interview
ready. So, I want to hear from the
player himself, Johannes, what it was
like playing against that matchup.
>> 67.
>> Thanks so much, guys. I'm here joined by
the winner of that nailbiter of a match,
Johannes Fouse. Congratulations on
winning that match. You're still
remaining X and1 moving into the
tournament. I saw that side relief from
you after you won with that defiant
dance. How do you feel right now?
>> Uh relief more than anything. Yeah, I
obviously messed up the arena's greatest
triggers, which was unfortunate. Um
yeah, it's my first big tournament, so
obviously, you know, nerves are bad. Um
but it's been a ton of fun.
>> You're you say the nerves are bad, but
you're doing such a great job. You're
piloting one of the decks that a lot of
people have their eyes on, but you have
some really unique spice here in your
list that I specifically want to talk
about your battlefields. Man, every time
I saw a battlefield come down for you,
you really had high priority on having
and finding the right cards that you
could, not necessarily 100% having to
rely on things like the Stellarorn
Herder. It meant any unit you could get
on, you know, you the sunken temple,
right? You had the Raven Bloom
Conservatory and then the Zon Warren
coming out in the third game. I'll be
honest, I was a little terrified for you
when when I saw the arena's greatest Zan
Warren flipped over. If I was Annie
there sitting in that moment, I go,
"Whoa, I play those." But you really
value that sort of filter ability or
draw power and it's really showing
success. So, speak to that a little bit.
>> Yeah, I mean, I went for the zone warren
game three cuz I wanted to deny Annie
the the zone warren if possible. Um, and
then after losing the first game, I
obviously know that I can't give the
Raven Bloom Conservatory, so I got to um
go for the Zone Warren going second,
which you never want to do, but it is
what it is. Um, yeah, I think Card draw
is huge for the deck. I I think I'm
right in saying that I didn't really
abuse a Stellicorn in the entire match,
which is unfortunate. That that makes
things harder. Um, and yeah, at that
point, I think the Vexes were incredibly
important. Um, they allow you to kind of
have card economy when you're low on
cards. Um, and yeah, that's what
essentially wanted for me in the end,
despite uh, you know,
>> being up against it. I'm just saying I
also have an Aurelia deck and I've never
really considered putting Raven Bloom
in, but as soon as you defended and you
flipped a Rebuke over at the top, I
believe it was game two, I was like, I'm
sold. I'm convinced. I'm going to put
that in my deck now. So,
>> yeah. Yeah. Especially in combination
with Triple Charm. It's a battlefield
that can get you a lot of value and can
swing a match.
>> And Charm has had a lot of value. I know
a lot of people are talking about how
important it was last week in Leo, but
you're on your way to climb yourself
into a day two already. I'm not going to
jinx it, of course.
>> We'll see. We'll see.
>> Still X and one on Aurelia. So,
congratulations on your match win, but
there was some insight there from
Johannes F. We're going to pitch it back
to y'all.
>> You know what? We heard it there. And I
I agree. That charm was an amazing card
for him. Um y'all, I messed up that
man's name 14 [laughter] times.
>> I I was about to I was going to say it.
I was like, "Did you hear uh the the
name?"
>> This is my public apology right now. I
am so sorry cuz I messed up your first
name. I messed up your last game.
>> It happens.
>> The Aurelia player. I'm so sorry.
>> Johannes, uh, great game though. He also
did say he never got to abuse the
Stellorn in game two. He got like three
draws off it. [crying]
>> I do think that Dana dealt with it
pretty early on, as she should, because
it gets scary. The more cards that an
Ireelia player has in hand, the scarier
she gets. And that's not even talking
about the might on the board.
>> Yeah. And uh again like you just get so
much advantage when you get multiple
draws off of that. So it was only one
game out of the three he was able to get
any value off of it. Didn't see it the
other ones but still showed that
sometimes just Aurelia like just get the
Aurelia out there and get that moving
around especially the Vexes which we had
already talked about. I feel that was
another really big uh kind of pivotal
moment. Uh soon here we're be hearing
from Charmer about his thoughts on some
of the moments in those games. I'm
curious what he's going to focus on
because when I think back to that game,
I'm like going back to that game state
where you're down multiple points. The
Annie's already got board presence and
all you have is an Aelia with a G.
That's a scary spot. But I think Vex did
a lot of that hard carrying. Um and uh I
might might even be the MVP of the match
outside of just the Aelia of course.
Like Vex did so much heavy lifting.
>> Absolutely. I mean, yeah, there was so I
I feel like that was one of our best
games that we've watched. There is a lot
to break down and I think uh why would
we hold that from y'all anymore? Let's
go ahead and get into it with Charmer.
>> Hello everybody. Charmer here ready to
talk about what we just saw in that
amazing matchup between the Ireelia
player and of course Dana on Annie. And
there's a couple of different things
that I want to focus on, but there's
going to be a theme throughout all of
these which is opportunity. When you're
playing against Aurelia and you expect
to see a lot at these events because it
is one of the top meta decks, you have
to take advantage of those windows of
opportunity. So, in order for that to
happen, Dana as the Annie player has to
find opportunities to catch these runes
offguard. So, as we can see here, we
have a setup where Dana is going to be
going into a play, and we're going to go
ahead and let this play now, where she's
trying to force these runes to be used.
So, she's going to have the rebuke come
out. We can see the rebuke here. And
then this is going to be answered by a
counter spell. Again, the calm players,
you expect that to be the play. Boom.
Hard bargain comes down. And when the
hard bargain hits, that's now in the
bin. But when the hard bargain hits,
that is the answer that buys her the
opportunity. This is why she was able to
capitalize and win game one. This is
what you need to do against Aurelia
players. You have to force them into a
situation where they do not have the
energy to pay for their counter spells
or to pay for their defensive buffs,
etc. Annie potentially is a good matchup
because of her ability to develop onto
the board and then with the legend
ability always get those runes back. But
Annie is not the only legend that is
looking to take advantage of these
opportunities in the matchup. So on the
other side, we're going to see uh
something that is very League specific
in this next clip. It is knowing when
knowing when Flash is down. If you've
played League of Legends, you know that
uh Flash being down is something that
you are looking for. So in this
particular instance, we see Flash.
That's right. Flash here has been played
by Dana. Flash is down. This is normally
when you would signal to your uh
jungler, to your mid laner, hey,
somebody's flash is down. Come give me a
gank over here. Well, as we're about to
see, uh this is taken literally. So, go
ahead and roll the clip. We're going to
see the boots of swiftness come down and
then that's going to allow the gank to
come over onto the other side because
again Dana has now used her energy. The
window of opportunity is going to be on
the side of Johannes Fest and we're
going to again like I said in a moment
see these boots of swiftness provide the
ganking. It's a tale as old as time if
you're coming from League of Legends
honestly. and uh cleans up the other
battlefield that helped secure game two
for Johannes. And so we're going to be
going ahead to the next clip, which is
again another one of those windows of
opportunity. Uh this one in particular
is again, you'll notice runes on the
side of the Aurelia player are spent.
Not only is there no energy available,
but very very important, no calm runes
available either. So even if that one
energy up went something like a defy not
available. So in this particular
instance Dana is trying to follow things
up with once again a hard bargain to
stop things. But like I said it's all
about opportunities. It goes both ways.
The final and the in my opinion the
clinching play that was made is the
following clip that we're going to focus
on which is the presence of Vex. And
again, talking about opportunities,
sometimes you have to create your own.
One of the things that I'm going to
highlight here is yes, she still has
these runes available, two energy up.
Normally, this means many things are
online, rebuke, switcheroo, etc. But our
Aurelia player is smart and they know
that Vex over here
is going to increase the costs in
combat. So, they're going to play a
charm, and we can see the charm. Let's
go ahead and highlight that now. And
that charm is going to target
this hopeful and make the hopeful go
here. And because it's that battleground
specifically with the Vex, those two
runes up are still not enough to pay for
all of those impactful twocost cards.
You can't flash out of it. Like I said,
no rebuke, no switcheroo, all of the
tricks that you want to use in that
particular situation to keep that unit
alive and or go over the top of the Vex.
They are offline because Vex is in
combat. So again, very heads up play. Uh
could have opted instead, right, to send
the unit to this where all the might is,
but that again would have allowed for
one of those plays to occur. So, heads
up play by Aurelia player to cinch
things with the Vex. Uh, again, the
theme in this matchup is opportunity.
And so, if you're somebody who is at
home saying, "Hey, I'm losing to Aurelia
at my nexus knights. How do I go over
the top of this?" You have to find these
windows of opportunity. Similarly, if
you're the Aurelia pilot, you need to
make sure you're capitalizing on your
own windows with cards like Charm when
your opponent has no way to combat it.
Uh, I think this was a really
outstanding series. A lot of good back
and forth. Again, congratulations to our
Aurelia player. But, uh, this this is
just the start. We're going to see a lot
more Aurelia throughout the event. That
being said, we have a fun segment coming
up next, which is going to be Miss Kim
Kim playing against Damian in a game of
Riftbound using a chess clock. That's
right. If you've complained about how
long some of these events go or you've
complained about the round timer, well,
now is your chance to see what a chess
clock would do. So, go ahead, take it
away, Miss Kim Kim.
>> Hello and welcome back to the Riftbound
Regional Qualifiers in Atlanta, Georgia.
Um, as y'all know, my name is Miss
Chimchum and I am here with a very
special guest today.
>> Hi, I'm Damian. I'm from UBS. I work on
marketing for organized play.
And today we're going to be playing a
special version of Riftbound. As y'all
know, with the bands listed, they want
Riftbound games to go a little bit
faster. So, we think we should ramp that
up just a little bit more. And we're
going to be playing with a chess clock.
Now, the chess clock has 5 minutes on
it. And you just go back and forth
playing super duper fast. Whoever runs
out of time when whoever has the most
points wins. Okay. So, uh I think we
should just get started.
>> Cool. Let's roll for first.
>> Yeah. High roll.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> I don't know that that's doing it.
>> Two.
>> Two. Okay. Okay.
>> Four. Okay. I feel more confident now.
>> Six. I will be starting.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So, let's draw our cards first.
Let's flip our battlefields.
All right. All right, we've got the
paper tree and the windswept look. Uh,
let's see. I will keep mine.
>> I'm going to send one back. Feeling good
about the other three, though.
>> Actually, you're right. I'm uh also
>> Oh, I think you passed. But you know
what? I'll let it slide. [laughter]
>> Okay. Are we ready?
>> We're ready.
>> Let's get started.
Am I trolling?
Are we trolling?
>> Oh,
>> I wonder if we have to.
>> Oh.
>> Oh,
>> there you go.
>> Okay, we're going. Okay, I channel two
runes. I draw for turn. I'm going to tap
two and I'm going to play Daring Coro.
And I pass to you. It's so hard to think
when you're going this fast. Luckily,
this is Aurora, so I don't have to
think. You're go.
>> Okay, I ready my units. I channel two
runes.
>> I draw for turn. Um and then I'm going
to go in here. Any response?
>> Nope.
>> Okay. I go up one point. All right. Uh
and then I'm going to tap two and I'm
going to play pit rookie and I'm going
to buff my daring poro. And uh I will
tap another two um to in a lot of time
>> play another pit rookie and I'm going to
buff
>> Oh, they can only have one buff.
You'll buff the other pit rookie.
>> Yes, that's actually what I was going to
do from the jump and I passed to you.
>> All right, I channel two, draw one. Uh
you know, not a lot of decisions here.
I'm going to channel two runes and pass.
>> Oh my gosh, you are really making me
work for this right now. Um, I am going
to go over here. I get one point for
holding. I get one point for conquering.
Um, okay. I got a channel my two. Dude,
I'm just like ABCing all out of order.
Are you kidding me? Um, I'm going to tap
four
and I'm going to play a BF sword. I am
going to recycle one rune to equip it to
uh the daring porro. So, I'm going to
tap my legend channel one rune exhausted
and pass to you.
>> Cool. Already my runes go to nine.
Nine's a pretty good number for Aurora.
Uh, you know what? I will see the
Aurora.
>> No.
>> Two.
>> Oh, no.
>> Okay, I will pass my turn. Aurora will
trigger. Casey Fay folk. Not what I want
to see off the top. Here. Go.
>> Okay. So, I go up two points for holding
both battlefields. I'm feeling really
good. I'm ready too if I
>> I'm readying my runes. I am channeling
two runes. I'm drawing for turn. Um I'm
going to tap two and play unsung hero
here. Also, I held here so we both
channel one rune exhausted.
>> Oo, I like that.
>> I don't like that anymore. Uh I
channelled the unsung hero and then
three, four, what? Two. Uh
I'm going to tap three. Bring in Fiora
pass to you.
>> Ready my runes.
>> Bro, I've really been playing. You
haven't been playing.
>> Yeah. I mean, I don't know what's going
on. Uh, let's go eight. Oh, you're in
punch first territory.
>> We'll see how this goes.
>> Um, this is
>> I'm going to attempt to go
here.
>> Okay. And I'm going to tap two, recycle
one rune, and I'm going to hidden blade.
Your dead bloom.
>> You love the hidden blade.
>> I love the hidden.
>> And I love uh not so fast, buddy.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Is it your
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Your action.
>> And it's back to me.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So, I'm going to tap one and
recycle two. And now I will punch first.
>> Okay. Now, it's my uh Yeah. You know
what? I think you got it.
>> Okay.
>> Fire. Um, and with that, I'm going to
tap my legend to
>> Okay.
>> So, this is
>> five over here, right?
>> Yes.
>> I'll come over here for six.
>> Oh my gosh. Okay. I think these are
dying.
>> Sweet. Um, okay. I will pass my turn.
Aurora will trigger.
>> Oh,
>> I'll leave it at home. Here I go.
>> All right. I'm drawing for turn. I'm
channeling two runes.
>> I actually have one. You're at six
points.
>> Everything goes up.
>> Yeah, I get two points here. No. Or did
you?
>> No, just one.
>> Okay. One point. I'm at seven.
>> I already ticked you up.
>> Oh, I'm trolling. There we go. There we
go. Um, okay. Ready? Ready. You're at
six over there.
>> Depends for eight.
>> I'm tapped out, though.
>> Okay. Let's
tap four. Recycle two. Yeah. No, the
board gets sloppy like this.
>> Real messy.
>> Um, I'm going to He's at five. That's at
six. I'm going to
bring in Spectral. And I'm going to
bring in a hit rookie. And as you know,
>> Wait, I'm sorry. This has a buff on it.
I'm trolling.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. As you know, I will be
buffing
the matron.
>> My time. My time is going crazy right
now. Ah.
>> Okay. Uh, what do I want to do? What do
I want to do?
>> Oh, are you just running out the clock?
That's crazy.
>> No, that's not what I'm trying to do.
Okay. Uh, let's
I'm just going to attack. I don't even
care, man. I'm going to tap.
Is this what I want to do?
>> [screaming]
>> I don't think this is what I want to do.
I'm actually pretty scared. I passed.
>> I'm actually pretty scared.
>> I'm actually terrified of your big boys.
>> One.
>> Oh, good job. You got two points.
[laughter]
>> Oh, this is actually a funny turn. Um,
okay. Let's go. I'm going to come in
here.
>> Okay,
>> cool. I'll grab a point.
>> There you go. I will charm in
>> this one into here.
>> No, it's going to die.
>> I will charm in this into here.
>> No.
[laughter]
>> Uh, it'd be crazy if I had another one.
Um, I'll charm in Spectrum. We're
looking.
>> Yo, what the
>> Oh, pay four. Make two dudes.
>> Yo, you just wiped out half my board.
>> I will pass. Auroral trigger.
>> Another Aurora.
>> Well, I can't play it. I wish I could.
>> Okay, good, good, good, good, good. Oh
my god, I'm wasting my time.
>> Good, nice, nice, nice. We love that.
>> Okay, one, two, draw for turn. Okay,
this is not looking very fun, nor is it
looking very fresh. We've got six over
here. We've got 16 over here. Oh my
gosh. Okay, let's
tap three.
>> I think you got it. You know,
>> and we're going to bring in a first
mate. We're going to Let's see. I can do
five, six, seven.
Six, [laughter] seven.
Um, okay. Dang. I can't even ready this
because of what you've done. Oh my gosh.
I've got 42 seconds. Okay, let's
let's recycle a rune.
>> Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
>> Let's recycle a rune and equip.
And then because she's mighty,
>> remember I defend for plus two.
>> I pass my turn.
>> I get two points.
>> No.
>> Oh, I'm about to tie up the game.
>> You're catching up.
Oh my gosh.
>> They're going to hang out together.
>> Freaking insane. No.
>> I'm going to bring that guy in there for
fun. Aor's going to play.
Oh, this this uh Yeah, he'll he'll come
over there. I'm going to spread the
space. And you know what? I'm going to
run out the clock a little bit cuz I
feel I feel [laughter] like
>> I feel like it's fine. You know, how are
you feeling this game so far?
>> Oh my goodness, dude.
>> Have you had enough time to think about
your turn?
>> What has happened?
>> Okay.
>> All right. We're readying everything.
We're channeling two rookies.
>> I think that pit rookie and the first
mate, I think they can take out this
mountain.
>> I hate you so much. Okay, so we've got
12 that we have. [screaming]
Wait, wait, wait.
Uh, okay. So, it's up to me.
>> I don't even know how much.
>> 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. Yeah, you could kill
one of the tasty things.
>> Oh my gosh.
Do you have any response?
>> No. That they all die once.
>> Can you Can you please have a response
real quick?
>> I don't have a response.
>> Respond.
>> No response.
>> I have no [laughter] response.
>> Okay. I killed this one.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, no.
or sorry, draw one. Channel two runes.
My turn.
>> Can we get this to stop? Okay.
>> So, wait. Now I have a minute left on my
turn, right?
>> Yeah, I think so. Will it play?
>> I don't remember how we got it to
>> I think you just win cuz you hold both
and I cannot respond. So, you're at
eight.
That is end of the game. GG's GG.
>> Wow. Look at the board, bro. Like, what
is happening? [laughter]
Well, thank you guys so much for
watching. I hope you guys enjoyed this
sped up version of Riftbound. And we
will see you back on broadcast shortly.
That was that was beautiful. Three
charms in one turn. I mean, what are you
going to do about that?
>> I think you rigged the game. I think you
gave him those three charms.
>> I definitely did not. I did give you the
chess clock that doesn't keep time going
once one runs out of time. I don't know
how to change that setting. Um, but that
was hilarious and exactly as scuffed as
I was hoping it would be. That was the
saddest thing [laughter] I've ever done,
y'all. How do I get up 40 million
points? Yeah. And this man comes back
for 40 million and two.
>> Welcome to Aurora. [sighs]
>> That's Oh my gosh. And I just want to
see are Ye doing this on the floor as
well.
>> Yeah. I mean, that's kind of what Aurora
does. If it's Aurora, a lot of Yees have
gone to more of like a mid-range style
if we're getting analytical about it,
you know. Um, but yeah, the the Aurora
Yees, they're they're something fierce.
>> And you know, it's so crazy cuz in
Fiona, I have a way to kill the gear.
>> Do you want to know how much gear
killing I drew?
>> Um, I'm going to guess a big uh donut.
>> Exactly. And it it just it was it was my
demise truly. And I feel like Damian has
a special way of playing where like
>> he's so cheeky. He's so
>> He's so cheeky.
>> I will I will ask him a question. It'll
be like he always raises his eyebrows
just like this. [laughter]
I don't know. I don't know what I got.
And every time it baits me in, I always
fall for it. And then stuff like that
happen.
>> I have a 0% win rate against that man
while he's on his uh Aurora.
>> Y'all, he is very good. Uh now, I will
say I beat him three times earlier
during the day. Okay, I want that to go
on record. But you know, since we were
just talking about Master Yi, let's get
into this next match. It is a Master Yi
deck, let's go ahead and get into the
deck list.
>> We're going to take a look at the going
to be the opponent.
>> Same colors, green, orange, but uh this
one mostly focused around the gears.
Even more so than the modern ye decks,
which have adopted the Trinity Forces.
Some of them adopted the guardian
angels. Jax is all about these
equipments. your grandmaster at arms.
Legend allows you to uh attach your
equipments either for an energy cost if
they're unequipped or just for free if
you're moving them around between units.
It allows you to dodge the power cost of
the equipments which is kind of the
downside of a lot of equipments is that
you have to damp your runes. Jax gets
around that. So, you're going to use
things like the 24 GA, the brutalizer,
also an important one right here. They
did recently change Jacks in the new
rules update. It used to be ruled that
you can unequip and then re-equip an
equipment to the same unit. So,
brutalizer was crazy good in Jacks. You
can no longer do that. It's a more
honest build of Jacks. That's what I'm
calling it. More honest Jacks now, but
you can still move the brutalizer
around, of course, and get really good
value. And then things like the Doran's
Blade and the Bone Shiver. Bone Shiver
is one that we haven't seen a lot of.
Um, but bone shiver is one of the
strongest equipments in the game in
terms of just like raw power of what it
does to might. And then also when you
conquer, you channel a rune exhausted.
It helps you ramp and it makes you guys
bigger. Very, very solid gear.
>> Amazing. And another call out I want to
do here is that Tiana Crown Guard. We
saw her earlier. She is a problem. When
she's at a battlefield, opponents cannot
score points. So, I'm really excited to
see this card come out to play. And when
you pair that with Jax's signature
spell, Counterstrike, that's when things
get really goofy because Tiana typically
you want to pair with something that is
gonna keep her safe. But Counter-Strike
just does that on its own cuz you choose
a unit, the next time that unit would be
dealt damage this turn, prevent it, and
you draw a card. So, uh, if you have a
Tiana at a battlefield and your opponent
doesn't have enough things to push
through the Tiana, you can always keep
it alive through at least like a combat
or a spell, um, and then prevent your
opponent from scoring. Uh, this is a
very interesting version. And then you
pair that with the Ruin Runner. Tiana
plus Ruin Runner mean that um they
they're two of the best units that
capitalize on Counter-Strike cuz like
Ruin Runner, one of the best ways to
deal with it is just attacking it.
Counter-strike protects that. Tiana, one
of the best ways to deal with it is
attacking it. Counter-Strike deals with
that. Also, both of these units can get
very big uh and are just kind of
headaches to deal with. So, interesting
build of Jax.
>> Absolutely. I kind of want to point out
Oh, here to help, by the way. I just
just noticed the one one here to help.
That's fun.
>> Yes. No, I think it's such a fun and
cute card because you get to make some
units uh a little bit cheaper.
>> Yeah, you hide this and then you play,
you get a unit for cheaper. That could
be the Tiana. Really mess your opponent
up. But I want to take a look at the E
deck that's on the other side of this
cuz it's the same colors, but I assume
it'll be drastically different play
style. And it is no Trinity Force in
this Ye deck.
>> This looks a little more uh standard Ye.
I feel like before uh we saw Spirit
Forge, we don't have the Aurora though.
There's no Aurora in this deck.
>> It kind of looks like a mid-range Origin
take on the You don't have the Triny
Forest, but you do have the Ruin Runners
and you do have the Aurelas and the
Stella. And so we've amped it up with
more stuff. We're still in the Clockwork
Keepers. We're on three lonely porros.
So this is a a unit heavy master y list
with just a lot of buffs. We got on
guards, we got punch first, we got
disciplines, we got challenges, we got
th we got every like combat orange and
green. Yeah, let's just cycle through
all of them. Like just
cuz all of these are going to be very
impactful at just protecting and
utilizing your units as additional
resources, but I have not seen a deck
quite like this in a while.
>> Yes. No, this is definitely like
Origin's origin. Okay, but speaking of
buffing, we also have that white flame
protector that's going to be able to
give a plus eight might to another unit
when it is played. But let's talk about
protection. We've also got two zas in
hand that can be used if something that
we really like, we really think is
precious is about to die. The one of the
awkward things with the E, and I've seen
this in a lot of E decks that have kind
of moved on from the Zonas, if they're
running the Porros, is that your Zonas,
you don't really get to choose. It's
just the next time a unit would die,
recall it instead. So, if your opponent
goes for like the Porro first or like a
sand soldier token, it's like you don't
really care to protect that. So, that's
why uh I don't often see it in the list
that are running a lot of low might
units. instead they're going for the GA
cuz then they can just put that on their
Aurelia and put that on their Celicorn
like the things or the rune runner
things that they know they want it on.
Um you have to be a little more
selective when you when you use the
zonas if this is the type of build of
deck you have
>> 100%. And finally uh
>> there it is [laughter] best orange card
ever printed.
>> Yes, it cannot be chosen by enemy spells
and abilities. So, if you think that
you're going to come in and do something
to the Ruin Runner, you better do it
just by might alone. But let's go ahead
and get to this game. I want to see
versus this Master Yi, will this Jax be
able to uphold and claim victory? The
battle of the equipments. And uh one of
the positives of this type of Master Yi
build is that a lot of thermo beams are
around, a lot of Ashons are around, a
lot of gear hate is around. you're not
on the gear, you're on two zonas, you're
not actually giving your opponent a lot
of value. Uh, and even if they don't see
a Trinity Force, I imagine a lot of red
decks would still side deck thermmo beam
against you regardless cuz they're like,
"Oh, he just didn't draw the Trinity
Force." Um, so interesting to see. I
mean, I I don't imagine that the uh the
Jacks will have much of that other than
maybe Axan actually. He might have a
side and then side those in uh and they
might not be as much value. You still
have Weapon Masters, so you get some
value out of them. That's a such a fun
card, but I can talk about that for a
while. We're ready for game one.
>> We're ready for game one. We're going to
go ahead and see if we're going to be
mulliganing. We've got a first mate. I
see on the side of the master. Ye. We've
got a gay, a discipline, and a defy.
>> Uh, the audience at home could not see
this, but I I'd love that you leaned to
the right to try and [laughter] pe
>> I did.
>> Um, McDade. McKade. I'm going to call
him Made
>> Macad.
>> Macad. Well, I'm going to assume the
three is an E. kind of like charmers.
>> Oh, I was thinking MacOD cubed.
>> Well, well, again, we have a lot of
questions about the names of the players
up there. Uh, but regardless, you tried
to lean to look at the hand. I I just I
I love that. Um, just, you know,
>> but we're getting started here
>> conceptually, you know. Yeah. Okay.
Lonely Porro. Good start.
>> Lonely Porro. Good start with the two
exhausted on the side of Mod McCub. Um,
>> I'm sticking with Made. I was right on
Johannes. I'm going to stick with McDade
here.
>> I I'm gonna believe you as we have both
Lonely Porros coming out now. The Lonely
Porro on the side of the Mastery is now
ready as it has been passed back to him
and we're going to move in for a Raven
Bloom Conservatory Conquer and that is
going to go through. So, he is going to
score first blood. Cool uh adaptation
with the battlefield. I didn't notice
this during the deck uh build or the the
the deck preview, but Raven Bloom
Conservatory in a spellheavy elist, you
have the one unit out there when it
defends, you have a high chance of
getting a discipline, an on guard, a
punch first, a charm, like all these
thing, a challenge, all these spells,
lot of spells in the deck. Um and also
going first for the Yi, you get to
establish your bigger units, take
control of the board.
>> Yeah. And I mean both of these players
are 5, so you know, like he's he's been
in the stew cooking up just a little
bit. The Lonely Porro on the side of
Bluefi is going to go ahead and conquer
Orange Forge and get the first point. I
know there's going to be some confusion
here shortly on which Lonely Porro is
whose cuz we've got three on the board.
>> You know how I'm going to differentiate?
>> How?
>> One's got blue around it, got black
around it.
>> That is true. Absolutely. I love the
sleeves
both.
>> Although the problem is that the black
Oh, I'm just noticing the black sleeves
have blue on the other side.
There's a lot of blue and like it's
lowkey almost the same color blue. One's
a lighter blue, one's a darker blue. But
you know, we're in here working. I think
I see a punch first in store. I just
want to keep a mental note of these just
in case. We're going in for the lonely
porros. They're both going to just let
those die and they're both going to draw
off of that. I think they're both happy.
>> Yeah. And if you're Made, uh, you now
get to establish another unit. Now that
Jackson single out to the Orange Forge
and there's the Ruin Runner. I don't
know how much value it'll get in this
specific matchup. I guess it can't be
challenged if the Jax is on that, but
there's not a lot of things that like
green orange out like challenge and
charm that they're going to have that's
going to target you.
>> Yeah, exactly. Jax going in though for
orange forge to get another conquer
point. It looks like we're doing a lot
of conquering in this first couple of
moments here with these uh lower units.
And uh let's see. I think we're about to
make a play. There is a Trinity Force in
hand. might be able to see something
come out. We are exhausting three. And
that Trinity Force, yes, is going to
come out for the jacks. And we're
passing turn.
>> And the green jacks gives all of the
equipment in your hand the uh quick
equip uh so that you can just equip them
as you play the card.
>> Uh really, really solid.
>> And it's also costs only three cuz we're
at orange forge. So if anyone's confused
like, hey, why do you only tap three?
Why is the trinity force equipped
without like having to use the jacks
legend or recycling? It's this is just
kind of what the deck's built to do. You
have the battlefield to help you out and
you also have your jacks unmatched. Of
course, giving the quick draw to all of
your equipments in hand.
>> Absolutely. I really appreciate that uh
explanation because yeah, there might be
a lot of players at home who are a
little bit newer to the game and so
we're here to help you out, friends.
>> Jack's also not a popular deck.
>> Exactly. Exactly. We haven't seen many.
Uh this is one of for I don't think I've
played against any at all really. So,
yeah. And I I I mean, I've been grinding
games, y'all. I I'm not just a newbie
out here, not doing nothing. So, we're
exhausting all of our runes here. And
we're recycling, too. Does that mean
we're getting the boom white flame
protector plus eight might is going on
that ruin runner? And it is ready. So,
we are about to attack.
>> And that's a 13 swinging in. So you're
attacking a seven jacks. Even a punch
first is not enough to swing the math in
favor of bluefly gone.
>> That is a g.
>> But we have this
>> we have the counter strike and y'all
know it results in reverse order. So uh
we're going to see that um ruin runner
leave the uh
>> Yeah. So counter-strike just means that
your Jax doesn't take damage.
>> The damage.
>> Yeah. uh but uh it didn't inflict enough
damage to kill the rune runner. So what
happens if an attacking unit and a
defending unit are still at the same
battlefield at the end of combat, the
attacking units go back to base. Kind of
like a stun or or instances like this
where you're protecting from damage.
>> And a player that stuns is is normally
Leona, right? Like
>> Leona is kind of the big one. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> He'll probably print more, but currently
Leona is the one that like really takes
advantage of that. Think of
Counterstrike as like an opposite stun.
I don't know if that if that makes
sense, but we're going to go for the
dors blade. Quick draw onto the jacks
here and still using that orange forge
so it's even cheaper.
>> Yeah, a lot of equipment of course and
challenge is coming out to play and that
white flame does get discarded here.
>> That's big. That's a nine might Jax.
Challenging a white flame is a daunting
task, but was able to get the Jags big
enough and is still at the point and the
Trinity Force is scoring two points. So,
we're winning the race. Uh, blue fly
gun. It just wins by holding and doing
nothing. If no more cards are played,
the point race goes to the Jax player.
So, that means Made is in the pressure
seat. Like, if you're the one that's
losing the race, you're the one
pressured to cause the game state to
change and actually push in for more.
>> Absolutely. But there are a lot of cards
in hand. I'm seeing the charm. I'm
seeing the discipline. Maybe we're able
to even punch for
>> Yeah, you can try and swing in. Another
strat is to just charm the jacks back to
base. That's often not used for charm.
Typically, you pull things from base to
a battlefield or move things between
battlefields. But for ye, you hold so
much better than you attack. So
sometimes you're just like, yeah, I'm
just going to like charm you away and
then take the battlefield and then if
you attack in, then I punch first and
discipline all these things. But it
looks like we're floating two runes
right now. We recycled both
>> and we are going for the punch first.
Okay, so we're going to go in now.
>> I I love that. But I also do think you
you are exploiting an underestimated and
underrated strat. You can charm to base.
You can move that unit anywhere. You can
move it to another battlefield. You can
move it back to base. It really doesn't
matter.
>> But this means that we're we kind of
have to keep committing. So the punch
first has gone through. We have a
discipline in hand.
>> Uh is that two disciplines? I can't
tell. Oh, a challenge.
>> A challenge.
>> Oh, I like this. We're not in a combat
uh phase. There's no action phase here.
So, Blue Flygon cannot use like his own
punch first. He could, this is scary. He
could use like a discipline, but then
Made has his own discipline
>> and quick draw
>> coming out with that uh quick draw.
>> Quick draw is reaction speed. So, Blue
Flygon's actually able to protect this
Jax. I've never actually seen the Jax
use quick draw in quite that method, but
that will be a three bonus to it. So,
even if McKay disciplines here now, it's
going to be a crash. It should be even
12 on 12 if my math is correct.
>> At this point, I think that's something
that you want to take if you are MOD. Um
because uh you don't want to just lose
this unit for no reason. The quick draw
the G.
Oh my, it hurts.
>> And even at Orange Forge, like that
first one you play is cheaper. But we
have an ong guard which will get us over
the hump because G's only plus one. Ong
guard's plus two. So I think that that
means that McKay does win that. G will
proc.
>> This is the most insane thing I think
I've ever seen.
>> What a chain.
>> Oh my gosh. And that's going to be the
G.
>> They do keep everything else. Okay, the
GA is going to be the only thing that
leaves the board here. Um, and we're
going to go in and conquer with that
ruin runner.
>> And this gets the Trinity Force off of
the point, which means the blue flag
will have to get it back onto a
battlefield in order to W score and
double. This has extended the timer for
Made. He's no longer in the hot seat.
Now, it's kind of back to Blue Fly Gun
in the hot seat.
>> Yes, it is. And uh that might isn't
going to go away until uh Made passes
his turn. And I think we're uh just
making sure we've got our runes counted
for as we uh decide if we want to do
anything else here. I'm looking at the
charm. We might want to charm in that
Jack while nothing's equipped. I can't
quite tell. I think it sounded like blue
fly. I I can't tell what exactly was
being said there.
>> He should be healed. Yeah, the the rune
runner I believe should be
>> even in a non-combat showdown. I I from
my understanding he would still heal up
and yeah. Okay. So, I think the Jax is
just down and then we're going to P. Oh,
>> because he charmed in the J after that
altercation.
Oh, and the Ruin Runner is gone as well.
So, I guess we're trading
and we're passing turn. Bluefly is going
to exhaust four runes and bring in
Stella. And three more are going to be
exhausted and we're bringing in a first
mate. We're going to ready that Stella.
And it looks like we might be going in
for something. One more is going to be
exhausted. We're tapping our jacks.
And here we go. We're equipping that
Trinity Force. And it looks like we're
equipping that Dorans. We're doing the
proper cost and we're moving into Raven
Bloom. That Lonely Porro, I do believe
is going to die cuz we did not draw a
spell. Yep.
>> And we're going to draw one off of that
Lonely Borrow. We also had recycled a
lot from Made. I believe that there's
not many runes left here from all the
recycling that happened on that last
incredible chain. And because the judges
didn't say anything, I'm going to just,
you know, default aside with them. Um,
that the the Rune Runner did not heal
after that showdown. Um, again,
reminder, I did fail the judge test.
Anytime [laughter] I I question them,
just remember that. I I am not the
authority in the room by any stretch.
>> We'll do the four uh runes are going to
be exhausted. And that's going to be
game one going over to Blue Fly Gone.
And we're going to reset and get ready
for game two here. Uh there's going to
be a little bit of sideboard action as
we repick our uh battlefields
and we're just going to figure out how
do we want to counter. Yeah, aspirin's
climb is a great one to delay the game.
I love that a lot of decks that you
wouldn't necessarily assume want the
game to go late are actually opting into
this, especially these gear heavy decks,
these equipment heavy decks, because it
just gives you time to ramp them up and
just get to a critical mass cuz the
inherent advantage of having equipment
or gears especially is that you equip
them to your units. Your unit might be
dealt with, but the gears stay. They go
back and you re-equip them. So, the more
of those you accumulate over a game, the
more advantage you can accumulate over a
game. And if you extend the game by
adding an extra point requirement, that
is a really good advantage for the uh
equipment heavy decks.
>> All righty. I'm just trying to take a
peeky at these first hands before we
mulligan. Uh I see a counter strike
illusion adorn blade. And I think I see
I wasn't quite sure on that last hand,
but it looks like blue flaggon is going
to keep his hand while made does
mulligan one. We're gonna go ahead and
channel two and we're gonna go ahead and
drop that
>> desert's call.
>> Desert's call.
>> Gonna go for the one sand soldier. Not
the duplicated one, but hey, it's a
unit. You're happy with it. It's not
quite a lonely porro, but it's
something.
>> All right. And we're going to then on
the side of blue flag gone, we're going
to bring in Lucian and pass the turn.
Made is going to uh channel his two
runes. And we're going to see a certain
Oh, we're writing down. Just trying to
keep tabs on everything. And we're
moving in with that uh sand soldier.
We're going to get that first point. And
let's see. Yep, the four
uh runes are going to be exhausted for
Stella.
>> Now, this is one of those interesting
moments there because there's going to
be a lot of contesting for this Grove of
the Godwillow. If you hold, you draw a
card. There's a world where if I'm the
mass E player and I don't expect to hold
this, I actually go for the aspirin's
climb cuz you're giving your opponent
the decision. Do I go in and kill the
unit or do I get to the contested
battlefield that's really exciting that
I want to hold and you want to hold? So,
you're giving your opponent a choice and
giving them a chance at misplaying as
opposed to giving them the obvious clear
choice, which is, oh, I get to go to the
battlefield. I want to and clear your
unit. So, that's like one of those small
little optimizations that I like to
utilize whenever there's an instance
like this. They don't come up that
often, but it's something to think
about.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And um I'm really
excited to see how he handles this
Lucian who is on the board. Bluefly gone
only has two runes up. It looks like
we're uh exhausting for recycling too.
Are we about to see an auction steal
away that Dorne's blade?
>> It might be. There it is.
>> We sure are.
>> Is that the theme song of Ashan? Uh, I
think it should be.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. But
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Sounds almost copyright territory,
>> but not quite. It's It's just distinct
enough
>> uh that I think you get away with it.
Either way, the silk is going to go into
the asserts glly. Get a draw and a
point.
>> All right. We might have to We might
have to work shop that. We might have to
work shop that. Um, we'll figure it out.
But, um, [laughter]
here we are. Lucian is just standing
there by himself. We're bringing in a
clockwork keeper. Durant.
>> So, we just spent three power from
Made's side there to establish two more
bodies, get a draw and steal a gear that
is a temporary steal. Cuz once on Exon
leaves the field, that gear goes back to
Blue Fly God.
>> What if he never leaves the field? Just
keep Oxan in base forever.
>> True. I mean, he if you play League of
Legends, he swings around. He's kind of
hard to lock down.
>> Exactly. Exactly. Uh I'm curious to see
if that is what is on the uh playing
field unless we're we're swinging with a
certainty such certainty that he cannot
die. Uh but blue flag gone looks like
he's about to exhaust two runes and go
ahead and bring in another lonely porro.
And yes, that's exactly what he's going
to do.
>> Yeah, he got the extra draw from holding
at the grove of the god Willow. playing
the porro to base means that maybe he
leaves the Lucian and he's just passing.
Okay, so to me I I would read that
there's a lot of buffs in his hand like
punch first disciplines things of that
nature cuz leaving the Lucian just
signals that he's confident that that
Lucian will survive or even the the
signature spell which I did spot there.
So counter strike uh can also help
Lucian out.
>> Absolutely. And all of the units are
ready here on the side of Made. Uh we've
got a couple of runes. We've got five
runes up. Let's see what we're trying to
do. We might just be mathing out a
little bit. Trying to make sure that we
can keep everybody safe. We're going to
move that Stellicorn so we can draw one.
I see an two on guard draw in in hand.
Yes, we also have a Thonk just in case
in hand. Um, and I'm not sure about what
else, but
>> I think we're feeling pretty confident,
pretty strong right now on the side of
Micade.
move that uh auction in.
>> I I try and take this SC over the god
Willow. It's so much better and easier
to fend for the Ye anyway. And you just
don't want to give free draws to your
opponent. Chew through their resources.
You have enough resources yourself to
probably beat through anyway. Like this
is going to be six attacking three. Even
the punch first only gives eight
defending on six. Your discipline will
crash it. You give back the the gear,
but then you can like retake the point
again. And I this makes a lot of sense
to me. I think Made's got the right line
in his sights. Let's see what Blue
Flygon has, though, cuz how many? Oh,
that's two.
>> That's two disciplines, but that's also
two on guards on the side of Made. I
think we're trying to just get these
cards out of his hand.
>> It's the only way to do it. I think
you'd have to double discipline, which
means you don't have access to the
counter strike anymore. You won't have
enough runes for it. So, just
counter-strike first. You have the
disciplines.
>> All righty. And so, that auction is
going to move back to base here. Now
that's only counter only defends the
next time it would be dealt damage. So
Mukade can actually go in with his
Clockwork Keeper with all these buffs in
hand and try and still push through. Or
this works too. JK, he's coming back.
You thought he was done. He's swinging
right back like he does in League of
Legends. Uh all because of that first
mate. Really nice play there. It was a
gotcha, but not even with what we
thought it was. We're going to go over
with the clockworker on the other
Aspirants climb and get another point.
>> I think that was the game deciding play
right there. Uh McKay just established
such a lead. There's one lonely porro on
blue flaggon side. He has a G and a
Trinity Force in hand so we can get this
Porro to four attacking with disciplines
on Aan but like still two runes up on
Made side and we know that he's got
enough gas.
>> Yes, honestly that lonely Porro is
looking pretty lonely. might be
exhausting living up to the name.
>> Yeah. Oh, nope. Jax is coming out. We're
recycling one and we've got three runes
to play with. There is a Stella in hand,
but unfortunately that costs four. So,
he's going to pass that turn.
>> Patient play.
>> Yes. Two points going over to Made for
holding both battlefields.
>> And we're going to see what he wants to
do with this.
>> Now, I at first I was like, "Oh, he
didn't play the G." Then I remembered
quick draw. Jax gives all of your
equipment in hand uh quick draw. So you
can just do it when you get a reaction
window from your opponent unless doesn't
give him a reaction window in which case
that is going to be some wasted uh runes
there on blue Flygon's side. I think
there's maybe an argument that you just
play it onto the jacks right now. But
let's see if Made gives him one. He
actually will move in, trigger the
Celicorn, draw a card. No reaction from
Blue Flygon there.
So still holding that reaction. All
right, we're tapping five and we're
going to end up playing Ireelia to base
and then we're going to move Aan back.
So, we're really trying to play it safe
here. Just make sure that we keep these
units in hand because we just need two
more points.
>> Oh, not putting the pit rook or the
sorry, not pit rookie. I always get pit
rookie and first mate confused. I don't
know why they're not even close to the
same name. First mate, though, um
surprised that McKay didn't put him out.
He's still got the buffs in hand and it
forces Blue Flygon to at least commit
resources to establish control over one
of these battlefields.
>> Absolutely. There's a lot of catchup
that has to be done here by Bluefly
Gone. There's a lot of units on the side
of Made that reconquering for this uh
the next two might be kind of easy.
There's uh Zach's on the board. There's
the Lonely Porro and we know there's a
Stella inside hand. Are we gonna try and
play that out to the field immediately?
>> It almost feels like MK is saving
resources to do a really big Aurelia
push because she's gonna be five might
when she readies and then if you use
your buffs on her, she gets an
additional plus one might every time you
target her with something. So
potentially that's the strategy for like
nope, I have so many resources. He's so
far behind and it's aspirin's climb
anyway. So it's not like I'm threatening
to win on the next turn. Let's just
conserve some resources. Um, which again
I I like highlighting when players are
patient and have patient play as opposed
to going for the aggressive play.
Absolutely. Uh, which is typically again
just my my kind of default here. But
yeah, again I do also want to highlight
blue flag did not get use out of those
three runes that he had uh up on his
last turn. So could have had a G also on
top of everything else. Either way, the
Jax will go in and get a point.
>> All right, it looks like we're going to
start in uh buffing up some uh units
here. So, we're going to go ahead and
discipline and bring in the counters to
give the plus two to the lonely borrow.
We might be disciplining one more time.
Beep bop boop. Oh, nope. We're bringing
out the Trinity Force. We're going to
equip that to the Lonely Coro and move
in to try and take down the Stellicorn.
It's interesting if you our plan was to
put the uh equipment on anyway. You
could try and maybe bait out like a on
guard or a discipline from Made,
but now you're showing the six mites.
And now Made has information and knows
what's required here. I guess it
wouldn't have made that big of a deal
cuz it's still going to be double on
guard here. Or
was it on guard already played?
>> Um there.
>> Oh, the plus two from defending for Ye.
Of course. Of course.
>> Yes. Uh, everybody always forgets about
that. It's it's something that is
commonly overlooked, but yes, uh,
because of the legend of Master Yi, a
friendly unit that is at a battlefield
alone defending gets plus two to my
automatically.
>> I need to go back and relearn origins.
>> No, man. [laughter] I I feel like but
that is so good on the side of Master Yi
and I feel like that's why he's been
underestimated because of that very nice
legend making these units a little bit
tankier.
>> That and Ari is also the one that
blindsides people. I always forget about
Ari and when I do my math attacking I'm
like oh right now I'm not one.
>> Um but yeah the Ye of course defends
much harder than it uh attacks. So
defending successfully feels great.
You're at seven points. You can score
one more if you can take this jack as
up. Thank you. Thank you for reminding
everyone what Ari does in case you were
confused. Um I I have Yeah. lost many
locals to this this legend.
>> Yes. And I think Oshan is coming out.
Grab that Trinity course. Anytime I see
four runes exhausted and two orange
runes going away, I know my boy is
coming out to play. He is absolutely
fantastic at just taking all the gear.
You thought you were going to have gear
on the board. Uh, why is all of your
gear on the side of Master Yi? That's
>> Yeah, th those sleeves don't match. No,
>> they're blue on the other side.
>> Exactly. And that's why I love Aan so
much because now that Jax is open for uh
taking so the Ireelia is going to move
in here. Oh, but you know one thing
about Jax, that quick draw, the GA is
going to come back out. But we have an
answer for that. And so Made is going to
on guard and uh choose that Ireelia to
give a little bit more might.
>> Uh I believe should be Oh, so choosing
to give the plus two. Let's see if the
spell resolves. And it looks like it
will. And now punch first. I like that.
Mage is past pryo though. That was
that's crazy. You're tagging him with a
five Aelia. Pass pryo on the five jack
to be like you play something first.
>> Yeah.
>> Like I'm not going to give you any
information. I'm happy to crash this. I
have enough units outside of that. But
the punch first will be too much for
Made to get over.
>> Yes. And we're just looking for the one
point.
We just want the one point. But we're
going to move that Stellicorn back.
We're going to draw one. Uh we're we're
dwindling down on resources. We've got
four up on the side of Made. Looking to
see, but Bluefly Gone is out at this
point. No more runes to play with. So,
we're going to first mate. We're going
to ready. We're going to move that again
to draw. And I see we just got that
punch first. So it gets a little bit
scarier here cuz five might go on the
board anywhere.
>> Yeah, that Jax was still 11 might from
the punch first earlier. So Axan could
have gone in and traded, but then you
give back the Dorne's blade. Don't
necessarily want to do that just to get
through the GA. So Blue Fly Gun will at
least get one more turn. McKade just
needs two points to win and that would
uh Yeah. Uh what a what a game two that
would be. Yes, exactly. Uh let's see
here. We've got all of our runes back
up. We're shuffling through the cards
just trying to determine how do we want
to tackle this beast that is the mighty
units on the side of McCain. So, we're
exhausting four runes. And are we
recycling too to take back some take
them back?
>> There's no way.
>> Take back. Yes. Recycle those. Show him
what was originally yours. The Trinity
Force is coming back to the side of
Blue. Do you see why I love Ouxan?
>> Now, now you know what's hilarious. I
believe
um
>> so yes, if I pay the addition glass,
move an enemy gear to your base. You
control it until I leave the board. So
there's a really funny sequence where if
Made kills the Akan
Oh no, but we Yeah. Yeah. So if we kill
the Akan, Akan leaves the board. Trinity
Force should, I believe, go back to the
control of Made even though it belongs
to Blue Fly Gun. Blue Fly Gun would then
have to kill the Axan that took it
originally to wrestle control back.
>> Oh.
>> Oh my gosh.
>> It's a really funny sequence that can
happen here. And the the Axons versus
each other can get really wacky.
>> Um,
>> but I think the Made has so much that I
I don't even know if this it's going to
be that relevant because Made just held
for a point and can now just punch in
for this last one. I want to ask you
here, the Trinity Force has been
equipped to Jax here. Why was it not
automatically equipped?
>> It was automatically and then he used
the Jax Legend Grand Arms to move it to
the Jax. Yes. Good, good question,
though.
>> Good. Absolutely.
>> Oh, wa. Heyo, McKade.
Yeah. Again, the patient play. He says,
"No, I'm not going to attack in tier
what uh 6 7 8 that's 12. 12 defending.
I'm gonna instead just go for the hold
and make you come into me because they
don't have a lot of ganking options in
Jax. Like maybe you can move one back
and then first mate to ready it, but
that's not going to be hitting in for
very much. This is actually a really
smart move from a cage to just guarantee
the win.
>> Absolutely. [snorts] And I want to
remind the folks at home, uh, Aspire's
climb does make the game go one point
longer. So that is not a typo on the
board. It is eight points. And yes,
we're going to go ahead and charm into
this mighty mighty Aspirants climb.
>> And we have to defy.
>> What if we defy it? What if it never
goes off at all?
>> And so we're going to go ahead and make
sure that Master Yi is on the board as
well. We've got a lot of Mike over on
aspirants climb and there's something
that has to be done or else he wins.
Blue Fly gone. Big pressure in this game
number two. Did take game one. So, we'll
go to a game three if McCade gets this
ninth point.
>> Let's see. I do see a first punch in or
punch first in [laughter] hand. You
know, it could go even, you know,
honestly, it's kind of the same
information.
>> Whoa.
>> Tiana
round card.
>> That'll do it.
>> Uhoh.
>> So, no more points. You got something
that you got to deal with and it's Tiana
Crownard. When this is at a battlefield,
your opponent cannot score points. So,
you've got to deal with Tiana.
>> You've got to deal with Tiana.
>> She's got a GA on her. So, you've got to
deal with Tiana dose times. Unless you
have a third auction in here,
>> baby. It's about to get rough.
>> I'm going to walk it back.
>> Walk it back.
>> I'm going to I'm going to say, Made, uh,
I'm on your side. I did not read the
Tiana either. Yeah,
>> that is the one punish for this
decision. You're saying, "Okay, you're
not going to be able to move around and
get me off of this point."
>> Bluefly gun doesn't have to. Tiana
prevents Made from scoring and Blue Fly
Gun will hold for two more points with
this Trinity Force to eight, but that's
not going to be enough to win either.
So, Made does have kind of two turns to
figure this out. But if you move stuff
back to base to then threaten the Tiana
on the next turn, that gives Blue Flygon
an easier point to go and contest then.
I I still think Made's in a good spot
here overall because just like the way
that the the timing of these turns is
going to work out and how we can move
stuff around. And also challenge will be
great here, too.
>> So, we're going to go ahead and try and
get rid of this GA and we're going to
move Tiana back to base. And so, uh
she's not out of battlefield right now.
>> Nope. You can now score.
>> Yep.
>> But do we have enough? I mean, we're
going to have to really buff up this
Celicorin to punch through. 7 + 4 is
>> 11. That one I was a little slower. I'm
I'm slowing down on the math today.
>> 11 holding right now.
>> There are two punch firsts in hand. I
do. No.
>> Yes, he does have the two punch first
and that is going to be the game.
>> Okay. Well, that was exciting.
>> That was honestly these are two really
big uh mighty uh just like decks in
general. These punch bursts can really
turn the tides on both sides.
>> I love how they're laughing, too. This
is some great sportsmanship on stage
right now.
>> They know that was crazy. They know.
They know those last couple turns like
the Tiana coming out. The two punch
first. Bat bat back. Come on. The ox
shots coming out stealing the dors
stealing the trinity force. Stealing it
again.
>> It was stolen back.
>> Yeah, it was it was a lot of back and
forth.
>> Give me back my Trinity Force.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. McCade um I mean he was joking
like Yeah. the the Tiana was crazy and
then blue flaggon I think I heard him
say like yeah that's won me a lot of
matches like just people don't expect it
coming down and I got to say I would not
expect that either in the J build I you
expect it or you expected an Ari don't
necessarily expect it in J
>> and I see why he has it yeah I can see
how it can win him some games because
that was an absolutely stellar play
probably made a little bit scared there
but we're getting into game number three
now this is the game deciding match both
blue flag gone and Made have scored one
uh match point. So, we're uh
>> we're going to see what happen here.
Yeah,
>> bad start for Blue Flygon. Not getting a
unit or a gear on your first turn means
that you're going to be a little behind
on the tempo here as McKay does get the
lonely porro. Okay, we're going to catch
up a little bit here with uh two sand
soldiers. I'm going to imagine the blue
flaggon didn't have that last turn.
Otherwise, you probably just throw it
out there so that you can try and uh get
the point advantage. But either way,
it's going to be Made getting on the
battlefield one turn earlier.
>> Absolutely. So, the Lonely Porro is
going to go ahead and move into the
sunken temple. And uh we're going to go
ahead and score first blood here for
Made. And we've got five uh runes to
play with. So, we're going to exhaust
three. And yes, the first mate is going
to come out and we're going to go ahead
and ready the lonely porro and pass our
turn to blue flag.
>> Okay, so I I guess Made's hand. I can't
quite see what's in there, but he just
wants another unit on the field. Also
crucially, a unit that can test a
singular sand soldier. So blue flag gun
is going to have to commit both of these
or have like other buffs. I do see some
in hand that are going to be answers.
Also multiple first mates of his own.
Notably not pit crew.
>> Not pit rookie for sure. I don't think
he has any pit rookies. I do see how you
could think it's a pit rookie cuz it is
orange. It is a lower.
>> No, wait. You You got it. You found the
bridge cuz pit crew is the blue unit.
Pit rookie is that one. There's a line.
Wait, Reagan, you solved my brain.
That's why I don't know why that pro
riffbound player.
>> I don't know if you could.
>> Are you a psychologist?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Yes, I I feel like you This is a
breakthrough for me. You can ask my
roommate Sam. He's like, "I call these
things the wrong thing all the time."
Yeah.
>> And I think I just found the the link.
>> Yep. That's
>> okay. Well, what did I miss in the game?
I feel like I just went on a self
discovery.
>> Out. There was uh four runes uh or five
runes exhausted and one recycled to
bring out Jax to come to play. Uh so
we've got three units on the side of
Bluefly gone. But it is now time for
McKay to go ahead and move that first
mate in to score a third point. Yeah,
bluefly gun not committing the sand
soldiers out. Would rather keep the
units than sacrifice them to like a
discipline or something. So if you're
establishing the jacks that means you
will not be able to defend it with your
own spells. I did see defy in hand
though. So yeah, bluefly again very
patient play right there. That's that's
one of those moments that differentiates
the 5's from the rest of the field. You
know, like there's a reason Blue Flygon
is undefeated right now. Clearly uh
understands his deck and understands the
matchups. But those are the types of
decisions that I think are like really
interesting to analyze and break down.
>> And boom. It does not matter right now.
Charm is going to go ahead and come out
as he's going to try and charm in uh the
I believe the sand soldier. I'm not sure
if he tried to charm the Jacks into the
first mate, but we're going to go ahead
and see that defy. So, we're not even
going to see it uh come to fruition
here. So, that's going to resolve.
That's not going to go off. Um, I do see
on the side of the cade. I'm really
trying to take a peek at that hand. Did
I see an auction? Did I see a punch
first? I think I did.
>> I think I see a punch first. Yes.
>> I I really feel like that's a auction.
So, we might be saving.
>> Now I'm doing it. Now I'm the right to
try and peek into the hands.
>> I'm seeing that aon once we finally get
the gear on the board. So, we're
probably saving that. So, we're going to
pass over and Bluefly Gone is going to
start his turn by channeling those two
runes per usual, drawing for turn. And
we're going to move the jacks in for the
lonely porro.
>> Yep. That's going to be five on the four
defending, which means that Made will
have to do something if he wants to keep
this alive.
>> And he is he's going to go ahead and uh
exhaust two runes to discipline the
lonely Porro. Now, uh because it is
defending alone, it does get that
additional plus two. And so the
discipline is going to come out as well
for the Jax. So Jax is sitting at seven
might while the Porro is sitting at six.
Ong guard coming out on the side of
McCabe. So we're going to get Oh Lord
have mercy. Another defy. This is the
craziest secret.
>> We here to game.
>> Yes, we are. The Defy is actually going
to stop that on guard. So the lonely
Porro after using all of those resources
might just have to die here. Is there
anything left to do? I imagine not, but
keep in mind will get a draw off of this
and still holds the other point and is
still ahead by two points once Flygon
conquers.
>> No way he punches first for Lonely
Porro. Okay. All right. So, we still get
value like you said. We get value out of
that. And we just drew a Stella. So,
that's that's still pretty good. You
trade your little lonely portal for a
Stella. I I think we can take that.
>> It's most effective with another first
mate. again. Blue Flygon passes, saving
the units, not chewing through his own
uh resources on the back row, but that
is two turns in a row where I really do
feel like maybe well I at this point it
is four tanking in on five defending. So
you'd have to use your own um cards in
hand to to try and punch through that.
But yeah, blue flag on very very patient
player.
>> All right, I saw the four exhausted and
I was like no way he auctionons.
Correct. Because Stella is going to come
out to play. When she moves, you get to
draw one. So, this is a very, very good
card. Especially right now, we want to
just get more cards on the side of Made.
And uh we are going to pass our turn.
Blue Fly Gone is going to go ahead and
ready uh channel and draw.
>> And again, it's coming down to one of
those concepts that I had talked about
earlier on stream that just cuz your
opponent has an out doesn't mean that
you can deal with it. Sometimes you just
got to chew through the out. Now, that
would be an expensive chew for a blue
fly gun. Like, if he sends in the two
sand soldiers and they trade punch first
and you lose two sand soldiers, you're
basically trading down three for one.
Um, cuz you're losing two of your units
plus a spell. But eventually, you will
have to get out there. You're not going
to win this game by holding one point
unless you get like maybe two Trinity
Forces or something. But it looks like
he's just going to be using the jacks.
He's even giving another battlefield to
Micade if he doesn't reinforce that. Oh,
okay. No, we're we're we're going to get
in. We're we're starting the aggression,
I have to imagine.
>> Yes, the first mate is going to allow
him to go ahead and reready that uh Jax
and going ahead and counter striking to
make sure that damage uh is going to be
prevented.
>> So, this means that they would crash.
It's five attacking five. Jax won't take
the damage.
Let's see if Made wants to do anything.
Now, keep in mind, we know that both of
these players have punch first. It would
just still be a trade of punch first and
still the uh first mate. I almost said
pit crew again. Still the first mate
would go down. Jax would not.
>> Yes. I also kind of just want to point
out all of bluefly's uh runes, I don't
know if it matters right now, are
orange, but we're getting the thon.
>> That works, too. So, we're going to stop
the damage from Jax as well, cuz that
flon is going to stun an attacking unit.
paid the deflect cost, but well worth
it. Made will hold for a fifth point,
can move the Celicorn in for a sixth
point, draw a card off of it, and then
is threatening a in a very, very scary
position on the blue flag gun, who now
feels the pressure. Now moves the uh uh
sand soldiers in and even develops a
lonely poro.
>> Yes. So, he still gets to get at least
one point here before passing his turn.
But now Made is probably going to want
to move that Stella corn to go ahead and
draw after channeling these runes here.
Another Stella was just drawn from a
turn. But we're going to think about how
do we want to play this at uh five
points here.
I imagine
we could see the accelerated Ye. There's
no runes for blue fly gun. You can just
send the Yei into the two sand soldiers.
get the guaranteed point. Move the
Stellicorn and the first mate so that
you get the Stellicorn draw and you
still are defending for the plus two.
That That's one of the lines that I'm
seeing. I don't see all the cards in
Made's hand though. So, let's see what
the the player decides to do. I feel
like every time I say, "Oh, they could
do this." Then the player's like, "No, I
got something much better instead."
>> No, they have been pulling out some Uno
reverses for real. For real. Uh, but it
looks like as we're gearing up to make a
play here,
I kind of want to analyze because Blue
Flygon is showing his hand here. We've
got a lonely porro in there. Like we
said, we have the first or punch first.
Um,
oh well, that deck is completely turned
over. I'm not seeing insight at all
anymore. I think we're passing. Are we
passing? I think this makes if you if
again decision making like in decision
trees often times you do the thing that
you know you're always going to do first
which sometimes is move the Celicorn but
no we are going to go for the master
first instead. We're going to send it in
and then we can also get a draw off of
this which again maybe changes our
decision from sending the Cellicorn in.
I love it whenever you're like okay
let's do the things that I know I want
to do and get the draws before I do
anything else. Although now I'm
realizing did I have them off? Is it
biom layer? No, it is um sunken temple.
>> Yeah. No, you're correct.
>> But he's not going to spend the rune. So
going to save it for I assume the punch
first in hand. Still send the Celicorn
in. That's nine defending on the sunken
temple and five defending from first
mate on the vile Mosair who also cannot
move back. I That's a good point. Also,
I was just mentioning that you can swap
them. You cannot do that with the Bomos
layer.
>> Yes. Uh cannot move from here to base is
Ball's layers uh text there. Shout out
to everybody, the the people pulling
these cards up, by the way. They're
doing a fantastic job. They're even like
they're they're poking fun at us
playfully. I appreciate it.
>> And they're also been very educational
with it, too.
>> Absolutely. Yo, we appreciate you. We
rely on you cuz sometimes I forget what
the text is uh verbatim. And you've been
you've been coming in clutch. So, shout
out to you. Uh truly appreciate you. As
we see that uh Blue Fly Gone is going to
go ahead and bring out a TA. I was just
going to say we need a card they can
throw to acknowledge a sauce and they
showed one. All right,
>> that is so cute.
>> We got a lot of combat going on though
here. This is what six
>> uh eight I skipped one of those numbers
intentionally. Uh and then 11
>> 11 might attacking in on nine currently.
>> Oh my gosh. So, we are going in heavy
here and we're going in strong as well
cuz that guardian angel is going to make
sure if something does happen, if
something that we did not plan for
happens, Jax can still go home safe and
sound.
And we know that there's a punch first
from Micade.
We know that there's a punch first for
Blue Fly Gun. They don't know that. It's
all about the mind games. And it looks
like Made's maybe just going to save it.
Yeah. So, both of them pass priority.
We're going to deal with the guardian
angel and leave the lonely porro there.
>> Lonely
>> taking out the uh first mate instead of
the lonely porro. So that means that
there is a draw potential for blue fly
gun. Now
>> the lonely the lonely porro is there
>> lonely. That's very uh very true to the
lore of lonely porro. Uh
>> look at all the lonely porros. Where
have they gone wrong? Where where have
they come from? What's the Beatles song?
>> No. Lonely people. No. I'm so sorry. to
reference. Sorry. 67.
[laughter] Sorry, I forgot forgot the
company I'm keeping.
>> You're so dumb for that. Oh my gosh. Um,
so the Jax is going to move into Ba's
layer and go ahead and clear that, but
Jax will die during the exchange because
again, Master Yi plus two on the first
mate because he was defending alone. Uh,
so we just got the first mate in the
Lonely Porro on the side of Bluefly
gone. uh in terms of unoccupied uh units
on the side of Made. We're going to go
ahead and bring out that Ireelia after
exhausting five runes. We are seeing
also just I want to say a beautiful game
of chicken.
>> Both of these players have had a punch
first in hand for what three turns and
every time one says pass priority, the
other says okay pass bet. You know I I'm
not going to play it if you're not going
to play it. And I eventually someone has
to play one. Someone's got to do it.
They definitely know that it's going to
cancel out, but it's such an expensive
spell in terms of having to recycle
those two orange, but you also both of
these players, as you know, are running
that auction. So, those oranges are also
going to be a good point. So, you kind
of want to keep those oranges in your uh
in your rune stack uh just in case. Now,
I do think that there are auctions on
the side of the cave, but there are none
in the hand of Legon right now. Also,
neither one has gears. And remember that
blue flag got put in. Made does not play
any equipment save for two zonas in
deck. This is a spellheavy master ed,
not an equipment. He didn't even have a
Trinity Force main deck. So, I think
there's a really good chance that Blue
Flygon, he only got value out of his
Exon because McDade stole the Trinity
Force with his exon.
>> Exactly.
>> So, if Blue Flygon doesn't play in
equipment, I don't think he's ever going
to get advantage from his own Exon cuz
Mccade's not going to play in equipment
either. Exactly. But you know, Bluefly
gone kind of in the power position right
now. The Lonely Porros are holding it
down on both uh battlefields. But once
we pass over Okay, we're getting good
intel on this hand right now. We got the
Stella punch first and a defy that is.
And the Ruin Runner might
>> It hasn't It hasn't hit yet. Chest
rules. He hasn't let go.
>> Okay, there. Just like that, it can no
longer be chosen by enemy spells and
abilities up there on sunken temple.
>> And that is more notable for the Master
Yi cuz we're talking about like orange
green not having that many spells that
will target. Uh Made has been playing a
lot of the charms and the challenges. Uh
and doesn't have the equipments to help
hit over the rune runner, which is
typically the way that you deal with it.
So Made's going to maybe need like a I
don't know, I guess a Tasty Fay folk. I
think we saw one of those. I don't
remember exactly what units he had that
can go and accelerated. Aurelia actually
on field is probably the best target for
it to just go in and start swinging.
>> Absolutely. And we moved that first mate
in just to do a little bit of
reinforcement on the lonely porro over
at Val. But now that it's there, it
cannot move. It cannot move from there
to base. So, uh if you want to go over
there, you're going to have to uh pay
the price.
>> No more lonely porros. They got buddies.
>> They got buddies. And I love to see it.
But it looks like Made just drew a
Ruined Runner of his own. Will it come
out to play is what I want to find out.
>> Made's got more time to play with cuz
Blue Flygon needs two turns to win. You
hold two points even if uh Becc does
nothing. But that's not enough. You you
need one more after that. Made is the
one that has the option to win the game
in one turn. And with how much he's been
conserving resources, I have to imagine
that is the game plan. It's like I'm not
going to use the punch first until it is
absolutely necessary to find the win.
This Aelia has one bonus might. It's
four base plus one for readying at the
start of the turret. It'll gain an
additional one might anytime it's
targeted. And a lot of the Master Yi
spells do target that.
>> I think he's ready. I think he's ready
to use it. I think we're going to see it
here. Uh, the Ireelia is going to go
over to Vile Maus with
boot bop beat bop bow.
>> Okay,
>> Stella corn.
>> So now you don't have to use a buff
spell on the Aurelia.
>> Yeah, that's
>> you can just pass priority if you want
to. I still think it's probably worth it
to do so cuz you'd rather the Celicorn
die here than the Aurelia because
Aurelia will just be so hard for blue
flag gun to punch through. Again, I just
want to keep reminding people I've been
wrong like five times this [laughter]
series alone cuz these guys just keep
doing stuff. Okay, here we go.
>> And there it is.
>> He finally played it. Everyone take a
sigh of relief.
>> And you know that's what uh Bluefly gone
is going to have to respond with. He's
going to have to respond.
>> Oh, and JK, we're just going to let that
resolve.
>> Blue Flygon is still playing chicken
with it. He's like, "Nah, no. I'm
committed.
>> Absolutely.
>> I'm going to win this game without a
punch first." Now he's going to have to
use it at some point, but it's going to
be uncontested. I think that's the hope
here is that now you've seen the punch
first. Actually, how many have we seen
from Made? Is that two? The game's gone
on for a while now.
>> Yeah, I remember they were putting them
down last game, so it's kind of fuzzy
for me, not going to lie. Uh, Clockwork
Keeper is going to come out to base
right now as we are going to exhaust
four runes. Oh,
>> probably Ruin Runner, I imagine. Rune
Runner to Vile Mos, I think, or space.
Okay.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. So, now we have the option to hit
in twice and Blue Flygon still cannot
win on this next turn. Blue Flygon will
minimum need two turns to win. Made now
can either hold or conquer twice on his
turn.
>> Yes, indeedy. And we're going to go
ahead and channel those two runes and
draw for turn. We've got Oh, that's the
I love to see it. They're just like, "Oh
man, I wasn't getting the cards that I
needed." But Made is going to go ahead
and be victorious here.
>> Yeah. And it did come down to the
differential of the punch first cuz the
Aurelia gets a bonus one might when you
target her with punch first. Meaning
that you will always win the punch first
battles. I was I was honestly feeling a
little bit of anxiety. Every time they
just did not punch first. I like when is
it going to happen? When is going to
happen? Made showed do it when you know
you're going to win the fight. And he
did just that. Great reserve play from
Cade. Incredible patience and a
well-deserved win.
>> Absolutely. But honestly, I just think
that that game was so much fun to watch
in a sense of like there was so much
back and forth and the players are
smiling there afterwards. So, it felt
like they also knew that they were just
playing amazing Riftbound.
>> Yeah. And they were both exo at that
point. They were 5 and0. So, Made's now
6 and0. Uh but his opponent still 5-1.
Very respectable score. and uh a Jax. I
mean, like this is a really not one of
the more popular legends to be playing
right now. Uh it was not on a lot of
people's radars. And the Tiana tech in
the main deck was very exciting to see.
It didn't quite get him across the
finish line, but it was close.
>> Yeah. No, and I think it's really
interesting because speaking about the
Jacks, a lot of people do count out Jax.
I've heard so much yip yap in these
streets talking about Jax is not good.
Um he's 5-0. Well, five and one, but
honestly, he's been putting it down.
Obviously, the tech that he has is
cooking. So, there's possibility that
this man can actually do something.
>> That is the beauty of a game like
Riftbound is that you can play your
favorite unit or just a unit that not
many other people are playing to make
deep runs, prove people wrong, and go
for that best of metal card. But, I'm
hearing that we have an interview ready
with McCade. I want to hear his thoughts
on saving that punch first for as long
as he did.
Thanks so much for tossing that over.
Incredible game that we got to witness
and an incredible battle of the calm and
body domains. And I've got the winner of
that battle right here. Mukade,
congratulations. And first and foremost,
6 and0 now. You officially locked in for
day two, no matter what happens in these
next two rounds. How does that feel?
>> That feels great. Uh this is my first
like major tournament, so it's nice to
be suo.
>> Yeah. I mean, and you did such an
incredible performance. You played an
incredible game or match alto together.
Game one obviously a little rough. Giant
jacks couldn't really deal with it. But
I think games two and three, you really
proved why maybe Master Yi is still kind
of the winner of those domains right now
because your list is really, really
interesting. Our casters kind of talked
about it. We were kind of talking about
it beforehand, but you're not playing
things like Trinity Force that we saw a
little have success in Leo last week.
you instead have a huge spell and sort
of buff focus, which is similar to how
this deck played in Origins a little,
but it really worked out for you. You
both get to play these cards like Ashan
and you get to win off of them and
they're over here just having to steal
back the equipment that they have. Why
that decision?
>> So, I played in the pre- regional
yesterday.
>> Yeah.
>> And I went four and two. I was playing
two two trinity forces. Um,
a lot of the Dravens and Profil decks
have started to tech in a lot of like uh
factory recall.
>> Yeah,
>> that returns the gear to your hand. I
can't be spending four runes and a power
on on a Trinity Force to have it one
energy to return it to my hand and then
have to replay it. So, because they were
all teched for probably the Azir matchup
that won last last week.
>> Yeah. and the the Yeis that also did
well last week. Uh I decided that
Trinity Force was los lose losing me
more games than it was winning me games.
So I took them out for two challenges
last night.
>> Wow. And the challenges came in clutch,
especially that Tiana that came down
game two. We we all went like, "Oh my
goodness, you did this in great play.
You loaded up the one battlefield and
then you had the answer to it. You ended
up winning it and then taking us to game
three." But that insight is so amazing
because you've literally proved it
literally today. You went 4 and2
yesterday in the pre- regional, adapted,
made changes, and six rounds later, the
same amount of games you played, you're
already doing better and undefeated. So
Matt,
>> incredible match, incredible game, but
your day isn't over yet. What are you
trying to avo What are you trying to
avoid for the these last two rounds here
and maybe end the day 8 and0?
>> Uh Draven.
>> Okay. Uh it's not unwinable, but I think
it is favored into into him. All of his
his cards are just better than my cards.
Uh if he draws like axe full falling
stars, my two early drops and then also
has like rebuke on my Y turn.
>> Yeah.
>> The game kind of just ends on on the
spot. I can still win it if I get ahead,
but it it is the one I've ch I've
struggled with the most.
>> Absolutely. Makes a lot of sense. But
you proved it here in this match that
you know how to punch first against the
other decks that are sporting the same
domains. Hukkott, congrats again for
your match win. Hopefully we'll see you
tomorrow. Of course we will. You've
already locked it in. We'll send it back
to the casters.
>> Dude, I love it so much. I love the uh
punch first there, Barry. That that was
good. But uh we need to point out this
one thing, y'all. Uh, Deckless were to
be submitted midnight last night. That
man just said that he subbed out those
Trinity Forces for the two challenges
and those were such amazing cards. Holy
moly, he cooked up.
>> I I got to say most duelists, most
players when I talk to them and they
make these last minute changes like,
"Ah, I just want to like do this one
thing and like it wasn't feeling right
the day before." It's like a gut
reaction and then they regret it. This
was a really solid meta call. Like his
logic was sound of like, oh, I'm just
losing to all these other tech like the
main deck decks. A lot of the yellow
decks are on salvage main deck, too. So,
it's like, yes, the theoretical strength
of Trinity 4 as a master is crazy. But
if everyone reads it, and that's
expected to be played. People are going
to be prepared for it. What they're not
going to be prepared for is a master,
which again, I promise you, it's
happened at least once where somebody
had gear hate in their sideboard and was
like, "Master, he's going to have
Trinity Forces." He just didn't draw
them. So, I'm gonna side the gear Hayden
anyway. And then it does nothing. Like,
that's such a cool heads up play. I love
it.
>> Absolutely. And I mean, we pointed this
out before the game even started. That
was not your regular schmegular Master E
deck. No.
>> So, he obviously has crafted up such a
masterful uh deck that has gotten him.
>> Uh,
>> so you can make these jokes, but I can't
say 67.
>> Yes.
Anyways, we're going to throw it over to
a match analysis with pastry time.
>> I don't know if that was
>> Thank you so much, Miss Chimch. What a
pretty incredible series. I feel like it
was looking a little one-sided at
certain points. Jack's looking great in
game one and game two will look a little
spicy. Let's have a look because this is
the game we're going to focus the most
on. First things first, you can kind of
see six points to two not looking all
that good here in the game. It feels
like again Jack was able to get off to a
good start in the first one and now Yi
is kind of at the point you know what I
played all my units I got in the early
point lead I was on the play going first
I stole your equipment with Archan I
have an Aelia ready to go and this Jax
is looking I don't know pretty scary but
not all that interesting so let's move
on actually to the next clip because
this exchange that happens as Fon is
trying to kind of play things out and
get and kind of get it going and arrest
control back in this game is kind of the
thing I'm really interested So, let's
play it out here and kind of show what
happens cuz there's a decent amount of
stuff going on. So, player shuffling
cards again, two calm decks. So,
definitely a lot of interaction between
these two. This jack is kind of scary.
First mate going to go ahead move up
that silicon. Move on in. We're feeling
good. Feeling great.
And uh again, moving towards the points
now. Important thing to note, this game
would be very very scary if Aspirin's
climb wasn't one of the battlefields cuz
already at seven points. Ye getting one
more point feels pretty easy. But we are
playing to nine and this jacks on this
bottom battlefield is looking pretty
fearsome.
So going back through a lot of different
interactive cards and all of a sudden I
spy something that I don't see very
often in Jack decks.
Find it in just a second cuz uh if I'm
the Y player, I'm feeling amazing at
this point. I feel like there's nothing
that can possibly go wrong in this
situation.
And uh spoiler alert, that is not the
case cuz I don't think anyone expects
what's about to happen next. Tap a
couple runes. Feeling good. Feeling
great.
And uh Ashan's going to go ahead and
take things back. Think we could speed
the clip up a little bit. I think we can
speed our playback. If we can do that,
we can go ahead and do that cuz we have
a little bit more to move through here.
And this not quite. Keep going. We'll
speed ahead a little bit further forward
here. So bottom battlefield looking all
right. Again, trying to deny eight
points now for the E player. And again,
feels like okay, I only have to get one
more point. That doesn't feel so bad.
Okay, let's sorry. move it back to uh
this point now and Y is in play looking
good and we're trying to have an
exchange. So, charm has happened
trying to coax a unit forward. And
again, I'm feeling great in this if I'm
a U player. And there's the problem
card. Tiana on that bottom battlefield.
And all of a sudden, you can look in the
player cam by the way, top right hand
corner, Y is like, I don't know what's
going on here. I'm not feeling good
about what just happened. Tiana pretty
much turning this game entirely around.
And even though we're at eight points
again, if this was a a regular
eight-point game without Aspirin's
climb, oh boy, are we in trouble. But
instead, it's uh Tiana being the
problem. But I think we can figure it
out cuz we move forward now to the next
clip. And uh some pretty funny stuff
happens cuz how do you get through all
of this stuff? Cuz not only is there a
ton of M on one battlefield, we have to
deal with this Tiana. So challenge is
going to be where we kick things off. We
can play the clip out. So first problem
dealt with. There is a G on this Tiana,
but remember Tiana has to be at a
battlefield for her effect to be
relevant. So now what we have to do is
figure out how to score on this other
battlefield. And this E player has got a
pretty uh fun solution. And I think a
lot of people when they play against the
orange players not too big of a fan of
this card cuz it's pretty powerful. And
there are definitely more copies over
this card in this year list than we
typically see. So again, thinking
through how we going to get over here
trying to figure it out. Punch first
one. Punch first two. Yeah, okay.
That'll be enough. Plus 10 might and
that's going to be our game. So game two
kind of close at some point. It felt
like G was running away with it. Tiana
felt like she was maybe able to equalize
and instead that double punch after that
challenge was able to sort out the
problem. So game number three, we're
going to get through into the middle
section of this game cuz this is where I
feel like things start turning around.
So quick pausing the screen. You can see
there's a charm right in the middle and
that charm is actually trying to move
this jack into the uh into the
battlefield with the first mate over
here. And uh we'll play the clip now and
you can see that Jack does not want this
to happen. So uh thinking thinking
again, this actually be a trade right
now cuz it's three plus the two from the
Y legend. Jack is a five defies the
charm and he says okay that seems fine
with me. But I think it's these next few
things that get kind of interesting
because he's going to look at the hand.
See, maybe do I want to keep going here.
What do I want to do? Looking back,
looking forth again. Really wanted to
get rid of this jack. It's kind of a big
unit and he does want to hold. Three
point three-point lead right now. Feels
pretty good for the E. So, not too much
to worry about as far as tempo goes, but
does want to kind of keep up the
momentum here. And Jax is trying to find
a way to crawl back into the game. So,
passes it back. And then Jax has to
consider, okay, what do I want to do? I
know you want to get rid of my jacks.
You just started to char it in using
that first defy. But the thing about
using defy in these spots is it's very
good. You don't have but you don't have
unlimited number of defy. So Jax is
going to come in and this is where I
think the exchange is starting to favor
cuz it's just one lonely power. You do
have to move in here at this point. So
it's not really a misplay but you have
to try and fight. It always sucks
against here because that free might is
good. And then this discipline is going
to make this parro even bigger. So now
we're winning this fight. Porro is very
big. It is six total. We're going to go
back. Discipline trying to fight back
here. to see if the pora happens. And
again, I think this is a fight that Jax
kind of has to pick, but not a fight you
really want to pick cuz remember at the
end of this exchange on guard on the
other side, lots of spells being traded
back and forth. But remember for Yi,
even with this defy that happens, Yi is
the one ahead on points and all of these
being exchanged just for this jack when
all you're doing is taking out a pur
that's also going to draw a card, which
I think is one of the things that makes
this so tricky. You can see there's a
thonk in the E player's hand, but
doesn't really want to commit anymore. I
think just happy to let the poor go. I
mean, look, it's a sad day for pro
enthusiasts everywhere when the Porro
has to die. So, uh, poor Porro. Not long
for this world, unfortunately. But at
the end of the day, just decides, you
know what? I'll give it up. I'll draw my
card. And I feel like at this point, too
many resources have been exchanged. Yes,
Jaxi is trying to play catchup. You have
to commit something. But I think at this
point, it doesn't look like it cuz we're
still quite early on in the game. It's
three points to one. I actually think
this exchange might have been the thing
that determined the games. As we jump
through to our next step, we can kind of
see slowly but surely things get ground
out. And we can play it out. Six points
to five. Jax has been able to catch up.
Ruin run on the battlefield. This does
look good. But this Aurelia, this
Stellorn, this situation, that lead that
Y was able to generate and kind of win
that first major resource war. To me, it
kind of feels like the point where okay,
this game got a little bit out of hand
cuz there's a bunch of breathing room
for Y to have here to try and maneuver.
And uh even though again it doesn't look
great, Ye is able to close out the game
from this spot and just kind of crunch
through the points. And uh we can speed
this up a little. I think maybe see a
little bit more more towards the end of
the game. Punch first. Charm is a lot of
different options here and Yei does
eventually find the line that takes it
down. There's the punch first on
Aurelia. We can pause it right here. And
this is pretty much what seals the deal
because even though again ruin runner
lonely poor very deadly battlefield Jax
as we can see no equipment anywhere in
the base which kind of sucks for the
grandmaster at arms and that exchange
for you right in that mid game kind of
made it feel like it just wasn't really
a good way back because you've used so
many resources in a matchup that is
really all about resource fights cuz
again matching domains different decks
different things they want to do but
when you use all your resources for one
big fight when you're already behind and
your opponent gets to draw a card feels
tough to win an exchange against a deck
that is so consistent and pretty good at
grinding you through the mid game like
ye. That's how I think about this game.
We'll see how our casters think about it
though.
>> Well, man, that think about it.
>> That was an amazing breakdown. Thank you
so much, Pastry Time for the amazing
breakdown. But
>> I also think that the Jax player may be
a little fortunate that they didn't get
equipment. I know they still lost the
series, but like yes, Pac was
highlighting there was no equipment, but
there were two ext
players hands. like I don't think those
equipments were going to do much anyway.
>> No, the Aons always seem to be valuable
in the hands of somebody who is going
against somebody who is playing a bunch
of equipment and we saw that in the
first game where the auction took both
equipment and Jax had to respond with
his own auction just to get it back.
Exactly.
>> Hey, you can't steal something that's
already been stolen. I think that's the
thieves rule. I I guess so because it
looks like the master has come out on
top.
>> Yeah, well played. And again, a very
exciting list. I think that's the
coolest thing to highlight there. He had
a really good logic for why he was
playing the list. It's unique and I love
it when people come in with a unique
take on the meta that makes sense as
well.
>> Absolutely. But I think we need to go
over to our friends over there to talk
about some jungle monsters.
>> I'm pastry. That's Sharma. We're here to
talk about Unleash cuz some jungle
monsters are making their way into
Riftbound for the very first time. These
cards are pretty interesting. I'm going
to go going to go through them one by
one. What are your kind of high level
thoughts about the jungle here in
Unleashed?
>> I'm very excited that we get the jungle
monsters introduced. They are an
integral part of the League of Legends
experience. So seeing them embodied in
Riftbound is I think going to be a high
point. I'm also just excited for the
ways they're going to change the way the
game is played. Obviously getting a
little ahead of myself, but there's some
pretty cool effects that they're going
to be bringing to the table.
>> First one, red brambleback. This one's
pretty interesting when you conquer
buffer friendly unit. That's pretty
good. But you get your additional
conquer effects wherever the red brim
is. And it's a fullite accelerate unit.
So already the stats feel pretty good
here in Fury.
>> Absolutely. And obviously in Fury,
there's a lot of conquer effects that
you want to take advantage of. So being
able to trigger them a second time is
very, very impactful. It's exactly what
you would expect from a red buff being
embodied in the game of Riftbound
because it's all about that action, all
about that combat.
>> Not the buff I want to take though in
game. I always want to take the blue.
Let's have a look at our next jungle
monster though. We will suspect Lucian
may enjoy that one. So look out Lucian
enjoyers. It's vile more time. Now this
one, I don't know about you, Charma, I
am a calm enjoyer in Riftbound. This
unit makes me very happy, which is not
good news because it will make my
opponents very unhappy. Enemy units here
with less might than me don't deal a
combat damage when I hold draw one. A
massive eight might monster.
>> Yeah, the text on this card is very calm
in its flavor, right? It embodies just
trying to chill out because you're not
dealing combat damage. But make no
mistake about it, there's nothing calm
about Biomal. When this hits the table,
it's going to cause a problem. It's
going to threaten that card draw. It's
going to anchor down on a battlefield.
And with the ambush, it doesn't even
have to be there ahead of time.
Why does it have English? [laughter]
>> What? What? Why does it have Okay, that
is something I learned today. That's
extremely exciting. But if you're a car
opponent's holding open eight, I guess
maybe beware. We'll have a look at our
next jungle monster cuz as you can tell,
these things are pretty impactful. Blue
set is up next. This is the buff I love
to take in game. Let's see if I want to
play it in riftbound. When I hold add
power at the start of your next main
phase, shield two. Your hold effects for
holding here trigger an additional time.
So kind of the inverse of the bramble.
The fury one wants to conquer. The mind
one wants to go ahead and hold.
>> Yeah. So, this is another one that works
very well with the defensive side.
Again, kind of the antithesis of what we
saw with the red bramble back. But, as
we just saw with Viawa, holding is very
powerful in this set with Unleashed.
We're going to see, I think, a lot more
hold strategies on display. So, being
able to get those in additional time is
going to be a pretty big deal.
>> I know you're an Aria. Are you putting
this one in AR? Are you at least going
to try it?
>> I don't know yet. It's going to depend
on how many hold mechanics I include,
but definitely the decks where I run the
uh Ari Champion where I get the
additional point makes it uh so you get
two points and that's pretty good.
>> Yeah, good with the Grove of the God
Will as well. Pretty sweet card again.
All the dragon is looking pretty good.
Have a look at our next one though. Oh,
this one is going to make some people
[laughter] upset if you're the Vmore
with the problem. Elder Dragon. I think
this is the card that has probably
gotten had the most conversation about
it ever since it was spoiled.
>> Absolutely. Obviously, because it is in
the body
domain. Yes. Uh I was I was already
jumping ahead. My brain is going faster
than my mouse because obviously the
thing to talk about here is really
Aurora. When you see Elder Dragon in the
same domain as Aurora, you have to
assume that they're going to go hand in
hand. Uh this is something that when you
play it, you get to defeat likely a
large number of units because you can
deal up to one damage of them. But
whenever you deal damage to stuff,
>> it's just done.
>> Has the Imperial decree effect, which
we've seen actually used in quite a lot
of decks, especially when you can
combine it with Bella's breath. This
gives you kind of both halves, the
damage part and the the ping part. So
very powerful, very expensive cards, but
one that I think you'll probably see
cheated into play more often than not,
but definitely one that's going to be
pretty problematic.
Of course, we couldn't have Elder Dragon
in the game without Baron Nasher. All
the epic monsters making their way into
Riftbound and Elder Dragons kind of like
does things we've seen even though it's
very powerful. This one does something
we've never seen before in Riftbound.
>> That's right. This is the first unit
that's going to allow us to add a brand
new location. This battlefield, the
Baron's Pit, will be added to the
[music] table, which means it's an extra
sight to conquer. It's an extra sight to
hold. It's also potentially a fourth
location if you're playing some of those
amazing multiplayer formats for
Riftbound as well. And the important
piece here is that it changes the way
you play the game because if you're
trying to go for that big conquer win
where you conquer all the locations,
it's an extra one.
>> Yeah. Also maybe makes holding a little
easier too cuz the brand's going to be
stuck in here. Units can't move here
from anywhere by the way. So it's kind
of tricky to get in. But uh pretty fun
one to try and add to the game. And I do
think adding another battlefield is
really exciting. So curious to see where
that goes. Our final jungle monster
though is one that I am very excited
about. And our final one, our
penultimate jungle monster is going to
be rift. This one is spicy. Shelly
making her way into riffound. And uh I
don't know. Does this tech seem good to
you? When it dies, you just play another
unit, ignoring its cost.
>> Yeah, it seems pretty good already.
You're getting the seven might just for
the unit, which is fantastic. But then
it's going to replace itself. And as we
saw earlier with cards like the Baron,
with cards like the Elder Dragon,
there's going to be some potential big
threats coming down as well when this
gets the death nail trigger.
>> Yep. Helps you find them as well
whenever it moves to a battlefield. You
get to look at and find a monster in the
top of your deck. I think a lot of
different decks can maybe have this at
the top of their curve. I've definitely
been looking at it with Beta [laughter]
to try and see if I can cheat it into
play. I'm sure the Elder Dragon players
are looking to try and bump this into
play. Something like Baron. Haven't seen
a unit this big in a minute in a found.
And there's even bigger units that this
can cheat into play. So very exciting.
But this one, the last one for real this
time. Might actually be my favorite cuz
I want to bet hook this thing into play
more than anything else printed rift
round. It costs 10 but only a seven
might. So not too hard to find. And you
can even reduce the cost as well.
>> Yeah, but don't let that small might
number fool you. And let's be honest,
it's not small. Seven is still pretty
big. uh paying paying 10 and three power
[music] that's not uh a very
cost-effective thing when you just look
at the seven might. However, uh when it
attacks, the defender has to kill one of
their units. And if you have multiple of
these in play, that's multiple units. If
you're going to copy it with something
like Leblanc and making reflections, it
gets dangerous incredibly quickly.
>> Yeah, if you can reduce the cost as well
if you killer friendly unit, which is
something order with all the deaths,
especially in unleashed already wants to
do. And for an order unit, it actually
has something I don't think we've seen
that much of. It is ganking, which for a
unit that kills stuff when it moves to
different battlefields is kind of nasty.
>> Absolutely. And I just am looking
forward to the number of ways that
people are going to take advantage of
that cost reduction. We just saw Rift
Hale, Rift Herald, excuse me. So, if you
were to use the Rift Herald to make this
cost less and then get the trigger and
get the Attakan, that's a lot of units.
That's an explosion. Well, the jungle's
looking pretty sweet. Charm, very
excited to play with these cards in
Unleash. That's all much though. Keep on
tuning in.
>> I was cooking.
>> It was Pog.
>> Regional Riftbound qualifiers here in
Atlanta, Georgia. Now, we're done with
the boring same old same old. We're here
for hot takes. Okay. So, what is your
one hot take for Riftbound Spirit Forge?
Uh, Ezreal is a better deck than people
let on to be at the beginning. Uh, in my
locals, uh, everyone hated on it. Uh,
and I think the tournament results prove
otherwise. So, I think Ezreal is the
best deck in format.
>> Oh, the absolute best. Well, I do think
he kind of rose to the to the equation.
So, I think you I think you might be a
little bit correct on that. Now, I'd
love to ask you, what is your hot take
for Riftbound? Genuinely, I believe that
Sarraka as a unit is underplayed. I love
that unit so much and I want her to be
seen in more decks.
10 out of 10. Pulled her in like the
pre- Rift event.
I loved it.
>> What is so good about Saraka?
>> Just the staying power, honestly. You
get a lot of uh like units. If you just
buff her up and give her a lot of things
to make her strong, she can keep
everything else alive. She has tanks, so
she has to be dealt damage last. Just
super useful in my opinion. Is there a
deck that you think she works absolutely
flawlessly in?
>> Probably Azir. Truth be told, I think
she works really well in Azir. Even
though I'm running her, I'm not playing
Azir. I built a really jank set deck
just because I wanted to see it work.
>> Absolutely. Well, y'all heard it here
first. Sarraka is that girl and Ezreal's
been him. Y'all, I am so sick and tired
of the basic, the old. We need something
new. We need something fresh. I want
your hot take for Riftbound.
>> I hot take.
I think that Ireelia players
are incredibly sweaty and make my Nexus
night worse when I play them.
>> And you know what? I'm going to agree,
girl. I'm gonna agree [crying]
as
>> and they're just like, um, yeah, I'm
like 34 might. And I'm just like, all
right, what am I going to do? What am I
going to do? And it's tilting.
>> It is very tilting. I I low-key agree
with that. I want to know, chat, is that
a hot take? Do y'all agree? Areia
players just sweaty and ruining all of
the Nexus Knights? We're looking for hot
takes. Okay, so let's start with you.
What is your hot take for Riftbound?
>> Uh, my hot take for Riftbound is that
Rexi is a very underrated legend and
people are not playing the Phoenix Rexi
build enough.
>> And you know what? I'm going agree. Do
you all agree with that?
>> I would agree. I would agree. Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
>> Okay, so we want to see more Rexai
players. Now, what is your hot take?
>> My hot take is I don't think purple is
as broken as people like to complain
about. Uh especially with the fighter
flight ban. I think purple is like in a
totally fine spot. We had like what six
or seven green legends uh in the last
regional that topped. I think I think
purple's totally fine.
>> Are you a purple player?
>> I am a purple player and a green player.
[laughter]
>> All right. All right. So, what deck are
you running?
>> Uh, IA.
>> Oh, okay. Gotcha. All right. And now,
last, but certainly not least, what is
your hot take?
>> Uh, I've been seeing a lot of people
call for Dazzling Aurora banned. And if
you think that Dazzling Aurora needs to
be banned, you're just bad at the game.
[laughter]
>> Well, god dang. Are you a Ye player,
Civer?
>> Uh, I'm a a reformed Volibear player.
[laughter]
>> Okay. But like, I respect that cuz not a
lot of people are playing Volibear.
You're trying to getting him on the map.
I love that. I love that.
>> I I wish he was a lot better. I do
really like Volibear, but I don't play
him right now because I lose a lot of
games with him.
>> Now, I have heard that Volibear might
make a comeback in Unleash. Do you feel
the same?
>> Yeah, I think Elder Dragon is going to
make Volibear really good with the I
mean, his his attack ability just
becomes a board wipe with Elder Dragon,
so it's just going to be awesome.
>> Oh my gosh, I love it. So, we got
Volibear. We got purple players are not
that bad. And then we've got [laughter]
>> And then we've got um
>> Rexai.
>> Rex Eye. Rex underrated. Actually good.
Let me see some Rex eyes. Let me see
some voli bears. I don't know if I want
to ask for more, but thank y'all so much
for watching and we'll see you soon.
>> Hello everybody. Steve Kangas at the
Rift Run Regional in Atlanta. The last
regional for the Spirit Forged format.
So, it's time to talk about combos for
Unleashed. I want to talk about Rengar.
This legend is crazy. Red orange. So,
already a fun aggressive combination.
When you play a unit, give a unit plus
one might this turn. You can really get
your units to giant numbers the more you
play. But there's specific combos that
players are already thinking about. You
might have already heard about this one.
Let's take a look at his signature
spell, Thrill of the Hunt, because this
opens up so many options. It is a
reaction speed spell, two energy, and
then either a red or an orange recycle
cost for the power cost. Banish a
friendly unit, then its owner plays it
to any battlefield, ignoring its cost.
So, no energy cost, no power cost. Now,
this is pretty flexible because you can
play a unit to your base and then um
reaction speed, play it to a battlefield
and score a point or on your opponent's
turn, try and score and then maybe hold.
really flexible way to move your units
around, but the key part is it says its
owner plays it to any battlefield. So,
you do get on tri on play trigger
effect. One notable one is this next
card we're going to take a look at here,
Brin here, Thunder Song. You've probably
heard about the power of this card
already in this format, stopping your
opponent from interacting with your
plays on your turn. Well, how about
stopping them on their turn? Cuz you for
six energy get a five might unit that
you play to base. If you have two more
energy up past your opponent at reaction
speed, you can now banish your Brin
here, play it to a battlefield. It will
get the Rengar buff of plus one might,
and then your opponent can't play cards
for the rest of the turn. So, they get
one trigger window that you can react to
and then they can't really do anything
else with action speed spells, normal
speed spells, any uh, you know,
additional cards from hand, any units.
This combo is nuts. And it's even more
fun when you think about the card from
Spirit Forge here to help, which is
another spell that I was even trying to
use with Brin here in this format. It
didn't quite come together the way I
wanted it to, but now when you think
that you could also play this in Rengar,
it gets really wacky. The combinations
you can do to just shut out your
opponent. So, if this is a strong uh
combo in the format, suddenly things
that have a lot of action and reaction
speed that you can just say, "Okay,
well, you blinked my turn, but I'll play
on your turn." That might rise up in the
format as well. Really interesting to
think of what kind of effect this type
of combo will have on the metag game.
But let us know what you think in chat.
And now, let's get back to the event.
[music]
Hello and welcome back everyone to round
seven of regional qualifier Atlanta. I'm
Pat. That's still charm last time I
checked, which was about a round ago.
And we're almost at the end of day
number one. Eight rounds of Swiss are
almost in the books and we have the cut
off to day two nearing ever closer.
That's right. All right, we're getting
ready to go into round seven of the day.
Again, these players are looking for an
X2 finish to move on to day two. There's
a lot of very prominent players when I
was walking around on break that I was
able to confirm are still live. Uh Alen
ZQ notably when I talked to him was uh
XO. I also had IicO was XO. I talked to
Casanova who is still alive X2 on
[laughter] Lucian. So, a lot of things
to be excited for in the future, but of
course, we're excited for the now as
well. And we're going to have a matchup
coming here shortly.
>> It was a Ye player who was XO from our
last round as well. So, perhaps there'll
be another one as we take a look at our
upcoming matchup. It's going to be a fun
one. Actually, two decks we've seen on
stream already, but I don't know exactly
if they're if I don't know if they're
exactly the lists we've already seen.
Actually, we might not have seen one of
them on stream, but I knew we had one
filmed at the back. I was just going to
say I think that you're slightly
confused. We had one
>> a lot of games going back there was
there was a uh a backup match. I don't
want to spoil anything, but it was very
fun to watch featuring one of these
legends
>> and I was impressed by the amount of
might it was able to put onto the board.
We want to go ahead and spoil at least
what the legends are supposed to be yet.
>> Well, one of them must we can tell the
people they kind of already gave that
one away. Uh the other one is one that
might be very good with beta hook, which
always makes me excited. Although I
don't think anyone is running the beta
hook version of this legend which is
chamom reveal
>> Darius
>> Darius.
>> So there is a version of Darius that's
been running around. I've seen a couple
of players on it. It is entirely focused
on just playing big units and there's
some pretty exciting things that they're
doing with Rally the Troops. Uh if you
are scratching your head and you're
saying, "Hey, I don't remember what that
card does." Uh you get to draw a card
when you play it, but you also buff the
units that enter play for the rest of
the turn. And [music] then when you pair
it with any effect that creates multiple
units or if you are using your legion
effects and maybe playing uh cheap units
followed by that Noxus hopeful, which is
a very common play we've seen with these
fury lists, uh you can get a lot of
additional might off of that card. But
again, the key is it also draws and
that's something that you're really
searching for traditionally uh in these
domain pairings. And I think that's kind
of been uh a bit of a lynch pin for this
new emergence of a hookless Darius. But
we'll have to see which version of
Darius it is. We're not going to reveal
it right now cuz the deck list is ready
for your viewing pleasure and mine and
charas. What do we got?
Regular Darius. Still good. And as you
mentioned still three Rally the troops
really dedicated to just making Oh, it
is a baited hook. I got baited by
myself. You did get baited by yourself.
But the cool thing with rally the troops
is it does also work with the units that
are entering play from baited hook. It's
also a great thing with hook and the
matron combo in particular. Uh it's also
something where if you are planning to
say sacrifice a ferris 4runner uh it
would then buff the mech tokens entering
play. There's just a lot of really cool
interactions uh with this. The other
inclusion that I'm a big fan of here is
of course the zhiao because this is
something that energy to might is very
efficient. It also allows you to have
some really cool hook plays there as
well. Yeah, sick nasty with Vanguard
captain as well. Very easy to make this
unit enter ready and it is quite well
stated for a three energy unit which
also by the way means you can get it
back with spectral matron. The top end
as is with often the case with baited
hook decks is uh you want to get to six
is usually the number that will change
in unleashed by the way cuz there are
some pretty attractive seven might order
units in that set. Uh but you can go all
the six you know often that's things
like harness dragon but we don't need
that here. We're just going straight to
first 400 which as we've discussed for a
lot of the day is maybe the best card in
the format if not one of the best.
>> Absolutely. And you're talking about the
top end. You don't have to get that
high. The beauty is Draven specifically
this fury version with a base might of
three can still represent as much as you
know eight or nine might going into the
late game off of a cheap activation of
baited hook. So that is why you see the
three copies of that included here.
There are also some strategies where
your late game revolves around Grand
Strategium. Of course, we see that one
copy there. If you do happen to have a
lot of units on the board, you can give
them plus five for a double conquer
turn. This also sometimes catches people
offguard defensively as well because it
does have that action uh keyword on it.
So, you can play it in response to
somebody initiating a showdown and then
just wall up and say you're not going to
get through.
>> Yeah, it costs quite a lot of power. So,
big only one copy because it can be a
bit expensive. This deck is very order
slanted as far as the rune split goes. A
somewhat rare 84 split favoring order in
that one. Nice. I like that you pointed
out the Draven thing though. Every
single unit you can crack with beta hook
with the exception of a recruit token
that doesn't have any other might. So
maybe war camp, maybe a buff from rally
the troops means you can hit that unit
pretty much at any time. And as you
mentioned, it is a very inexpensive
pretty big unit in a lot of time. So
enough about baited hook darus which I'm
very excited to see. Love to see baited
hook on the stream if you don't know. I
am uh currently obsessed with this card,
but Master [laughter] is also in this
matchup because of course Beter Darius
does need a worthy opponent and we'll
take a look at the Mastery deck list in
just a moment and it is going to be not
Aurora once again. I don't think there's
very many Aurora U players out there,
but another take on mid-range here with
another pretty big uh range of card
choices here. I mean, we haven't seen
Fiora, I don't think, today in main
decks at least.
>> No, that is a little bit surprising.
Another thing that's jumping out to me
is two main deck auctions, which says
this might be a Yi player that was
trying to play very wide against the
field and just kind of have something in
your pocket to answer any of these
unexpected equipment choices or if you
run into Azir or Lucian or what have
[music] you, uh, two copies is good in
the main deck, I guess.
>> Yeah. Uh again, other than normal stuff,
lots of pumps, lots of counter spells,
some Aelas, uh Trinity Force, which we
didn't see in the last match up, but is
very good in these yellow list,
especially if you are going first and
play it on curve. So, enough about this.
We can have a look at the players
themselves cuz our game, I believe, is
going to be ready very, very soon. So,
curious how this one's going to uh shake
out, but there are still quite a few
players in the hall as you may be able
to see. Round seven is about 12 minutes
through and our feature match players
are busy trying to see who is going to
make day two.
>> Hopefully
>> again that target is X2
>> to guarantee day two. Obviously if you
can go XO that's just going to increase
your chances of not just making day two
but converting into the ever elusive top
eight situation. We're jumping in. Uh
and it is worth noting both of our
players are six and0 which means they're
actually locked for day two. This is
just for position in the standings and
you are correct. We are we are deep in
this already.
>> Yeah. So a little late but that's okay.
Four to two on points there. You play
currently ahead guessing actually maybe
based on it's tough to say who did go
first but we won't worry about it for a
second. There's an AL in the base in the
back lane there for Staren and Z has a
lot of might battlefield cuz Rally the
troops has happened. Don't be fooled
that is not double the number of recruit
tokens. That is recruits with a bunch of
buffs on them.
>> Yeah they have hit the gym. Those
[laughter] are swole. They are getting
those gains and they're using them to
try to uh again hunker down on this
Trifarian War camp because that's also
going to give an additional plus one to
all of them. And uh I see
some readying happening here. The the
big thing for Zyle in this situation is
uh now you've got this war camp pretty
well positioned, but you are still
behind on points. So, at some point
you're going to have to uh find a way to
take a battlefield away from your
opponent to slow them down and kind of
even it up. You jump to three from this
hold, but that Stellicorn is still on
the other side.
>> Yeah, Darius of course could get it
done, but right now is actually going to
uh trade with the Stellicorn holding
Forge of the Fluff in the bottom part of
this game. So, it does need to get uh
buffed up by playing two cards. Not
exactly Legion, although pretty close to
the keyword that Darius basically is
known for. And of course, Darius a
legend can make some energy uh if you
have played another card this turn. So,
we're going to start by just going in
for it. He's going to pump and Z says,
"Yep, you're good. What do you want to
do? Do you want to trade or do you want
to do something else?"
>> I I was going to say I think that this
is them handchecking. There is the one
rune open and that one energy could
represent something like an ong guard.
So I think Zyle was fine with passing
and saying if this trades fine but I
gain that information maybe I can play
another unit with accelerate and move
over there but if you know if you have
it and you try to protect it then you
waste it here. So I actually really
liked kind of just handching Stars in
there.
>> It's actually so hype that Darius can
pay for your beta hook activation and
the seal that's already been played just
makes it uh feel pretty free. That's
such a nice little bit of deck building
here that this version of beta hook does
get to use. And of course, we've cracked
a one and we're going to look for a
five. Finding the only copy of glass
mixologist in the main.
>> And it looks like that was going to then
be played to the war camp once again
reinforcing over there. Uh it does have
that important death nail on it where
you can play a unit with uh no cost more
than three and no more than one power
from your trash. So again, often one of
those things that allows you to chain
units around if you want to activate uh
baited hook on it the following turn,
but for now it's just going to help uh
again kind of reinforce this war camp
doesn't look like there was any
accelerated units available to Z. So the
trade with uh Darius might have also
just been saying I want to get rid of
Stellicorn to prevent the card draw.
Yeah, I think uh pretty deadly unit that
you want to try and uh reduce the number
of draws as best you can. And I was
saying it's unfortunate that we can't
break the mixologist also to get veteran
captain back from the bin and trigger
its legion effective playing two
recruits to wherever the captain is. But
you know what? Matron's good enough at
doing that. Just playing it from hand.
Don't always have to find it with baited
hook. And all of a sudden, I'm not going
to do the math. That is an unbelievable
amount of might in that top battlefield
which against two Aelius you are going
to kind of need.
>> Yeah, you're going to need every inch of
it. Uh again, the war camp doing a lot
of work here because it is so wide. And
this is also again why Rally the Troops
is such an integral part of these new
Darius lists, whether they're Baited
Hook or not, because with the Vanguard
Captain, with the Matron, with the
Mixologist, when you have all of these
units where you're going to have other
units enter play, those are just even
more buffs. We have a bunch of buff
recruit tokens already on the board. Uh
if you could have had a Rally the troops
on that other play, then you would have
had four more buffs spread across uh and
drawn a card. Turns out that's pretty
good value. But uh for now, Star's just
going to send that lonely Porro onto the
other side to continue getting those
points.
>> Very lonely, but uh still good for
points and still ahead on points as
well. conquering both battlefields. It
might be tricky, but perhaps you can try
and hold one, but can't be too unhappy
with how the point race is going so far
as the finger taps begin in the air as
uh it's a lot of might to try and
calculate. I suppose I can give it a go.
2 4 6 Oh no. 10 15 18 + 5 23 That's the
base. How many units drama?
>> 1 2 3 4 5 6 I think seven. I don't know.
Somebody call a judge and get an abacus
over there.
>> That's 25 then if it is seven units
[laughter]
and Ashan steals the baited hook. That's
incredibly rude. Fortunately, I think uh
tough for you to use cuz you do actually
have to make order power in order to
activate it. But stealing it away from
the deck who you know it's uh its
namesake card seems pretty good. And
these main deck actions actually coming
up trump here.
>> Yeah. And the really important thing
here is unless there's another
activator, maybe something like a death
grasp or uh maybe a hidden blade, you're
shutting down them purposefully
triggering the mixologist, right? We did
see them go and find that has the death
nail. So if you take this baited hook,
even if you can't activate it, you are
slowing down your opponent in terms of
what they want to do. We do have one
Aurelia going in and it's going to be
targeted with the ong guard which is
essentially plus three might because you
get one for choosing and then the two
from the text on on guard itself. So 458
I believe the number we said to beat is
25. [laughter]
So uh one Aurelia only going in here is
uh it's quite something. We'll see if
there's enough. Go again. Plus three
effectively thanks to Aurelia plus
Ungard's text and that is 11. Still
quite a bit to go again.
>> Another
>> three more. Is that a punch bur first? I
also see in hand.
>> Punch burst is plus six. So that would
be 20. That's getting closer, but you
might need another one. And that isn't
possible based on the uh power
available. And perhaps we need to do the
math again.
>> Uh yeah, I was just going to say if if
the power I was going to say there there
is there's uh two body runes. So you
could play the punch first and then if
the last card is maybe there's a
discipline, you do have that two energy
up. Uh does not look like that's the
case.
>> I'm pretty sure I did the math wrong by
the way cuz I just counted again. And I
think it might even be more than that.
But uh we'll see early I guess we'll
keep on track. That's uh 4 10 16 plus
420. I guess just picking off some
immunity. You kind of have to do it one
at a time.
>> And you I can tell you right now you
definitely don't want to kill the
mixologist if you can help it.
>> At some point you do have to find a way
to deal with the massive ward presence
that the other player has.
>> When you have two Ireelas, maybe using
one as kind of a sacrificial lamb of
sorts does make sense. And that is the
case wisely staying away from the
mixologist. You don't want to
purposefully just give them more units
back after you did all of that work. But
uh a lot of cards committed
>> to not conquering, but Starson does have
the advantage of being two points ahead
still.
>> I think that play would feel a lot worse
cuz that is so much. I mean, captain is
like those recruits in those rallies
like the rally dur the captain made a
bunch of extra units like matron revived
another unit from your trash like the
trade on total cards definitely favor
Zyle but without baited hook without the
engine that really drives this deck
feels tough to maybe make things happen
here and again still behind on points so
do does have to enter the bottom
battlefield at some point this uh would
be a great time for Zyle to top deck a
Darius because the bottom battlefield
has two units on it, which
uncharacteristically means Ye's
>> legend ability is turned off. So, a
Darius would actually just be a seven
into that six and would require Staros
to have some other effect to stop that.
>> And you have to think Saros used most of
them dealing with most of the war camp.
So, we'll find out in a second. Z is
looking at the hand and that looks
suspiciously like a lot of mana. That's
enough for a Draven.
>> It is a Draven. I got a little excited
that maybe the top dagger Darius did
happen, but it is a Draven followed by
our Trifarion as well.
>> And a little unfortunate for Zyle just
because not only would that have
conquered the battlefield, got those
much neededed points, but it would have
defeated the Auction and got the baited
hook back and instead we're just going
to see a retreat from the war camp for
now so that Zyle can maneuver as
necessary on the following turn.
>> Pretty interesting little situation
here. So going to hold to seven points I
believe.
>> Uh no it was should be a hold. Yeah
should be a hold to six and if they
conquer the war camp they will go to
seven. I think this is also why Zyle
pulled the units back because knowing
your opponent can't go to eight here but
that you will have to be able to stop
them. You want to have maximum mobility
so you stick everything in base. See
where Starosen sets up and then you try
to go wherever the math is in your
favor. Areelia does go to the war camp.
That takes him up to seven. I was going
to say I would expect one of these units
to come back to reactivate Y and Axan
makes the most sense because you don't
want to give up the hook.
>> Yeah,
>> nice triforce
>> does I mean gives some stats which is
always nice. Makes the porro a bit
bigger. Now it's going to be as big as
Arshan would have been chilling on that
battlefield and lonely por draws a card
when it's alone if it dies. So, not bad,
but I don't think Steros expects to win
by holding next turn. But I think you
are at least forcing your opponent to do
something here. And you're holding up
full runes, which in calm always feels
pretty good.
>> Yeah, I think I like the setup from
Starson simply because you are forcing
your opponent to go to both places. You
are at seven, you just need to hold on
one location. the extra point from the
Trinity Force, not relevant. But at
seven, any hold point is incredibly
relevant. And dividing your might kind
of evenly means that your opponent then
also has to divide.
But when you leave the runes up, they
have to then factor that in. And so the
puzzle then becomes for Zyle, how much
is the minimum might I can send to play
around what I think they have? And we
see the repeated thwon and that's going
to shut down the biggest units on the
side of Zyle that are coming in.
>> That's even worse. It's shutting off the
mixologist as well, which was kind of a
quote unquote free unit to run in cuz
you at least get a unit back. There is a
Zin in the bin as well, which would have
been ready when it came out of the
trash. Instead, it's just going to be
stunning up these two units. There won't
be anything else to the rest of this
turn, and you still have to run units in
to try and take out the Lonely Power.
Now granted, you do know the coast is
clear in the top battlefield at the war
camp, but you don't really have a lot of
might left with this uh six might power
still holding down the foot.
>> Yeah, there is a situation where you
again potentially if Zyle does have a
Darius or some form of accelerate, you
can get the job done simply because all
of the energy on the side of Saros has
been used up. The runes are exhausted.
You don't have to play around any more
combat tricks. But of all the combat
tricks to run into, that one was
potentially the worst in that situation.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I do see a Zen in
hand, but I do not see a Dar. So,
there's at least one unit that will be
ready.
>> I waved looking around perhaps have a
question for one of our friendly judges.
>> Yeah, so the Zen if it enters ready
should at least prevent Styus from
winning this turn again with no other
options. available. You
>> Well, maybe I'm mathing wrong here.
>> Really? They're both sixes at the same.
>> Yeah, they're they're both sixes because
of the the Ye ability. Uh we've got
three and four. So, the remaining might
can deal with one. The Zen still needs a
plus two to get there. And I thought I
saw it in the hand of Isle when he was
kind of briefly maneuvering, but now I'm
second guessing myself. I think that
that was not the buff that I thought.
>> Yeah. I mean just what we do know right
four for the matron three total two plus
the buff for the glory seeker that is
seven zen is four which would only be 11
and [laughter] we've already counted
it's 12 between these two battlefields
and you do need to conquer both or at
least push the units off of them
>> in order to not lose
>> an even trade is still fine on both
sides so you just have to get to
that situation
I
>> I think that they for running this back.
Uh, judge was called. Uh, I suspect
what's happening is with the Thonk, uh,
the two units are stunned. I think Zyle
wanted to know if Starin was allowed to
just put all of the damage on the Draven
to avoid the Mixologist trigger, and
that would still be allowed. And so, the
Draven would not die, but the Mixologist
also does not die.
>> I
don't actually know the answer to that
question. My instinct is that
>> if there's no tank, you still get to
choose or you assign it. It's just
normally there's no incentive to not
kill a unit.
>> So the so one of the things about though
is that well you can't so you can't
split damage in a
>> right but you can just take your six and
assign it all to the Draven who's a
seven. Draven doesn't die. Mixologist
also doesn't die. They both go back.
>> I'm going to say
>> I'm going to say you're probably right.
But that's interesting. I I don't
actually know the answer to that
question.
>> Yeah. And again we're just speculating.
We don't the actual judge call us.
>> The judges are doing their job. We're
doing our job, which is rampant
speculation in the movie. [laughter]
>> Completely uh uninformed guesses
>> and uh misinformation. But
>> I I can only imagine because again with
flunk stunning the units, they're not
dealing combat damage. So the only real
question is what kind of combat damage
is being done?
>> And uh I think yeah with the pointing
there saying like, "Hey, aren't you
supposed to kill this mixologist? Aren't
you sure you don't want to do the
[laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah.
And that's a really interesting I mean
uh I'm very curious to see
>> what shakes out here. Also just
generally curious to to maybe chat with
some of our judges after the day is done
and get an understanding of this cuz
it's a fascinating one. It's a big
difference right whether or not the
mixologist is allowed to perish or not.
Yeah, because if the mixall just goes
away, as you pointed out, there is the
Xenzhao in the bin and that with the one
from hand would be enough to get over
their threshold, but I think they
arrived at the same conclusion that I
did, which is, uh, the damage can just
go to the Draven. You don't have to kill
the mixologist, and then Z has no
additional buff to get over the hump.
So, uh, Starosen is going to go ahead
and take game one. And, uh, that Aan
might have come in clutch there. It's
taking away that baited hook.
>> Yeah, taking away the hook again. take
over the entire engine. Uh, production
did confirm for me. You were right about
what the call was for. It was an appeal
to the floor judge about assigning
damage and as we kind of seen after the
dodge call, uh, yes, you are allowed to
do that. You did assign your damage
properly. And unfortunately, Draven too
big for you to take out. So, sorry,
nothing I can do. Mixologist just just
goes back home. Uh, nothing else to do.
No way to correct those battlefields.
You already did the might math for we
could see in Z's hand. And
unfortunately, the 12 might presented uh
could not was not able to be traded or
toppled. So, we are going to go to game
number two. A fascinating first game
here. Very excited to see what everyone
has cooked up here for game number two
cuz this Darius list looks sweet.
>> Yeah. And if I'm being entirely honest,
I think that the Darius player was doing
what needed to be done and had a great
line. you just kind of don't expect to
run into main deck auctions, let alone
again we know there's two there.
>> But when you consider what you might
have expected coming into this field
post AL with the Azir running around,
>> uh again, Achan could steal something in
uh Aelia matchups like a guardian angel
that could be incredibly relevant in
those scenarios. There's so many kind of
cool things for the Achan and at the end
of the day, worst case scenario, you can
just pay four for four might. you don't
have to do the trigger. So, the
versatility here, I think, is paying off
and uh in a big way.
>> Yeah, that's the nice thing about Ashan
is that that power cost you pay is only
an additional cost if you want to try
and steal a gear. And obviously, if you
steal a piece of equipment, you get to
hook it onto the Axan, which is kind of
fun. So, it is just kind of a base, a a
unit that doesn't cost any power that
has a pretty decent rate on might, which
it's kind of the thing for a lot of body
cards. They tend to be pretty well
stated as it turns out. And I guess if
you ever run into the uh the Ye matchup
and they happen to be on Aurora, you
have a lot of fun with your main deck
actually.
>> Absolutely. And another thing we're
highlighting here uh why I think it's a
good inclusion specifically in the Yi
list is that uh four for four decent
stats but not necessarily above rate.
However, because Yi is offsetting that
as well and the fact that if you are pay
uh playing it without paying for the
power, you're not dramping. You're not
going behind on your rune. So you can
save those for the calms, for the
counter spells. Uh it really just plays
into the inherent synergy and bonus that
Yei has by just giving you free stats.
So kind of generic units like that start
to shine.
>> Yep. Delighted that uh both these
players are already made day two cuz
these decks look pretty sweet. But I
have to say the one thing I really want
is the game three. I do want to I do
want to see more between these two
players. So we'll see if Darius can make
it happen here in game two. It's going
to be a clean sweep as I can spy the
battlefields with my literal eyes on the
playmat. It is Vom's layer and seat of
power here for game two.
>> Yeah, and this actually kind of works in
favor of the Darius player. Uh the
violair when you're playing baited hook
is kind of irrelevant. You can go there,
you can sacrifice the units to trigger
your hook. Uh in fact a lot of hook
lists also just choose to run biom
layer. Uh whereas on the other side uh
seed of power for a list that is often
looking to double conquer that means
more card draws potentially for Zyle
than Staros. And not to say that this is
a a list that's incapable of double
conquers. In fact we saw them in game
one. But uh overall when you're just
kind of spamming units and flooding the
board you're more likely to have
presence at both.
>> I like the idea of like you don't think
I can leave by almost there. I can leave
anytime I want. Hook. Just get it out of
there as is going to be going first.
Finds a seal. Finds a captain.
>> It's the dream opener. Seal into captain
which triggers the legion
>> because of Darius. I was like, where did
the third energy come from? I was losing
it.
>> So you play the seal which triggers
legion. that allows you to activate
Darius, which is the third energy, which
allows you to play the captain, which
then turns into five might on turn one
when you're going first. Now, the
downside is, as you can see, you go down
a rune, but you're also setting up for
the future with that seal. So, this is a
great start, and we see the Fiora that
we called out on the other side.
>> Also kind of like a seed of power. Uh
big W here cuz Captain made so many
units that uh you're going to get to
draw a card here as well. So, if you're
going to be the play, a pretty sweet one
if I'm honest, when I attack or defend
oneonone, double my might this combat.
So, pretty fun, you know, in the when
I'm alone, I get bigger thing. But
unfortunately, I don't think uh Zle's
units are going to be alone very often.
>> Yeah, Zyle's deck is very well
positioned to kind of turn off the Fiora
value because you can choose to just
send in a recruit with something bigger.
Uh again, the Yei passive will still
likely trigger. Fior is going to be
alone, but has a lot of options to turn
that off.
>> It's kind of cool to see the different
options cuz again, kind of like a in the
main like teching for a few things. Fior
in the main kind of feels like, you know
what, I'm kind of scared of the mirror
cuz that feels like a really good card
in the mirror.
>> Feels like a good card in the mirror. It
can also be a really good card for
making the hump harder to go over for
Aurelia after they've established.
Right. A lot of times Aurelia for that
first attempt at a conquer, they can
reasonably get to, you know, six, seven,
maybe eight, but the Fiora just sitting
there by itself with no additional buffs
can jump up to eight easily because it's
going to double its own and then get the
passive from you.
>> Is it 10 or could actually be 10?
>> I don't know the answer to that
question, but if I want to get the job
done,
>> it certainly does get the job done. Two
points already for Darius here. Z is off
to the races in a hurry, I think. I
imagine I think Daryus is the only deck
that can play captain with the Legion
effect on turn one. I love doing it when
going second. It was even better when
Obisa Power was still around Sagge. But
uh that uh that's real nice as uh that
recruit is heling something down here.
And Fiora I feel like smells something
fishy. It's like I see two recruits.
They are alone. That's typically very
good for me, but I'm terrified and we'll
go here instead. I think that the
interesting decision here is that the
recruit with the hidden card on the
Viom's layer might be trying to get the
Fiora to strand themselves there. You
could go in and it could be a hidden
blade on your own recruit, but then the
Fiora is just stuck at Vials Ma's layer.
And I think that Star rightfully sniffed
that out and decided to go someplace
where Fiora can still be relevant if
needed. You don't want to go into a
position where you're just giving your
opponent free value. Now the downside
though is that Zyle does get the hold
point here, but in the future Stin can
send that lonely porro to the other side
which is far more expendable. That's the
kind of unit you want to be on Biom
layer. So you're telling me that it's
there's more than one bit of bait in the
baited hook deck.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Feels good. Fiora up to four
in the top side. Does have Guardian
Endor. So if she does perish, she will
make it back to base. But uh have to
think Z's doing a little bit of math
here. Does have Inoxus. full honest
broker quite a lot of might available
among these three units and the recruits
still holding things down good for a
third point there to star roans one but
tap in quite a few runes here tapping
the table as well
>> and thinking about it again those back
the other way
>> I was going to say all of the runes are
exhausted on the side of star so this is
really just a math check if you send
more than one unit then the Fiora text
is essentially invalidated so the magic
number is six or more to win is conquer.
Uh you could opt to just send six and
then send a unit in after the fact if
you're trying to protect a particular
unit and you don't want the damage to be
assigned in an unfavorable way cuz you
are just trying to trigger that
guardians. Anyway,
>> I think the puzzle is and I think the
math does check out by the way. I think
the puzzle is running the captain in cuz
there's a spectral matron in Z's hand.
running the matron in uh and then
getting the vanguard captain back, but
you still need to trigger the legion,
which does happen automatically from the
matron, but maybe think you can get a
bit more because there's a rally the
troops in hand as well. And Darius again
can make one extra energy.
>> Yeah, and the rally the troops obviously
is great for being that first card to
get the Legion online and then make the
spam. I think that the biggest issue is
that if you want to send the captain in
and have the captain die,
>> yeah, you kind of have to do it alone.
you will have to either be even or make
it be the juicier target. And the issue
is you have a three and a two. Or if you
send in the hopeful with it, then
they're just going to get rid of the
hopeful in most can uh cases. I guess
we're about to find out now cuz that's
the play. But I would imagine that of
the two, you want to get rid of the
hopeful knowing what the other deck
wants.
>> You didn't even think about it.
Immediately pointed to the hopeful. Of
course, the guardian angel does shatter
but protect the Fiora. Scoreboard does
get a point and picks up a draw. thinks
to seat of power cuz of course the
recruit is occupying the other
battlefield. So getting a draw finds a
Draven showboat and that might just be
good enough for this turn and it is put
that one down. Recycle a red rune and uh
see you later.
>> I like this. You're kind of holding on
to that
>> rally the troops plus matron play for
when you can get maximum uh efficiency
from it. Instead you just play your big
unit, make your opponent come into the
captain which is over there because
again that's kind of your whole plan.
You need that captain to go to the bin
so that you can do your big might play.
But of course, we're going to see the
porro start on the other side. And as I
had said before, likely the hidden blade
for the recruit.
>> Not so hidden anymore. Also denies the
lonely porro draw. Extremely powerful.
And I can see a defy in the top of the
hand.
>> Do I want to play this to deny you two
cards? Yes, I do. That seems like a very
good use of that spell.
>> Well, not only that, in this particular
matchup, what are the other things that
you're really saving the fivey for?
is rally the truth.
>> It's rally the truth, right? [laughter]
There's not a lot of options. So, uh,
when the options are presented, you kind
of want to just play whack-a-ole anyway.
>> You know what's funny? I think both
players are actually very happy with
what just transpired. [laughter]
And I think we'll find out in a few
turns which player is happiest with how
this is going cuz it's still playing
catch-up as far as points go all the way
up to three now as Fiora does take out
the captain in the seat of power. But we
know there's a pretty big turn brewing
on the Darius side. Yeah, the captain is
now officially in the bin.
>> Right where you want it.
>> Yeah, right where you want it. So, we
could see that rally the troops into a
matron into a captain for just the
explosion of might
>> on the side of Zyle. And uh again, super
relevant because of the Fiora on the
board.
>> That means that you can turn off her
passive by just sending in multiple
units. And we see the development of the
Stellicorn Herder and then the pass from
Starson.
>> Yeah. So has been putting the shields
down a little bit here. You know, had a
discipline in hand, maybe some other
interactive spells. Deciding that I need
to kind of advance my game. Need to get
myself a few more cards flowing and has
recycled a few runes. So going to be
traded back now as first little recycle
is happening. Gazile is going to play
Darius from the chosen champ zone. And
that one we know gets ready in a hurry.
Legion already active. Knox is hopeful.
Trigger the Darius gets ready, gets
bigger, and feeling pretty good as
Showboat is going to go ahead and smack
the lonely parro in the face. does draw
a card at least.
>> Yeah, I like this game plan as opposed
to just playing the big might explosion
simply because uh you needed two units
to turn off the Fiora attacks. There
wasn't a lot of options here. So, by
going with this particular path, the
Darius can come in with help get the job
done and stick around. Also, we should
be seeing uh I believe the draw from the
seat of power as well, unless unless he
already did it. He might have already
done it. I missed it. I think that
already happened. But yes, do get a
draw. I think Z was actually drawn from
Cedar Power every single turn of this
game. Takes to that turn one Vanguard.
Okay, sorry. I guess not turn one. Fine.
But every turn since the Vanguard
captain got played, which was on turn
one on the play. I believe Z has
triggered SA power every single time.
And Celon Herd are going to get a draw
here. Try and dig Star out of this
pretty tricky situation. A charm off the
top of the deck is pretty nice, but this
Stellicorn is maybe in a little one-way
trip, but it's currently five might to
three. See if we can't make that a
little bit more even for that uh
Shepherd. And Discipline is going to get
the job done here if committed and will
be put on the chain. Pumping that one
up, drawing a card. And now it's six
versus five. Darius looking a little
silly now at five might.
>> Yeah. And again, this is just a simple
math equation because Zyle has all of
the runes exhausted. So no energy
available. Uh no way
>> another
>> to get anything else going because
there's no buffs on the board. Sometimes
with these decks, you worry about like
cards like Call to Glory out as uh you
know the the free zero cost zone, if you
will, but with no buffs present. Uh
Staros knows that you can just go over
the printed value with the Stellicorn
Herder. Uh and now we're going to see
the charm over. It's a nine. This is a
very big Darus, but the Yei is going to
make it a
>> it's an even trade. I think 6 plus 3 is
nine. Yeah, that's a really nice play
out of Stoos and getting I was going to
say like it feels kind of bad even
though discipline draws a card to use
that many pumps to just deal with the
Darius, but feels much better when you
can get extra value out of those pumps
by also charming over another unit. And
now a situation that felt pretty tricky
with your opponent holding two
battlefields at six with two very big
units. The board is clear and you are
feeling like you're starting to play
catch-up very nicely. Yeah, the real
danger in this particular situation is
that Saros in order to make those plays
had to exhaust all of the runes. So,
keeps
>> uh if Zle has a way to get a ready unit
into play,
>> this turn's going to be sick.
>> Double conquer would seal it. So, we see
the Rally the troops possibly digging
for like a Jin Xiao or uh something of
that effect.
>> There's there's a hook in hand. This
turn's going to be sick no matter what
happens. I don't know if it's going to
win, but it is going to be cool. that
much I can promise uh promise you all.
>> And we could also see a situation where
you find something with the hook that
enters ready. We're going to see the
Darius activated with Legion because
again, Rally of Troops was played. Uh
Matron,
>> that one get buffed.
>> This one gets buffed. Just trying to
make as much might as possible. It seems
like no hook necessary, which makes me
personally quite sad. But I think Zyle
taking the line that maximizes his
chances to conquer both battlefields
because that is all he has left to do to
win this game.
>> Correct. And uh could just conquer one
with the hopeful if they want to. But
also I think the play pattern here
because you're trying to double conquer
to win anyway. It might be I was going
to say that might be a consideration
where you stay at six and go for the
double conquer next turn. But uh by
doing this and forcing them to have some
sort of accelerate, I do think uh that
is the right call. Uh Zyle wins game two
and we're going to see game three. My
favorite thing.
>> I get my wish. We get game three here. I
don't I'm trying to remember. I think it
was four runes at the end of the last
turn. I guess there's five on the board.
So could have I suppose gone to seven,
played the year, and then taken out the
unit, but you're just going to lose to
all the two recruits at that point. So
not a lot left there in that game. Very
nicely navigated by Zyle. an incredibly
explosive opener with that Vanguard
captain thanks to Darius's legend
ability. And we're going to play yet
another. Who do you like in this match
up from what we've seen so far?
>> Uh, it's kind of tough to say. I think
that game two really went Z's way with
the opener because it's an explosive
start, but also, if I'm being entirely
honest, I think it favored Zyle because
of the battlefields. Like I said, BMA is
very often something that you see Darius
players play just in general with their
hook builds. Uh, and so the fact that
they had that and then they were able to
fully take advantage of that seed of
power, I think really pushed things into
Zyle's favor. But now that we're going
to game three, Grove of the Godwillow, I
would say, more so favors Strosen. And
Monastery is going to be kind of hit or
miss. It's going to be dependent on
whether you can find those buff
generators. So, uh, this is one where
I'm less confident that Zyle has the
battlefield advantage and also will be
going second.
>> Yeah, Monetary Hana in general is a
really sweet one. a great draw engine.
If you if you are good at activating
monastery, very few other decks in the
metag game are I mean set's the obvious
one that's the allar as far as
activating it goes, but obviously with
rally the troops which gets a lot of
buffs. You can try and cash those in
later for card flow which can feel
pretty good.
>> I have played this in Leona. I will just
say it right now. It's much tougher to
get buffs in that deck. Darius again
doesn't have access to that many
effects, but probably just enough to get
a few cards and you don't need that many
cards in this kind of deck cuz you are
just often trying to push a little bit
further to close out the game cuz this
at the end of the day it's playing a lot
of sweet different things. Has all these
cool interactions. It's just playing a
lot of M trying to win relatively
quickly.
>> Well, if you're also just trying to be
patient with your card draws, right?
Something like rally the troops into a
captain does generate three buffs. Yep.
And so if you just send, you know, a
recruit one turn, you cash in that one.
A recruit the next turn, you cash in
that one. Right? You have the
opportunities to kind of space it out.
Doesn't have to be all in one go,
>> but you have to find it, right? So
that's the step one of the Herana
equation.
>> I only caught one only caught the cards
in Z's hand, but I'm going to get the
rest. Unfortunat I was trying to see if
Noxus Hopeful was going to be playable
on turn uh two, sorry, turn one for two
energy, but I think seal is the only way
to do that cuz there's no one.
>> No, you need a two drop
>> because the Z's going second of course
the extra room. So
>> two drop and you drew the two drop and
that then allows the Legion to trigger
on the Darius Legend.
>> One day I'll remember what Darius
Legends ability [laughter] is. It's so
good. I mean, it feels maybe tough to to
trigger at times, but it turns out
having an extra energy just chilling in
your legend zone. Char, I don't know if
you know this, that's quite powerful.
>> Yeah, it's why I'm so excited for Diana
when we finally get her in unleashed
because she has a similar effect but for
spells. However, here we're now going to
see a conquer on the monastery of Fana.
So, Zyle will score the first point.
>> Glory seeker, another unit that does
give itself buff by the way, but
unfortunately had to be played first for
the hopefuls legion effect. So, uh, not
going to be able to draw a card here,
but can't feel too bad about things cuz
kind of going second, you've actually
managed to gain the tempo, which feels
pretty good as Darus again, the deck. I
think in this matchup that does want to
try and get ahead and stay ahead,
whereas he's happier to for things to go
a little bit bigger as oh my goodness,
we talked about the showird coming out
early. We're just doing it naturally,
playing for five.
>> Yeah, I love this. And I think that was
also the hidden blade going down as
well, saying, listen, I know you want
this grove of the godwillow. There's no
way you're getting here anytime soon.
And I'll give you the other location.
You can send Ashan over there if you
want, but you are not drawing cards off
this grove.
>> Yeah, we talk about how good our card
draw battlefields are, and there
certainly are things that players have
been looking for, especially with the
banning of Dreaming Tree. Turns out
sometimes the best card draw battlefield
is your opponent's card draw
battlefield. They just bring it for you.
>> Absolutely. And looking at the hand of
Stars in there, I'm not seeing many
answers. Uh there is one charm. So you
could conquer on the one side and then
charm one of the units over. But the uh
Draven is still actually no. The you
could get rid of the Draven if you
wanted to get rid of the bigger one. But
the biggest biggest issue is you can't
get rid of both, right? So there's still
going to be presence over there
>> considering the the hidden blade that's
kind of face up even though it's face
down.
>> Don't know how many hidden cards are in
Z's deck, but too many. And yeah, just
again taking the draw.
>> Defy. No, none available or none used.
And it doesn't look like there is one
from a glance at Thoros and sand. So two
cards going over Grand Strategium drawn
which is always an exciting one. And I
think Z rightfully thinking there is no
way you can stop me from holding. So I'm
going to take the point and I'm going to
take the card draw that you very nicely
donated me.
>> Yeah. So between the hidden blade and
the grove trigger, that's three extra
cards that Z will have to work with for
this turn. And uh on the other side
again kind of looking at Saros's hand, I
noticed there were a couple of buff
spells. It looked like an ong guard and
a discipline. Uh I also saw a Fiora. So
given the kind of few options, Star just
decided to develop this Ireelia and
pass. But this does give Zyle another
window to work with because with all of
the runes exhausted for Star, Zyle can
just do the math and go over top of the
Ashon if the draws are there. But
instead, we're going to see rally the
troops. There's a Zin here as well. And
there's also Baited Hook, but not really
many attractive targets. And you also
can't activate it at this point since
using your rally. So it might just be
Zenzal with an extra might with a buff.
>> And unfortunately because of the plus
two from Yei that is not I think going
to be enough on its own.
>> He's also not ready cuz there's no other
units surrounding Zin. Zin needs a
couple friends
>> to enter ready as well. Two to be exact
in his location.
>> I think this rally might have actually
just been a dig to find something
better.
>> Little value rally. You'd love to see it
sometimes. And now uh yeah, thinking
about moving the hopeful back to base
does do so. Oh, of course you can
activate paid hooker victorious. Why do
I forget every time? It's fine. It's
just honest broker with a buff and pass
to you.
>> All right, so the broker also has
visited the gym. Did not skip leg day.
>> It's good. don't know how uh they have
the time with all that brokering
happening, but good to see them
prioritizing their uh themselves,
getting that that fitness, that physical
health, that well-being all taken care
of. One of the things I love about
Riftbound is they didn't even play
around with the naming. They were like,
"This is just a buff."
>> Yeah.
>> Right. We're not going to mince words
here. Like, it's just a buff token.
Though, I will say for future sets, if
you're listening, Riot,
>> I think
>> put the plus one might on the bottom so
that when I put it with my equipment, I
can just do the math that way. Having
the buff stick out the top and the
equipment out of the bottom messing with
my brain.
>> I could flip it over.
>> Yeah, but then it's on the other side.
Then I'm then I'm driving in England on
the wrong side of the road.
>> All right, so back to the game. Here we
have the Aurelia going to the Grove
getting that conquer and evening things
up for Staros. So, uh, up to three
points a piece and the Trinity Force
coming down on auction.
>> Yep, that's eight might including the ye
legend ability on defense and an extra
point if you manage to hold there. All
of a sudden, this race is looking quite
a bit closer. That is one of the things
that Trinity Forth is quite good at. And
of course, we talk about it. I like the
uh the distribution as well. Aurelia
kind of the more attractive target, not
only because she's quite a quite a
powerful unit, but because she's hanging
out at the grove. So, instead, Axan
going to go ahead and say, you know
what, I'm going to try and make myself
more valuable because I think I I want
the card draw quite a bit in that bottom
battlefield. So, Z going to have to make
quite a few decisions here. Does have
enough might to to win one of these
combats. Actually, that's not true with
uh the plus two on Ashan in at the
monastery right now and can technically
win a fight with Aurelia. Although, as
we do often see, Aurelia is a lot bigger
than she appears.
>> Yeah,
>> there are runes open on the other side.
>> Three energy available on the side of
Star. And again, we were able to see
bits of the hand earlier. Uh there
should still be an ong guard as well as
a discipline there. So on that Aurelia
could represent as much as uh uh plus
six additional are the choices also
buffing her
>> booking a captain. This gives you the
out of gives the option of hitting
matron and getting it back and does give
you access to most of your deck. There's
the matron.
>> There it is.
>> So happy to put one captain in the bin
and likely get her right back again.
Building up a pretty nice board of
might. But
>> to me this line says I'm not looking to
contest your battlefields this turn. And
indeed does pass it back.
>> I was just about to say normally you're
okay with making this particular play
just because you're only giving up two
points, but you're getting a lot of
might on the board in return. However,
because of the Trinity Force, it's three
points. And that also means that Stosen
goes to the allimportant six, which
means uh a single Trinity Force hold
wins the game.
That is problematic. Zyle is going to be
forced into that side of the board as
early as next turn.
Would not surprise me if we actually see
Styosen maybe play another unit into
base and then just pass. Uh I see the
buffs in hand, but also sometimes you
just want to fain having more than what
you have, especially as a calm player.
>> Yeah, it feels like the the best spot to
put yourself in is to leave up your
interaction, leave up your buffs, leave
up your counters, whatever you have.
Play two units if you can. Doesn't
really matter what size they are. As
long as you can play two units to
threaten the double conquer on the back
swing, then you have every threat you
want, right? If Trinity Force goes away,
you're still threatening a double hold
for the win. If Trinity Force stays,
you're threatening a single hold for the
win. And if both all the battlefields
get cleared, right? And uh you know, in
the worst case scenario, you can maybe
just win by moving your other units in
presuming that Darius has to use most of
his resources to clear all that stuff.
So the other reason that I was
suggesting maybe even just one unit is
we do also still have the Y in the
champion zone. So if you can just play
something and leave a bunch of energy
up, say, "Okay, come at me, bro." Right?
What do you got? Make them uh agonize
over what you could possibly have.
That could be good enough.
>> Certainly could be. So down comes.
>> All right. So the Fiora does enter play.
seems like seems like a pretty good
backup unit to have. Good reinforcement.
It's uh it's quite forward in the base.
It's kind of between two realms in the
battlefields, but uh you know, it's
fine. Uh we know what's going on there.
Maybe just deciding where it's going.
>> Yeah, this is going to be interesting if
it does actually reinforce and not go to
the base. It was placed in a kind of
central location, so I thought maybe
that was going to be the case. Instead,
it reinforces to Grove of the Godwillow,
then Ireelia moves back to the base. So
again, still one unit in each spot and
we are going to see the lonely porro
developed as well. So uh and then I'm
I'm wrong. We're also going to see the
sea monkey. So only going to leave one
energy up. That is a lot of confidence
in just the base might on the board.
>> And not only do does that make the
options much more limited, that's
basically just to fight or on guard,
right? That's the read you get. We know
that there's another buff in Saros's
hand. So there were more options he
could have left open here, but instead
deciding that playing more threats cuz
you already know you're forcing your
opponent to come into the battlefield.
Trying to play for the reconquer with
your chosen champion as well, which does
enter ready and have ganking. Both great
qualities when you're trying to close
out a game as you from six points.
So what this signals to Zyle is that
Sarosin is of course playing for the
reconquer saying listen I know that even
if I leave my energy up I don't have
enough to actually defend if you shove
everything. Uh Zyle is going to be
forced into a shove everything situation
because at a minimum you have to make
sure the action is taken care of. Can't
let the Trinity Force hold trigger but
if they're already going to do that they
might as well also take a shot at the
Fiora. So Saros says, "Okay, spread
yourself thin and then I will come back
on the following turn."
>> Yeah, it's 18 might for Zyle right now
on in his base. Also do like in general
just moving around your back and putting
Fiora there. I think Fiora is a much
better uh defensive unit and early is an
incredible offensive unit. So that
tradeback definitely makes sense for me.
Curious to see this line, but I think
Star Wars are just saying, you know
what, this feels good enough. And it may
be true that leaving up two more runes
or exhausting them here to play another
unit feels like both parts might have
just been enough. But we'll find out cuz
Z's got quite the puzzle to solve here.
>> Yeah. One of the things that is worth
noting is if you know you're going to
commit so many units to the board, then
the Fiora swap makes a ton of sense
because you're also not going to get the
multiple triggers from playing multiple
buffs like you would have on the
Aurelia. So, uh, here we have a couple
of units coming in. So, the Fiora text
is turned off, but does still get the
plus two from the Master Yi legend
ability. So, it's going to be five. And
then of course we have the hopeful
representing form might and an
additional three from the honest broker.
>> The ong guard does come down.
>> Yeah, good math. That's actually just a
trade. Really nicely calculated there by
Zal. Knows that seven is the number to
beat there cuz again pretty face up with
only run one rune open. Now we're going
to move back to the other side. Is six
for Axan as we've counted quite a few
times.
>> It is eight though because of the
>> I can't count again. And I don't think
either.
>> The same mistake appears to have been
made from Zyle based on the expression
we just saw on the camera.
>> Oh no,
>> not the moment you want to have so much
thought, so much counting. You just
forget that that mastery legend ability
is always there.
>> Shaking the head.
>> Yeah, and this is the critical one, too,
because of the two, this was more
important to make sure you took care of.
The Trinity Force would still be enough
to win the game with this hold.
>> That might just be it.
>> Yeah, Zyle's shaking shaking his head.
Not likely to have uh you know like a
cleave or something else in hand. We
haven't seen them in the list. Uh of of
course we don't know what the sideboard
is. So on the off chance maybe they came
in, but it's not a traditional sideboard
card, so it's not what you would expect.
Uh but if anything, I would say that the
the expression, right, this is the
story. Yeah, this is uh one of the great
things about all sports, card games
included. Sometimes glorious things
happen and sometimes tragedy strikes and
agony is all you have left on the table.
One little recruit is all that was
needed to tip the scales there. That's
funny cuz I did the math a few times and
I came to the same conclusion and I can
see significantly more cards [laughter]
than I can. And this it's round 7,
folks. I have to remind you it is late
in the day. The players have been
playing since 10:00 a.m. It is 8:30 p.m.
right now in Atlanta.
>> TCG tournaments are grueling.
>> Yeah, they are very much a marathon.
They are not a sprint. You have to be
mentally aware for long periods. And
this is, I think, why there was the
dismay as opposed to just a concession
because there is an answer. It's just an
expensive one. And it's very clearly, I
think, one that Zyle wanted to use on
defense. Uh, seeing the recruits still
in the base, I think the plan was you
make the trades and then you send the
recruits to the locations and then you
defend with strategy. But unfortunately
being forced due to the miscalculation
to use it on offense. This is going to
put Zy in a perilous predicament.
>> And it's face up at this point, right?
>> Yeah.
>> There's two energy left including the
Dared ability which I miraculously did
not forget. So, we're going to have to
pop the hook. Daria is going to get
exhausted. Hook is going to go sideways.
Not yet. Again, I think when things like
this happen, the most important thing is
to just think through your plays. How
you made a mistake.
>> How can you recover and get out of it
cuz there are there's almost always a
way to do something. And a recruit's
going to get hooked here. Remember, it's
massive thanks to grand strategim. So,
it's going to find anything in the deck.
But what's left to hit here?
Whoa, that's a good one. Ferris 4runner.
Ferris Foreigner is a big hit. The only
thing that I maybe question there,
again, heat of the moment, but uh you
know, your opponent has to double
conquer to win next turn. Anyway, the
recruit on Grove of the God Willow
doesn't really, in my opinion, represent
anything meaningful. I liked the idea of
maybe hooking that and then whatever you
get reinforcing on the other side,
sending those other recruits over and
just all ining on one. I don't think uh
forcing the split is a a huge deal
necessarily, but doesn't matter. Uh this
is still a pretty big hit and I think
now Zyle
is looking to reinforce this 4Runner on
the other side taking a moment to
reconsider.
>> It's an interesting question, right? Cuz
uh I can kind of see both ways. I think
your line makes a lot of sense in terms
of maximizing your hold on one
battlefield cuz that's kind of the
situation you find yourself in. But just
pure value-wise, a one might recruit is
going to force at least two might worth
of unit from Stars inside. So, you know,
on uh on balance, it does feel like it's
slightly better to leave the recruit
there. But, uh tough to say.
>> I think again, lots of tricky decisions
to navigate.
>> Lots of tricky decisions and again one
of those things that you wouldn't even
be in uh if
Master Yi didn't have that text on it.
So, yeah, we are going to see the
4Runner go to the other side.
>> I was going to say uh there was a lot of
deliberation. 4Runner obviously stickier
and has a bigger printed number, but uh
this getting the captain which will then
trigger two more recruits because of the
legion as well does represent more just
raw might.
>> Yep, it is uh all of the captain which
is five on its own and then the four
matron uh that is nine versus the six.
And again, the mechs are great. You do
not have time for mechs. They they are
going to be in the base where they
cannot help you.
>> And so the recruits move over. We
actually left one at home as well.
Yeah. And again, this is a situation
where Starosen just wins with a double
conqueror.
>> And at this point, you know, there's
there's nothing left. They don't have
another trick,
>> right?
>> Not much that Darius can do with only
one rune. It's not, you know, there's no
on guards happening. Uh no cheap pumps.
All of the all of the things have been
expended.
>> Maybe this is where Zyle has the 400 IQ
from the sideboard single hex tech ray.
>> That' be pretty good. It' be [laughter]
one of the few things you can actually
play here in this.
>> I'm trying to think of any potential
out. And that's where I landed.
>> 13 might. If I'm doing the math
correctly, it's 410. Yep. Oh, sorry. 14.
Math is tricky. And indeed, the sea
monkey is going to do the first thing,
which is uh get a card draw, kick the
recruit out of the battlefield, and get
conquer number one. But to score the
winning point in Riftbound, you must
score both battlefields, whether by hold
or by conquer in the same turn.
>> Yeah. And uh now we're going to see
Styosen take that lonely porro.
>> Chip away.
>> Turn him sideways. Make some trades so
that we can cascade this Trinity Force
onto
different units.
>> That's a draw, too. I actually love that
play. Drew disciplined by the way as
they got off the top. So, it feels
pretty good there. Still all the runes
left available. Charm that one back
home. I don't want to see that anywhere.
It's only six might left here at the
monastery of Harana. And Aurelia is
actually that big right now equipping
the Trinity Force. So, just needs one
more spell and oh, I don't know how many
spells can calm possibly have.
>> Well, at least one discipline because we
know that it was gained off of the draw
from the poro, but I see another one in
hand.
>> That should be it. GG.
>> There's the handshake. And
>> uh Zyle, I just want to say my heart
goes out to you because I know how
heartbreaking it can be, but well played
uh for the most part by most players and
they are still locked for day two. That
is the takeover.
>> That is that is the uh [laughter] that
is the silver lining. I mean, it's
happened to the rest of us. It's
happened to me and uh certainly usually
happens at a nexus knight. Not as good
happens at an RQ, but again J2 was
already secured. Six in one still. Very
impressive record with a round to play
here. Shake it off. Get keep your X1
[music] record and keep the train
rolling. And Master Yi seems to be doing
an awful lot of winning on the feature
match area. I may add a deck that we did
expect to see quite a bit of. There was
an uptick from Lil to Atlanta in
representation. And uh we've seen two
feature matches and we've seen two
different yeast remain undefeated.
Yeah. And it's interesting to see how
the meta continues to evolve, right?
Because after the changes, right, after
the bands, we all thought, okay, maybe
Draven's on the downturn, but Draven's
still having really good conversion
rates. We thought maybe Aurelia was
going to be the new queen. Obviously,
Aurelia, the champion unit, still
performing very well because that's also
played in these E lists. Uh but overall
when I was walking the tables earlier
there's still some very wellperforming
Aurelia in the room. Uh but we are
seeing the rise of Master Yi once again.
It turns out just having raw numbers,
good stats is good in this game.
>> It is. And I think Trinity Force big
upgrade to this deck from Origins lets
you kind of catch up which is something
that this deck often struggles to do. In
fact, it kind of does both. Lets you
catch up if you're behind but also just
gets you further ahead if you're ahead.
So pretty good card as all things all
things considered and lots of different
configurations of this list as well.
We've seen uh no Trinity Forces more
punch firsts in our last match. We've
now seen main deck Fiora and main deck
Aan in this list. There is a lot of
different ways you can build this deck
which for a deck that I think most
people would say is fairly
straightforward, fairly simple. Well,
there's maybe more play than you think
to this kind of thing.
>> Yeah, I will say that this particular
version is one that I like at an event
like this where you know it's going to
be a very widespread across the room.
You got 1,600 plus players in the room.
>> But also with the best of prizing,
sometimes you have to expect the
unexpected. You don't know what your
pairings will be. You can't just say,
"Okay, I'm going to see Aurelia and
Draven all day cuz you might run into
the one set that's trying to chase the
best of or whatever the case may be." So
having a bit of a wider strategy, this
particular list was running a lot of two
of. So, it was just frequent enough that
I'm likely to see him in the games I
need them, but not so frequently that
they'll be dead draws all the time. And
it paid off here. The Fiora not so good
in this matchup, but the Axon did show
up when it was needed and took that
baited hook in game one and kind of
sealed things.
>> Well, good to know that at least one
play set of baited hooks is going to be
making day number two. But Master seems
to be doing all the winning here in this
feature match, which I guess begs the
question, what beats Master E?
Well, if set one was any indication, it
was Kai'Sa.
>> Well, we did see that matchup and
>> we we did see that matchup. Didn't
necessarily go that way. Uh but yeah, I
would say something like that or
potentially Victor. I know that there is
a Victor that was still undefeated as of
last round because they were on the
broadcast. Uh you want anything where
your removal either just doesn't care
about the might or takes advantage of uh
doing it outside of combat before the
defensive buff goes on, right? you want
to deny the additional value of the Yi
legend itself. So decks that can take
advantage of that are going to be well
positioned. Uh other decks that might do
well would be decks like Aurelia where
you can use cards like Charm to force
things uh off of the sites or to force
combats that they don't want uh in
certain situations. So uh there's still
a lot of I think ways to play around it,
but it's one of those things where I
think it's still kind of catching people
by surprise. We saw it do well in Leo.
You kind of expect it to maybe do well
here, but the the numbers jump from that
event to this one was much bigger than I
thought it was going to be.
>> Well, I do love hearing Trump's thoughts
on Ye genuinely, but I'd love to hear
from the winner themselves. Let's go on
down to an interview.
>> Thank you very much, Pace Tree. I have
Star aka Cody here. Congratulations on
your win now. 7 and0. How you feeling?
Is the energy still with you?
>> Yeah, feeling good. Feeling good. One
round left. I'm going to go eat after
this. But yeah.
>> Oh, after this interview. Uh after after
this last round
>> after this last round. Okay. I was going
to say you got to stay hungry for the
last round. You can go undefeated on day
one. Was this uh how you were expecting
day one to go? It's
>> how I was hoping it to go. Uh one round
at a time. Um I come from a lot of Magic
tournaments and stuff. So I've had some
deep runs in the past in Magic, but uh
it's nice to get it in Riftbound, get it
going.
>> Have you been to any of the other
regionals for
>> I haven't been able to yet. I wasn't
able to get tickets or wasn't able to
travel. So yeah.
>> Okay. Well, happy to have you. Welcome
to the community. I'm sure already
people are going to be turning heads or
you're turning heads. I want to talk
about the deck that you chose to bring
cuz Master E, it's not one of the most
popular, but it's on people's radars.
What made you gravitate towards it and
how do you feel like your matchups are
against the field right now?
>> Yeah, so uh this was kind of a last
minute pivot. I was going to play Kais
up until like last week.
>> I like Kaisa. Oh, come on. Uh now now
I'm not on your side anymore. [laughter]
>> Yeah. So um I really feel like u the
strategy of the deck kind of meets my
play style. I like to play it as like a
tempo deck where um you're getting that
two might every every defense from
Master Yi. Um if you think about like
discipline is two energy for two might.
So you're getting like free energy every
turn that every turn that you use that.
Um and then I found an interaction
someone posted it on Twitter uh with
Fiora Peerless and Master Y. And I'm
like, "All right, I can't pass this up."
>> Yeah, I noticed that you a couple cool
options, but you were also talking about
the defensive style getting the plus
two. There was that one moment in game
three. opponent swings in. We couldn't
quite hear what was going on on the
table. What was uh being said there?
>> Yeah. Um that's rough. Like I I feel bad
winning like that, but it happens. It's
a long day. Um
>> stamina is important, right?
>> Yeah, 100%. I mean, obviously he had uh
the might on board to be able to take
that battlefield. Um and then hold up
grand strategim next turn. So, I'd have
to do the math and see if I could have
worked through that. Um but yeah, just
unfortunate the forgot to master E
trigger is is
>> it's it's real. I mean, that's it's a
long day. I mean, you've been to Magic
tournaments, you said, so you probably
know what that's like, but
>> 100%
>> your brain just turns to mush. And
mine's already turned into mush. I'm not
even playing today, so I can only
imagine what it's like for you. But I
want to talk about the deck uh even
deeper cuz game one, you had some cool
options in there. Akan in the main deck.
We've seen the gear hate in the main
deck is very uh pivotal. How much work
has that done for you so far today?
>> It's been really good. Um that was also
kind of a last minute addition. Um the
four might and then six might break
points um I find are just like really
important having an extra turn two play
that just comes down for four and like a
lot of times especially with a pump
spell can go in and conquer and then
just hold and sit there for sit like at
six.
>> Yeah, you did that game three, right?
You just played him on the on the ramp.
>> Yeah, honestly I found like uh a lot of
the time in game one I'm just playing
him, you know, for fun. I I've still in
a baited hook twice which I can't do
anything with but then [laughter]
neither can they, right?
>> Um so yeah, it's been solid. Um, I like
just having another format unit in there
to kind of play out on curve. And the
gear hates a bonus in game one. But
>> I noticed in game one you played the
exon to the battlefield to steal the
baited hook. Was that intentional? Cuz
usually I think you want to put it to
base so it doesn't die. They don't get
the the baited hook back. So what was
your thought process?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So I wasn't too worried
about the baited hook at that point.
Like if he got it back is fine. Um
>> I guess it's still exhausted if he gets
a hook.
>> Yeah. You know, at that point it that
may have been a misplay. I'll have to go
back and watch and think about it some
Well, I'm going to analyze it after
this, so I won't go too hard on it.
>> We We can both go back. At that point, I
I wanted two uh two units on there. I
didn't have any tricks to hold up. And
so, um
>> I was just trying to get some extra
might on the battlefield.
>> It worked, right? Like you were able to
get the baited hook. You held it and you
won that game one. You won the series.
So, congratulations. I like to give
interviewers or interviewees giving
shout outs. Do you have anybody back
home that might be watching or anybody
here in the venue you want to shout out?
>> Yeah, absolutely. Uh shout out to
whoever I saw on Twitter that posted
about the Fior interaction. [laughter]
Oh, thanks for that. Uh, hi to everyone
at home. I know nobody's actually
watching this, but I'm going to make you
go back and watch uh this part of the
this part of the VOD.
>> Clip it. Clip it and send it to them.
Make them feel bad. There we go. All
right. You have my approval. Thank you
so much.
>> Cody,
lovely to hear from uh the winner there.
Very uh very humble, very uh a player
with I think the right mentality for big
tournaments like this, one game at a
time is really where you want to be. But
uh shout out to the dark technology uh
provider on Twitter for the Fiora tech
which means I guess it does work the way
we considered which is before the uh the
trigger goes off before anything happens
you react and then F just goes
>> boom it's a massive amount of
>> choose order of reaction.
>> Yeah. So or
>> not triggers react to triggers too.
>> It's been a long day as we've noted
here. So uh my brain is not cooperating
with my mouth 100%. But I will also say
uh shout out to the people that are
going to be forced to watch this in the
future. You've let Star down, but in the
future [laughter]
maybe you'll be there to cheer him on.
Also, shout out to Zyle who was crying
in the background. You and I chuckled
very hard.
>> Yeah, I don't caught that. That's that's
I think that's the that's the good like
mental bounce back you need there.
Again, X1 still looking good. Can still
be X1 going into day two and already
qualified for day two as well. So,
feeling pretty good as we are very close
to the end of day number one. So,
Charmer, I have to ask you, round eight
is coming up. We've seen quite a lot on
the stream today here in day number one.
What's left? We don't know. Again, we
don't know. We're just speculating.
What's left? What do we want? What are
we looking at?
>> Before I run back my Ari versus Valar
prediction is if as if there was some
world where they're both undefeated and
playing each other. I will say the
tradition generally is to find two exos
and then find a fun matchup and see
who's going to be undefeated going on to
day two. So if our own volley undefeated
that's going to be pretty nice. We are
going to go back down to the desk for a
recap.
Thank you very much Pry. We're going to
take a look at one of the pivotal
moments in game number one. So let's
pull it up on screen. I actually asked
Cody about this in the interview and
he's going to be watching from off the
camera to remind himself of some of the
decisions. But what I want to highlight
here is the fact that this game state
looking pretty tough. Oh, I don't know
why I'm tapping the screen right now. We
got to tap over here. There's a lot of
units on this battlefield. And there's
also the baited hook on this side right
here, which is no good for the Mash G
player. You want to deal with that. And
there's actually something really cool
that a lot of people have been talking
about. I was talking to some uh other
folks. They're saying any main deck gear
hate has been putting in work at this
event this weekend. and whether it's
salvage in yellow decks, ext
I've heard about adaptatrons and
Aurelia's main deck. Crazy stuff because
as we play the clip, let's take a look
at what Cody decides to do. It's game
one. Keep in mind right here, game one.
No one scored any points yet. And we
play an Xan. Not many people expect the
gear hate in game number one. And I love
an efficient unit like this cuz you can
also weapon master your own Trinity
Force. You have other tools for it. But
the point is we steal the baited hook
and we don't need to watch all the rest
of the play. But Cody's also able to
clear out the field. There's no baited
hook for Zyle. And that is basically
like the game-winning play. He's able to
later get the ext. Never gives up the
baited hook and just controls the field
from there. And that means that it is
sad news for the Darius player. They no
longer have their baited hook and their
game's pretty much over. If you can stop
that one gear, so many decks, the powers
around that one gear. And we're seeing
that that single main deck gear hate has
been putting in a lot of work. So that's
my analysis. Back to the cashes.
>> Thank you, Kangas. Loved that. I have to
say if you are thinking about playing
main deck gear hate as a baited hook
enjoyer, don't do it. Take it out right
now. You don't want it. It's no good for
you. You don't need it. Ignore the fact
that I'm playing a main deck disarming
rake in [laughter] my current Leona
list. Just don't do it. You don't need
it.
>> I couldn't have said it better myself.
>> All right. Well, I did uh lie to you
accidentally, viewers. Round eight is
coming up. And that is true. It is still
on the way. But we have bonus footage.
We have more coverage of round seven.
Chararma, let's hop on in to game number
two. Aurelia versus Fiora.
>> Two two legends we have seen uh this
week this day already, but not a match
up we get to see all that often.
>> Okay. And this is going to be an
interesting one in my opinion because we
have uh battlefields that I think both
of these players will be able to take
advantage of, but maybe more so the
Fiora. We have Trifarian War Camp on one
side, Sunken Temple on the other. Temple
of course letting you draw cards when
your units are mighty. War camp just
giving that bonus, but Fiora does care
often about becoming mighty. So, you're
either already going to be there and
then drawing cards off the temple or
you're just going to use the war camp to
get you over the hump.
>> I don't want to promise anyone anything,
but one of the other reasons you might
have war camp is for a different reason.
Uh, [laughter]
which is that, you know, a card I may uh
may have shown a fondness for already,
but is Fiora on the trot here going
first? Sea Monkey very nice little
versatile two or three drop depending on
what you need. And it is open zas here
for Harukazi. Aelia a player currently
up a game here in this match. We'll see
if Fiora can even it up and give us yet
another one as Seaki going to dance on
in get a point and get Fiora going. And
this is kind of a curious mant cuz in
some ways both these decks do want to do
the same thing. Make a big unit and take
battlefields with it.
>> And we're going to see a reinforcement
of the war camp with the Fiora from the
champ zone. has shield, has deflect, has
ganking, is mighty, gets all those
keywords thanks to being that and that
war camp. As you mentioned, Sharma does
automatically grant that status. So, it
feels pretty good to be aggressive here.
And again, this is not this is better
than the one whole point you're going to
get cuz you know, you can gank on over
to the sunken temple. Ironically, you're
actually going to lose mighty status and
be trapped for a little bit, but that
might be all right. Sea Monkey
unfortunately does not get conferred the
same bonuses, so we'll see what Austin
wants to get done here. But off to an
early league which has to feel pretty
good against Aurelia. Although I will
say one of the things Aurelia is very
good at is uh kind of grinding out
comebacks cuz uh this is kind of an
interesting like aggro tempmpo combo
deck. It's kind there's lots of Yeah,
there's a range of Aelia things that can
happen [laughter] as Fiora Victorious
does dance on Nova with ganking for uh
to make it point number three now.
>> But uh again, I really doesn't mind
having to hold back a little bit. In
fact, if we think about Vegas, the best
of Bliss that top eighted that event was
actually quite a bit slower than the
other Aelia decks wanting to play even
more of a control game even. So, not too
bad to be behind, although you know, you
never like to start that way. Certainly
not a uh not not a moment to despair for
the Aurelia, shall we say.
>> Yeah, the Aurelia deck is one where I
think tempo might be a good way to
describe it, though. You're not
capitalizing on early tempo. It's more
like you meet a minimum threshold to
activate and come online and then you
continue to outv value after the fact.
But uh here we're going to see the
stellarorn herder go into the camp
>> and yeah.
>> It's actually quite a few options that
Austin has hand. I saw a death grip. I
believe I also saw a challenge but going
to let this one go for now and uh just
have the Aurelia be played. And again
very common again biting time. Aelia is
the unit with the zonies behind that's
pretty threatening. I guess that zonies
also meant that trading with this or
trying to take out the silicon kind of
felt not as good. So, uh Austin just
going to draw back up to four points
now. Can't gank over right now as I as I
did note before, but only one more might
needed for Fura to be mighty once again.
So, we're going to see what Austin does,
whether this is just continue to develop
more units in base or if this is going
to be some sort of uh might buff.
Instead, we're just going to see a
salvage. We were just talking about the
main deck options to deal with gear and
how they're putting in work. Salvage
will get rid of that hourglass and draw
a card.
>> Yeah, pretty nice. Gets a lot of value
there as Fior is just going to have to
go back to move the oldfashioned way.
No, no fun by a first mate. AI. There is
one in hand. Austin actually drew it off
of the salvage if you can believe.
[laughter]
And uh lines up perfectly. I would like
to ready this unit. Uh Karakazi says I
may like to react.
>> Yeah, there is a reaction window here to
the first mate trigger and I think there
was a consideration of defiant dance.
>> So it's interesting cuz now Fiora is a
five.
>> Yeah. So I think the consideration was
if you diviant dance the Fiora as a
reaction to the first mate then what you
could have done was make it so she can't
become mighty but
>> Huracaz probably identified that then
Austin would just not send the Fiora
instead here you wait for them to come
in. You try to ride the wind over to the
other side which would have drawn cards
for the Stellicorn as well as get an
additional point on their turn but that
gets blown out by the cost. That is uh
one of the reasons to play this deck.
This card is filthy. Two energy reaction
does cost two power. Two is a friendly
unit and a spell. Counter that spell and
give that unit plus might equal to that
spell's energy cost this turn. So a
little combined counter plus pump.
Pretty nice little trick there. And
Fiora going to stay mighty on the war
camp. Five points now for Austin. This
game is looking tough for Aelia. Yeah,
and this is a spell that I think
sometimes catches folks off guard
because they often times misjudge it and
think it has to be something targeting
the unit, but it does counter any spell.
So, it was a great shutdown of the ride
the wind there. And now we have the
Aurelia going into the Fiora and it's
backed up by a discipline so far. Yeah,
Fiora is a six at base with the shield
and as a mighty unit at the war camp.
So, really did need to get a little bit
bigger and does do so now. more than big
enough to deal with the problem and
Harakazi going to retake some control of
this game. Charming unit in always good
I feel like to end a turn as Aelia with
uh if Aurelia is not going to be safe in
your base at least make sure your
opponent's base is clear.
>> Absolutely. And uh I'll be honest, I'm
never going to get tired of seeing charm
get played. I am biased recognize that.
But I am a charmer and you should be
too. Well, uh, honestly, given how Karma
has been performing in this last week or
so between Lil and this event, I would
say that having this card in your deck
is a very good idea
as Austin five points still, but
Harukaza catching up two points now.
Unsung hero going to be put down onto
the base and just a setup turn here.
Fior going to be deployed as well and
pass it on back. Feeling pretty good
about the points lead although again can
never get too comfy with Aurelia. Yeah,
again, Aurelia capable of closing the
gap coming from behind. Aracaz did just
get that whole point. So, actually goes
up to three here to Austin's five.
If there is I was going to say another
charm here. This could be disastrous if
there's not an answer. But with the
cards being recycled, that signals, but
that is answered with a hard bargain.
That is filthy. Austin thought it was
safe with the repost, but there is a
counter on the other side. And again,
uh, can you not so fast or post?
>> It doesn't target your unit.
>> Uh,
>> oh, because your it Yeah, it has to
target a unit or gear, right?
>> Uh, well, it's unit or gear on your
side. And so the not so fast could not
have been played on the repost there
because it's countering the spell
targeting Austin's unit. But the hard
bargain does shut it down which is again
why we're seeing these decks even when
they have access to calm for those
counter spells they're still rocking
usually one to two numbers of the hard
bargain because of its versatility.
>> Well what I was going to say is defy
also doesn't work in that spot cuz uh
repose does cost two power which is a
pretty steep cost for a very powerful
spell. So that may have been the only
answer in that spot there for power but
does find it at a timely moment.
Adaptatron gets deployed on the other
side and it is now just an unsung hero
trying to do the work here and I think
perhaps we're going to wander to the
sunken temple instead. Pit rookie going
to buff unsung hero going to get a
little bit bigger and Fiora does care
about making things mighty and uh unsung
hero is getting up there but not quite
there just yet. So I guess the decision
is do we contest Aurelia with two runes
open on the other side or do we try and
sneak away a couple more points before
we set up to win from six? Death Grip is
going to be the play, which means we are
playing to take out the Zerelia.
>> Uh maybe this also could just be the dig
to see if there's anything else that
answers it a little bit better. Again,
the drawing of the card is very relevant
here. But there could be a world where
if you don't find the right thing, you
go to the other location and you just
try to draw again off of the temple. Uh
however, Austin seems to have found
something that they like and they are
going to go into the Aurelia here. To be
fair, if this does go wrong, you do get
to draw two cards. Oh, no. No, you
don't. You're no longer mighty because
of Defiant Dance. A massive pump. This
is effectively plus five
number three.
>> All three in one game. Just like that.
Yes, we are. Do we have a second Defiant
Dance though for Haraz? That would be
backbreaking in this spot. Says okay.
Says okay again. And Aurelia going to
lose this fight right now. Although,
yeah, back up we go. Repost again also
giving that pump buffing up the unit by
two more might and now define dance at
least means the card draw still happens
that would have been a blowout of the
sentry but Austin has found repost at
pretty critical times
there's a consideration that for an ong
guard that's the card that's in hand so
on guard is a plus three
four five six only seven at the war camp
but Aurelia five base up to four more
that's going still win the fight here on
guard is enough. But what else is left?
Two more used. There's challenge
punching the adapatron
>> saying, "Okay, I'm going to get rid of
at least the other unit, but unable to
go through this wall of an Aurelia
sitting on the Triferian war camp.
Aurelia apparently says, "I don't need
help. I am the entire war camp myself."
>> And that's kind of her whole thing
getting very unnecessarily big with some
pretty efficient spells. So Haraz kind
of taking control of this game again.
Still down on points, but Aurelia goes
back to safety. Fur doesn't have any
units left. And Fiora does kind of need
to draw a mix of units and spells. And
uh there's just a first mate by the
looks of things. Not sure if there's any
other units in hand. I do see an Aan. So
I know there's one more, but somehow
Aurelia does not have a gear you want to
seal. And usually she does. Yeah, this
is a situation where you might still
have to play it anyway because uh at
some point you need to get to the ever
important six if you're going to try to
win with a double conquer. Austin has
been kind of uh stuck on this five and
not able to even get into a position to
threaten the double conquer. Meanwhile,
Huracaz has really climbed back into
this all the way up to four and in a
position with this Ireelia on the next
turn to at a minimum jump up to five. Uh
again, Austin got those early points was
able to establish the lead, but has
stalled and we do finally with the first
mate get in for the sixth point to at
least set up a future double conquer
attempt. But still not a lot of might on
the board.
>> Like this a lot passing back. You're
right. It's not a lot of might, but at
least navigating yourself into a
position where you can try and close out
this game. But Aurelia, the princess,
has been protected quite thoroughly this
game. And uh that usually means that uh
the battlefields do not belong to you.
They belong to her. What do you see,
Chara?
>> So Huracaz has I believe another ride
the wind in the hand. So I was trying to
think of a path to victory for Austin.
There is that punch first. We're going
to see that now. But Huracaz can just
dodge this completely with a ride the
wind if they don't have the buffs to go
over top and still net points on.
>> You know what else there is? There's
also rebuke,
>> which feels pretty gross in this spot,
especially when you've seen all three
reposts.
>> Yeah, because the rebuke, not only would
it be successful, but it would deny the
death nail trigger as well. So, could be
a complete blowout.
>> Says okay to the punch first.
>> Uh, no, actually I was mistaken. The
other card that I thought was a ride to
win I think is another defiant dance.
>> Well, all roads lead to Aurelia winning
the combat. Rebuke is played. Austin
plans get foiled. At least if your unit
was going to go down, you could have uh
drawn a couple cards off it. But that is
denied as well. And Aurelia is almost
even on points all the way to five now
as Harazi once again pass it passes it
on back. Leaves up all these runes and
says, "What do you have for me?" And
Austin is unfortunately starting to run
out of things.
>> Going to go top.
>> This is just to get that seventh point.
Uh, seven is still important even if
you're trying to set up a down conquer
win later because sometimes the seventh
point means you get to draw off of that
initial conquer. Uh, Austin's hand has
been slowly depleting. So being in a
position where if you do get that
opportunity later, you get one extra
shot, one extra dig. However, uh, we're
still not seeing a lot of might
available off of these draws. We know
there's the action in the hand. Uh, this
is again going to be that unsung hero
that was rebuked the last turn going to
the sunken temple.
>> I think you have to go for I think your
I think your game plan is just to try
and hold and win.
>> Do you have a better spot than this?
>> No. Action back.
>> I was going to say Ashan's going to go
there. I
>> I still feel like having the patience of
trying to get the double conquer makes
sense. I don't think there's any
scenario where against an Ireelia who's
going to have all of these
and you have no more rapas left that
there there I don't think there's a
world where you hold on that
battlefield.
>> All right. Well, that seems true cuz
Tide Turner is basically giving you a
little bonus retreat and Axan's going to
be used for the death grip and Defi is
going to say no to that and Aurelia is
going to crash through the sunken
temple. Fell all of the Denisens within
it. Draw a card as well if uh if he
wants to pay an extra energy. Does
indeed want to. Aelia does keep the
cards going and that defy dance you
mentioned is still there and uh all of a
sudden Haraz is the one that's
threatening to hold one battlefield and
win. Find your center says thanks that's
pretty cheap. Boots of swiftness cuz why
not make one of your units bigger. Pick
your favorite. I don't think it really
matters too much at this point because I
don't know what Austin E has left. This
feels like a checkmate scenario.
>> I was just about to say of the two I
like the tie turner just because that
makes the Aon not even go over the top
of it. So if you send the auction on
there just trying to not lose the game,
you're only going to trade and not
establish your ability to try to force a
hold win on your own side, but
ultimately no additional [music] sources
of accelerate, no additional first mate
triggers, no way for Austin to get into
both locations. And the win goes to
harder housing. And I feel like the
power of Aurelia really showcased there
in that game fairly far behind on
points. But once Aurelia was out on the
field, she never left. And typically
that's a problem.
>> One of the I think really interesting
things to highlight about that game is
that the Fior player played all three
reposts and still could not get the job
done. They got the early lead. They had
the potential counter spells, but
Aurelia was able to just push through
it. Had the card draw between Stellorn
and the [music] disciplines and
everything else. So, uh, ultimately just
ran out of resources.
>> Well, I have great news for everyone. It
is actually time for round eight. We
just kind of rolled on in. So, we're
going to kick things off and I just got
told what our matchup is and uh we have
something fun. We have two very notable
players. We're going to have a look at
the deck list first and we'll reveal the
player as we show it because we have set
back on stream.
>> Colin is back.
>> Okay.
>> And I have to think again, like I said,
typically here you want to try and find
two undefeated players. And uh I'm going
to have to guess that Colin is still X
and O on his old favorite. Yeah, this is
a list that we saw Colin playing earlier
today. I know that it was at least one
of the backup matches. I don't know if
it made it to the broadcast, but when I
was watching it, uh it did win in the
early rounds, it looked very impressive
in doing so. Excited to see what this
brings to the table. And uh just some
spicy fun. I mean, it's stuff that you
expect in set, but anytime you can
feature cards that most players are not
accustomed to seeing, like the Fay
Dragon, uh you get those scenarios where
sometimes you play something and your
opponent picks it up to read it and you
just kind of feel good. So, if you don't
know who Colin is, by the way, uh Colin
made top four in the last original
qualifier in North America in Vegas
playing Miracle Draven. Pretty good
deck, or so I've heard. And uh but
before that, Colin was known as a set
player. He was in Origins, a player that
showed that set could be a valuable
pick, could actually do some damage, was
known for his prowess on this champion.
Now, do you happen to remember who won
that original qualifier? Chararma,
we'll remind you quickly cuz we have a
look at our next deck list. Dra,
actually, I don't know what's on the
menu, but I do know who the player is
here. Sam D. Sherman back with Lucian.
Our champion from regional qualifier Las
Vegas [music] is playing an opponent in
his top four.
>> Yeah. So, Sam D. Sherman on Lucian. I
knew that Sam was on this list because I
was talking with Cass earlier and he
[music] was obviously trying to pay
attention to the other Lucian players
because there is the competition for the
best of and I had heard that he was
undefeated going into round seven. So,
this is a good indication that that is
still the case and I am very excited to
see these two get out because both of
these lists are about going big and
getting into combat. Uh, turns out good
players still good as two top four
competitors from Las Vegas are now going
to play each other here in Atlanta to
determine who gets to stay undefeated
going into day number two. What a treat
we have. Two decks we I say one deck we
maybe expected but maybe not to be
undefeated. One deck we definitely
didn't expect and one great game to
close things out here in day one of
Atlanta. We're ready for the game,
folks. Let's go down to the feature
match area. Oh goodness, this is going
to be fun. Yeah, I am excited to see uh
a lot of just combat, right? Uh we had a
meta recently where with the Dravens,
everyone was trying to avoid combat.
Everything goes about how do I get in
and conquer and then get out safely. Uh
these are two heavyweights. We're going
to have units with equipment. We're
going to have units with buffs. Uh both
these players are going to be starting
with battlefields that favor them. Forge
of the Fluff on the side of Sam and then
Colin of course with the Monastery to
draw cards off of the buffs.
>> Yeah, I did say Monastery is one of
those things where even though
battlefields in this game are
symmetrical uh not always the case it
feels like sometimes and FET definitely
feels like Monastery really favors one
player over the other as uh Colin is
going first. Feels pretty good here in
this spot to kick off your match to stay
undefeated. As you can see, seven and
zero for both these players and C monkey
going to make yet another appearance in
the feature match area as Sam is going
to channel these three runes. Again,
both these players playing to finish
this day with an unblenmished record.
And it is such a treat to have two very
skilled players piloting a very fun
match up as Lucian going to come out of
the chosen champion and onto the table.
>> Yeah. And Colin now readying up going to
four runes. And we have that sea monkey
on the side. So, you know, monkey see,
monkey conquer. I would expect that to
go in somewhere here soon, but uh looks
like we're going to have a card played
ahead of time. And that's going to be a
Fiora and a pass. Okay, so instead
opting to preserve the might. Doesn't
want to throw something away, right?
Being patient. I think a lot of players
would have put something on a
battlefield there to get the point. But,
uh, again, we've talked about in the
past in Riftbound, the even numbers of
points are more important. Two is better
than one. four is better than three,
etc. And so getting that one point for
kind of no reason and then losing the
unit. Uh Colin says, "Hey, I don't want
to do that and give you free value."
>> Yeah. Now, Lucian a little bit different
because Lucian when Conquers does ready,
so it can always move back as there are
being played as well going to be
equipped thanks to uh weapon master. My
brain is remembering.
>> Uh no, it's actually going to be the
forge here. So, the way that you're
dodging the costs as you conquer the
forge and then you are able to turn your
leader sideways, turn that legend
>> into the exhausted position and attach
an equipment.
>> And actually, that's even better cuz
Skyfall has a little bonus equip cost.
Most of the equip costs are a single
power. This one is an energy and a
power. So, a big discount thanks to
Forge of the Fluff as Sam Sherman first
on the board with the first point. But,
I love Colin's patience. And just want
to pull up Set's legend real quick
because we might have to give this one a
read cuz I think our viewers might be
familiar with Lucian. I'm not sure we're
as familiar with Set and I believe this
is Set's first time in the feature match
area. So Set really interesting legend.
Yeah, this is one that tries to preserve
your units, right? You're trying to save
them over the course of a game. And if
the Forge of the Fluff is also something
that maybe Colin wanted to use at some
point, the thing is is forge does
require you to exhaust your legend. Uh
Lucian just has a passive. You do not
have to exhaust it when it's used. Set
does exhaust. So again, uh if there is
equipment and Colin wanted to take
advantage of it, unable to. Uh but
again, Set's legend ability. I I know
that the Chinese card is down there and
you can't read it, but it is one where
uh you can preserve a unit at the cost
of a buff. I'll translate for you,
Chara. When a buffed unit you control
would die, you may pay a power and
exhaust me to spend its buff and recall
it exhausted instead when you conquer
readyme. So really annoying for your
opponents to deal with. The units kind
of feel like they never get failed. I
mean, if you remember reaver's row uh
being very annoying to try and pick off
units from set kind of does some of
that, but he does it on both sides of
the equation, offensive defense, so long
as you have a buff, which the sea monkey
and the fura now have. And this is also
showing why the sea monkey did not get
thrown away because with two units on
the board, the kinku monk gets maximum
value. You get two buffs and the four
might. So this is essentially four
energy and one power for six additional
might. But also makes that Fiora mighty.
So very relevant. Also on the sea monkey
now is an expendable buff. So if you
come out and then go back in in terms of
conquering the monastery, it's a way to
draw cards if necessary. Again, just a
very versatile opener here from Colin.
>> I also just realized that that is not
the set people typically play.
>> Uh, correct. I believe that's King.
>> That is set kingpin. We'll give that a
read in just a moment. But Lucian's
getting loaded up, so we didn't have
time for that right now. It is two to
one in points, but Sam Sherman is trying
to even things up. Get out of here,
Lucian. Just a good oldfashioned classic
hidden blade going to make Lucian hit
the bin. Sam will take the cards, but
Colin at least wins the day in the
battlefield.
Yeah, and this is actually a pretty big
deal because the Lucian uh is denied
getting the points. Sam also only on one
whereas Colin's on two and currently has
both locations. Uh not likely
to
be denied holding either of these. I
mean, I guess there's a scenario where
uh if Sam really wants to, there could
be a situation where you attach all this
equipment to the Porro and go in on one
side, but then you're going to be
dramped a lot of runes to do that. I see
Relentless Pursuit in hand as well,
which will save you one of those
potential equip costs, but also might
mean that Porro can do some dancing
between the battlefields. This is one of
the ways that Lucian can both score a
lot of points and clear out a lot of
battlefields. So, could get spicy. I'll
say that very much. I'm not I'm not
going to do the math right now, but I am
telling you that Sam D. Sherman is
>> well, and this is also the best place to
use something uh like Relentless Pursuit
when it comes to equipping because as
you pointed out, Skyfall has one energy
and one power. Pursuit allows you to
attach something essentially for free.
So, you are dodging the additional cost
there. But again, it's a powerful card.
It's typically one that you want to save
for either a combo turn or where you're
going to guarantee your value. Uh this
is just a simple math game. Colin has
exhausted all of the runes. So, you'd
have to be confident that uh the Damp
and all of this is worth it if you want
to pull it off. The other thing you do
have to consider is uh set is not
exhausted. The legend. So, uh one of
these buff units can be saved.
>> Correct.
>> So, which unit are you trying to go
after first? And I guess Coland does get
to choose. So, it does just want to save
Fury. He will have the option. And we
are going for it here, but we are not
equipping. So, we're not going for
Relentless Pursuit.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and I think that this is uh
correct in this situation because if Oh
no, I was wrong. We are going to
Relentless Pursuit.
I I take it all back. Let's pause. Let's
come back to what I was just about to
say. Uh because we paid all of the
costs, but then equipped the Doran's
Blade instead of the Skyfall. There a
minor misstep we can say, but still
going to work all the same. Here it is.
Eight might on the pouty porro and is
only seven between the sea monkey its
buff and the kingu monk. So sea monkey
is going to go by. Colin already knows
what's happening cuz the other part of
relentless pursuit. There's quite a lot
of text on this card. The last bit is
when I conquer which has just happened.
Sam Dman now up to two points. You may
move me back to base. And Pyro says yes
please. I am hungry for more blood.
Fiora is going to be taken out here in
the top side. Null I think is saying you
know what this buff is not worth it. I'd
rather keep my Fiora. does cost the
power as well, but seems like a worthy
bit of uh expenditure in order to save
your pretty nice unit.
>> So Sam of course had to recycle a number
of runes there, but with the set leader
activation, you also have the situation
where uh Colin is only going to come
into this turn with five, but as you had
pointed out, it is set kingpin that is
in the champion zone. So we could see
that at some point here. Uh this is a
unit that is very might positive. you're
spending four energy and one power for a
base five might. It does also have tank
and then it gets bigger as well if you
have other buffed units present. So, it
can represent a lot of additional might
for low investment. Uh in the current
situation though, it would just be the
raw might because there are no other
buffed units. They were cleaned up by
Sam the previous turn. Uh looking at the
hand, we could also see something like a
sabotage just trying to pick apart what
Sam has left. There's a really
interesting spot for Colin because I
think after that play like Sam obviously
is happy with clearing out a bunch of
units getting up ahead on points keeping
all the equipment on one you know it's
not Lucian which would be amazing but
pouty par you know he's doing a decent
job here with the deflect and Colin I
think wants to take advantage of the big
rune advantage he now has and try and
get some tempo back with the fior that
he managed to save but there's not
really much tempo to be gain that hand
did not have a lot of action in it
>> and so the set is the play here just
again getting that big raw might on the
board for now I think the consideration
is whether or not this is going to be
either a sabotage. I don't think
showstopper is worth it. You want to
usually use that to capitalize on units
that are on battlefields and catch them
off guard. Um so again, I think the
consideration is whether or not the
sabotage is worth it or perhaps just
saying, "Hey, Sam just spent a lot of
the runes in the recycling format, so
only going to have four energy available
next turn. Maybe I'm not worried about
what's coming." And I was wrong. Uh we
are going to see a showstopper here. I
mean, the thing is this is the only way
for Colin to actually put a buff on his
units, which is pretty key to how Set
wants to function, especially with this
Fiora that can get mighty with just a
single buff. So, we're going to get
moved over to the battlefield and then
retreat. That is an option here cuz of
course, Fiora stayed ready thanks to the
Showstopper move. Showstopper notably
also set signature spell, not an action,
is a regular spell uh regular speed
spell. So, does have to be played with
nothing else really going on. Uh, no
trickiness like Reliance Pursuit or Ride
the Wind where you're moving around
battlefields in action windows. So, Fura
does take the retreat. The points get
evened up and Colin passes back the
term. This game already getting quite
tense between these two.
>> This is uh very interesting. So, this
tells me that Colin just really
prioritized getting that might on the
Fiora, activates all of the keywords on
it because she becomes mighty. Also
becomes savable once again with the set
legend. But the thing that stands out to
me is that the one point gained is still
just on the odd number, right? We were
just talking about how even numbers are
traditionally where you want to be in
Riftbound. Uh Sam with this likely
incoming porro conquer will jump to
four, but the porro unlike the Lucian
legend does not ready on conquer. So uh
might have a situation where the porro
is left out to dry. We're going to see
what Sam can develop with the four runes
available. Getting a peek at this hand.
It looks like punch first relentless
pursuit challenge skyfall. I can't quite
figure out
>> is a Trinity Force.
>> I think you might be right. So, some
decent options here, but no other units
really to speak of that Lucian that they
uh decks not rely on, I would say, but
often lean on to be kind of the the
lynch pin of their strategy, especially
in the earlier turns. Not available at
least for
>> No, I was wrong. The last one is a
challenge. That is a two out of four.
It's a little bit blurry on the side,
but
>> puzzling out. What? There's a I don't
know if people can quite see it, but if
you look at the edge of the screen as
Sam shuffles his cards around, there's a
three energy card. I'm trying to figure
out what it is. But you know what?
Perhaps that's a question for later. As
Pow is going to move in, get to four
points. So, we're back to even kill, but
uh Pipo has no way to leave the
premises. No way. But because this was a
challenge, I was correct here. This will
be a great way to take out one of these
units. The question is, do you want to
just get rid of the buff that was on the
Fiora and force the expenditure of power
to save it with the set legend ability
or
>> call to glory?
>> Is it a call to glory? So again, we've
talked about how this is so important
because you can play it for free just by
spending the buff. That means that the
Porro dies from the challenge.
What a blowout. Yeah, that was nice.
Cold to glory. Really nice. One of the
few free spells available in roof
bounded again with set having all this
access to buffs. I guess Le does as
well, but unfortunately you don't see
that one too often in the feature match
area. Certainly not at X and O at the
end of day one. Able to buff that up and
force a trade which does mean that Pipo
and that equipment had nowhere else to
go. But Sam did have another unit.
Legion rear guard as sabotage going to
reveal the hand. It is Skyfall punch
first and Relentless Pursuit. So we had
everything right for this Legion rear
guard. was just chilling, ready to pick
up the equipment. I think the problem
is, yes, all this equipment is here for
this rear guard, but you're not going to
have very many runes at this rate.
>> Yeah, this is an interesting match up
because both players are showing that
this is a a power hungry match between
the two. Uh, yes, you can play all of
these very powerful cards, but they all
cost power uh to either play or to
equip. And so, we're routinely seeing
these players at five runes or less. Uh,
not a lot of big bombs coming down from
the late game in this matchup. And a
second showstopper is going to be played
on this Fiora. So, the buff coming back
once again.
>> Do it again. Buffing the Fiora, setting
up protection for her with the set if
needed. Moving her in for a point.
Getting back to even here now as four
and then retreating once again. So, oh,
actually going for the second point
here. ganking over now that she's mighty
>> and being able to draw the card cuz the
other site is the monastery. And now
we're going to see a challenge as well
to get rid of the rear guard which was
the only unit on the side of Sam.
>> I think this is a huge play because you
clean it up before the equipment can be
attached. You're just removing the
choice alto together. And now Sam is
kind of in a pickle. I love
>> I love this play pattern because I think
one of the things that Lucians often uh
you know aren't too happy about is when
they draw you know don't draw an even
split of both halves of the deck. You
know you need units and equipment. You
know if you have nothing to attach your
equipment to doesn't feel so good if you
only have units and nothing to attach to
them. That also feels kind of bad. And
Colin I think is just taking the line of
I'm just going to keep taking out your
units. So these equipment you can keep
them. If you have nothing to put them on
I do not care. Unfortunately there's
another unit in Sam Sherman's hand. And
now the question is, do you want to
equip to try and make the might a little
bit bigger cuz you just got challenged.
You don't really want that to happen
again.
>> Well, so the I think the real
opportunity here is if you play this
Relentless Pursuit and you attach an
equipment and go in, you can get rid of
the Fiora before it can get another buff
on it.
>> Unfortunately, Relentless Pursuit got
taken by Sabotage the previous turn.
>> Oh, that is correct. Uh and and that
makes all all the more sense on why the
challenge was played on the rear guard
as well because other than the top deck,
uh you knew that there wasn't going to
be any accelerated units coming, right?
There could have been a situation where
you're punished by like a Kai'Sa another
rear guard, but
setting up for the double conquer. Colin
has been really light on buff effects
this game. I mean, pitu in only one of I
think the Kinku monk in his main is the
only copy. That was very good for a
bunch of extra buff value. But, you
know, for the the deck that wants to do
all the buffing, for the guy with all
the abs in the legend picture, he's
Fiora not looking all too mighty, but
still setting up now at six points for a
double conquer win. And Lucian, I mean,
can come back. Usually needs the combo
pieces of Trinity Force and Skyfall. Has
one half of that right now. In fact, if
it was Trinity Force, Relless Pursuit,
Sandy Sherman actually would win the
game right now, which would be pretty
sick. But we already know that one of
those pieces is missing.
So five here plus a recycle
>> survivor.
>> All right. So the Kai'Sa was picked up
off the top deck. And this is something
that uh is very important because it not
only accelerates in to get the point but
draws cards to maybe find something like
that Trinity Force or uh some additional
help. card that has treated Sam D
Sherman very well, I might add. Was
obviously in his winning Draven list in
his mid-range Draven list that he played
to win a Vegas and you know seems pretty
good here at home in Lucian.
>> Yeah, I was just about to say these
equipment pieces I think have to go on
the units because you don't want a
double conquer to occur. Now, normally
you might say not that worried about it.
It's just two Fioras. However, uh you've
already seen at least one Kinku Monk
played this turn which allows you to
buff two units and that would activate
both of them. There's of course other
cards that are just as impactful as
well. So playing around uh the double
conquer here is important. One card in
the hand on the side of Colin and then a
top deck is what Sam is worried about.
So is indeed going to recycle yet
another rune and leave up one. And often
you I'll say these uh these domains not
a lot of tricks to worry about. Oh,
there is one that springs to mind that I
do know happens to be in Sandy Sherman's
hand and uh that is punching first for a
lot of extra M as Fior are going to have
to rumble in try and take out the
Kaiser. No buff to speak of, no other
way to buff these units. So, it's
currently eight to six. A punch first
says no, I don't think so.
>> And that's going to be game number one.
>> Going to be it because there was no
additional answer. The hand was the Fay
Dragon and the Lucian. And uh Sam able
to squeak into victory. I felt like
Colin had a really good opener there at
one point, taking out the units,
continuing to pressure Sam, but uh the
good news for the Lucian player is that
when those units die, the might from the
equipment stays on the board, right? So,
while the set player is trying to
preserve the units by spending the
buffs, keeping the units alive, the
Lucian player is just kind of always
keeping the might that was developed in
the uh form of equipment on the board.
That was the one that won. But uh this
was close and I think it was a lot of
fun. I'm excited to see what players
bring for game two.
>> Yeah, already actually I think it's kind
of exciting. It is Grover the Godwiller
here for Con wanting more draw from his
battlefield. Monastery obviously best in
class for set but Grove's pretty good
set does do a decent amount of holding
and char you can't see shaking his hands
violently at the television because we
see a battlefield that we do not see
very often. Sam D Sherman I love this
little tech choice. Windswept killing
Yasawo's home now here for Lucian. Yeah,
this is of course a battlefield that
provides ganking. And yesterday you and
I were saying that we were windswept
Helic truthers. We kept saying, "Hey,
that'll be good someday." Well, it turns
out that day was today because we're
seeing it used by a player that is
undefeated going into our last round of
Swiss on day one and is up a game. So
again, Sam finding success with the
Hillick. Uh, and it makes sense, right,
from a standpoint of yes, the Lucian has
a lot of mobility, but as we saw in that
first game, sometimes your Lucian dies.
Uh, giving ganking to something like
those porros or the rear guards that
have a bunch of equipment on them gives
them the additional utility. Uh, this is
something that I really like to see in
the Lucian deck. game one I think also
showcasing that yes Lucian is obviously
the best unit you can use and you
thankfully get one going second every
time from the champ zone which feels
pretty good especially because there's
no threat of something like a charm uh
that can maybe undo your plans here by
playing an early Lucian which I know the
Aurelia players have been pretty fond of
in that matchup but it is a Lucian on
the other side deciding you know what I
do like that you know I will also play
it I don't have as many weapons as you I
actually don't know if Colin has any
weapons at all but the first time I
conquer each turn ready me is pretty
good text Well, even if Colin does not
have any weapons, if they have an
auction or two in the list, they could
take the weapons and then attach it to
the Lucian, which is just very, very
cheeky. But nonetheless, it's also just
a good unit for getting in, getting
points, and getting out as we're likely
to see from Sam here. So, uh, goes to
the Hillick and readies. How we feeling?
Are we feeling greedy? Do we want two
points? We have another Lucian instead.
We're just going to go ahead play the
dorance, play the second Lucian attached
thanks to weapon master for no
additional cost and retreat the other
Lucian. So the ganking would have meant
you could have get two points there, but
deciding that the safety in the base is
more worthwhile.
>> Yeah, I like the patience. And uh do my
eyes deceive me?
>> I don't know. Do they?
>> Uh do I see six runes on the side of
Colin?
>> Yeah, he did not have a turn two play or
turn one play.
>> No, no, no. I'm mostly mentioning it
because last game we were so low on
runes for the majority of it, but so far
uh neither player has actually recycled
a rune. So, a big departure from what we
saw in the first game and Colin uh is
instead just going to take that double
conquer that we were just talking about.
Lucian goes into the hill and then ganks
over.
>> Love me some arena. Lucian going to
chill at the god Willow and perhaps have
a little sip.
>> Ooh, first mage to bring it back. Buff
from the bar as well. That is exhaust
buff an exhausted friendly unit and
again set loves buffs so this is a
pretty nice way to provide them. The the
down payment is a little steep perhaps
having to invest three energy but every
turn after that it awakens and you get
to use it kind of for free turn after
turn.
>> Yeah and Colin is playing a quite a bit
of units. I mean you expect that in any
deck that's going to be body oriented.
Uh we have a sabotage coming from Sam
though.
>> Didn't get to see what it was cuz
there's only one option to take. Can't
take units with sabotage. So, uh,
something has been recycled. A non-unit
card to be exact. I think it might have
been a showstopper as Sam D. Sherman
gonna have to have a little read of Fay
Dragon. This is like Kingu Monk but
better.
>> Yeah. And it's so funny because when we
were looking at the deck lists earlier,
I highlighted Fay Dragon and said
anytime you can play a card and have
your opponent reach over and read it,
you start to feel good. And that's
exactly what happened. Now, that
obviously the Fay Dragon wasn't played
here. It was revealed with the sabotage,
but uh it is one of those situations
where you're like, "Okay, uh it's a
little bit spicy, and I was not
expecting that." And now we have a
challenge going.
>> I love uh Sam's shortcutting there. By
the way, these players obviously both
very good at rift bound. So Sam just
exhausting his two units and saying,
"I'm cap I'm getting these two points."
And Con saying, "Yep, that's fine. We'll
move on. I don't need to move the
Lucians to the base. Don't need to do uh
the uh the ceremony. Can just go ahead
and take the points." Uh challenge does
remove the buff. and Kaiisa is going to
be the followup here. So interesting
just to want to make that Lucian a
little bit smaller because as we know
with the arena bar easy to rebuff again
but guess just testing a little rune
there wanting to see if uh Colin to use
sets ability does indeed want to save to
Lucian. So kind of a curious little
exchange but don't mind it here as Colin
is considering what to do. Uh, another
thing to consider there is that it with
the save forced the recycle, which is
relevant because you just saw the hand
with the sabotage and you know a fade
dragon is there. So you're saying if
you're going to play the fade dragon, I
want it to be your entire turn
essentially. I don't want to give you uh
even an opening to maybe top deck a
punch first and have an energy
available, right? So, uh I think this
was a situation that might have been uh
the benefit of sabotaging getting the
information and Sam saying, "Okay, uh
either you lose the unit or uh you're
going to ramp down because of the
recycle."
>> You are going to be twopoint gamers once
again, but first mate is going to do the
work at the Grow the God Willow and Fade
Dragon is going to reinforce buff up to
four friendly units including itself.
So, he's going to get one. First M's
going to get one, you get a buff, you
get a buff, etc., etc. I assume Lucian
is going to go back home and indeed is
going to exhaust back there and arena
bar unfortunately sadly I do say you get
to use it turn after turn that's only if
they don't have a buff you can't buff a
unit
>> only on turn you're not playing fade
dragon buffing the entire board
>> and playing fade dragon feels pretty
good so don't think Colin's too mad
>> yeah it does feel good this is a
situation where it now again becomes
just a simple math equation for Sam
though because Colin had to use all of
the energy to play the dragon and that
means that if Sam has a punch first or
some other things to go over the top.
You could still conquer the grove. Uh
you don't have to play around anything
with the exception of Call to Glory
because we saw that be incredibly
impactful in game one and you have to
think that that's on Sam's mind because
it just happened.
>> It is 12 to 12 right now as far as might
goes. 12 sitting on that battlefield
thanks to the buffs there for Colin and
12 in base right now for Sam. But that
is all of the might each player has
right now. So if C of glory is one of
those cards, it's going to look real
silly to run your entire team in there.
>> This is also a rough situation to be in
because even if you do go over top of
everything on the grove, the set legend
ability will be able to save this fade
dragon. The fade dragon being so big and
having that base might of seven, but
also having the buff and with the
presence of arena bar as well, it's
going to be very hard to get rid of
that. So this is something that I think
Sam has to recognize and know. I have to
go over this over and over again or we
kind of have to adjust our game plan,
maybe play for the combo in some
direction. So, it looks like we're going
to have a double Kai'Sa go over to the
Hill and this says to me digging for
answers again. Maybe those combo pieces
is the route Sam is going.
>> Not the combo I expected, but playing
another Kai'Sa to draw an extra card. I
would say that's a combo of sorts. So,
SamD Sherman going to not be too unhappy
with the situation. Curious if Colin I
guess we'll see what happens after this
but curious if Colin is considering to
run the Lucian in maybe trade off with a
Kaiser because again you can exhaust
your set recycle a rune lose your buff
and have things kind of work out in your
favor if Colin wants to chip away but
it's a whole point to five now four for
Sam Sherman who did not who only
collected a single point sorry on that
last turn and a quick flash of the hand
there for Colin showed me a Fiora but
not much else keeping it fairly close as
Grove of the Godwhe going to draw an
extra card this turn
>> we know from the sabotager earlier
there's two Fioras in hand. Uh, but the
new information, as you pointed out,
will be the card from the turn, the card
from the Grove,
and now Colin's taking a moment to think
through how this is going to be
navigated. Uh, if I was on the side of
Sam, I'd be worried about cards like
potentially showstopper to maybe run one
of the units back to base, jump in over
top of the Kais become a real problem.
Uh, right now sitting on the Grove is
obviously beneficial. you want to draw
those cards from the grove hold, but
also as scary as it seems, you could get
that fade dragon on the hill and then
just threaten the other side anytime
they go there. So, there's a lot of
versatility in the way that Colin can
attack the board stick.
>> Yeah, feels like Colin's positioning is
pretty good. I I don't think you ever
feel comfortable fully against Lucian. I
do see an Axan. I do see a face breaker
and I do see Fiora Fiora first mate. The
two Fiora's first mate Akshan and
Facebreaker of the cards in Colin's
hand. Sam D Shman doing his traditional
uh keeping his hand face down on the
table. Almost picks it up right as I
said it. Unique form of cast a curse
perhaps, but [laughter] Colin deep in
the tank. Two runes available here for
Sam. And again, not an easy situation to
navigate. Even if Colin feels like it's
going well, his units are buffed.
They're protected in some way thanks to
set. But I guess it is worth noting uh
set does not awaken at the end of your
turn. That happens at the beginning. So
if you want to use your set, let's say
offensively here by running Lucian in
using the buff to trade off with a
Kaiser, you only get to ready set when
you conquer. And trading is certainly
not conquering. Yeah, I think the real
decision here for Colin is just how to
navigate through the situation when you
don't have a lot of combat tricks,
right? Like we're looking at the hand.
You got face breaker and you essentially
have a bunch of units. So, anything that
you're doing, you're kind of doing the
good old-fashioned way. Am I moving a
unit back to base to maybe set up a
conquer in the future? Am I doing
something uh with this auction to maybe
steal the Doran's Blade away? I don't
like that play. I like saving it for one
of the combo pieces like a Trinity Force
uh or like an Aryan Skyfall. But uh
again right now uh the turn appears to
be on Colin's side just developing might
and then either passing or trying to do
something where you're setting up a
future turn. Uh the downside is is that
you're going to give up that hold point
and all likely to Sam. On the plus side
though because the Kais are going to be
likely staying there. They won't be able
to draw from the conqueror on that side
unless they go to the other side. And
we're going to see set kingpin come from
the champion zone over to the grove of
the godwillow. Get a buff as well for
your trouble thanks to the arena bar
because set exhausted himself uh
naturally by being reinforced to the
battlefield cuz that is the standard
state for units. They do come in
exhausted. Colin steal a few more runes.
There is maybe a play here to be made
with first mate. You could move the
dragon back, reread it, move it over.
Don't know if that's necessarily what we
need. Again, I think it's important not
to overplay at this point cuz we're
getting to a point where last few turns
of this game are kind of approaching.
And I think both players are thinking,
well, for Sam, you might be thinking, if
I draw my combo, I can maybe win from
four, but both players are generally
thinking once we get to six, I can then
craft an endame where I win with a
double score. So, now you're trying to
navigate to the position, we're getting
close to that stage of the game. What do
I need to do to ensure I win this game?
>> So, the interesting thing to point out
right now is that uh oh, we might see
the Aan. Okay, Ashan's going to steal
the blade and just kind of take the
tempo away. I don't hate this. It's
going to attach to the Aan. Maybe set up
a future take. Uh what I was going to
point out is that uh Colin technically
has the point lead. So holding on this
grove means if things stay the way they
are with just one on each side, Colin is
favored. But also that set kingpin
sitting there by itself is worth nine
might. has the base
>> gets the buff to six, but it also gets
an extra plus one for every buffed
friendly unit counting itself. So that
unit alone is nine. Then you have the FA
dragon for eight. And the other unit,
you could just sit there and say either
you draw the combo and go over top of me
or I just win from camping growth.
>> Yeah, 21 might at that battlefield when
it's all added up. And as a reminder,
set Kingping does have tank. I can see
why Colin maybe likes this unit as his
chosen champion. And as you mentioned,
camping that grove means you are just
getting extra cards turn after turn. And
that is typically in card games a good
way to get ahead. So Sam Sherman with
quite the puzzle kind of went in on the
Kaiser to get some cards to dig for some
answers. But Kaiser is not stranded cuz
Windswift Killic, which is the
battlefield they're currently sitting
at, does grant ganking. So if you can
get conquers, and you can or you could,
I should say, yeah,
>> you would be able to draw more cards.
It's just that conquering this
particular battlefield looks a little
dicey to say the least.
>> And the other situation you're in is if
you pull the Kis's back to try to
conquer on the hillic side the next
turn, you are allowing Colin to
potentially get a free point there
because of the Lucian can go in and go
out or Colin could just put the other
units there and say when these Kais come
back, you're also going to force some
trades, right? There's a lot of might
that has the potential to go in that
direction because uh again the auction
with the Doran's blade now is up to six.
That Lucian with the buff is uh an
additional four. So that's 10 might
being able to be thrown in that
direction plus whatever is in Colin's
hand. Uh if you're Sam, you don't know
what it is other than the two Fioras.
Again, known information from an earlier
sabotage, but uh if your opponent has
drawn into something like a punch first,
that could be an even bigger hill to
climb. Uh this is not an easy situation
to play from if you're Sam.
>> I do spy confront at the top of the hand
here which does mean that you know a
deck that kind of typically is a little
doesn't have as much accelerator as
maybe this you might expect in this in
these domains. Uh confront is a way to
ready up some units for a pretty big
turn. I see a first mate as well. I
believe I spy another challenge. So, a
lot of options here potentially for
Sam's shown. But again, figuring out
what makes him when you're trying to
crack more than 20 might out a
battlefield. And that's without set
saving one of the units by the way. Like
whatever damage you do, you're only
going to do so much. But confront is the
call here. Sam Sherman saying, "I have
to move in and do something." And Colin
leaning back in the chair behind a game,
but in a pretty good position does not
want something bad to happen. But
confront usually means uh something is
going to happen,
>> right? And there's also the dig there,
right? If you're saying like maybe
[laughter] Sam is just trying to find
the one thing they need or maybe they
have a very big play. Uh the interesting
thing about Confront in these lists with
Fury as well is uh it's a great way to
trigger Legion if you're running
hopefuls and also give them accelerate
with the draw. It almost comes uh out to
be a create your own Kai'Sa at home,
right? You're accelerating a unit
getting a draw.
>> But uh
>> in this case, I I really think this was
Sam digging for an answer and I don't
think one was found. The hand does not
look that much better. Uh, no Trinity
Force. There is the Skyfall, but if
we're trying to get the combo online,
doesn't look like that is the option.
Instead, we're [laughter] going to make
the full house on the hill. That's
right. It is three Lucian and two.
[laughter]
One of them's awake.
Uh, Colin says, "Yeah, I'll take my
point. I'll take my extra draw and I'll
keep myself ahead in this race." Sandy
Sherman trying to play the whole game,
which I think something uh is is
something that set does quite a bit
better, but uh there's always a plan
here, always a wave for Lucian.
>> So, this is actually a really
interesting line from Sam because what
you're doing is you're putting a bunch
of might on the Hill to prevent Colin
from getting the free point there, but
also if Colin doesn't go in and doesn't
take some of that might offic allowing
ganking means you can still go from
there to the other side. So you're not
really losing anything by stacking
everything on Hillick.
>> That's hype. It's like uh the best base
you could ask for. Chilling in the
windswept here. First mate going to re
ready set kingpin. And I think this set
may be doing uh little little solo
mission. Although we're counting, so
maybe not. Maybe there's a couple
friends coming with the kingpin.
>> No, I think this might either be
everything or at least the Lucian with
it because Kingpin is going to get the
additional might from a buffed unit. But
uh this is I think a very safe offensive
use of set from the sight of Colin
because as you pointed out uh the set
kingpin has tank so the damage has to be
assigned there first and then also
because of the buff the set legend can
recall it and make use of that as well
and it does look like that's going to be
the case here. So you get rid of a bunch
of might off of the hillic
>> and you're getting to preserve units and
you still have a mountain on the grove
and it's fast approaching a situation
where we're going to game three.
>> Yeah, you get all theite. In fact, you
get the buff back as well thanks to
arena bar if you want to put it back on
set kingpin. You certainly do in this
deck. Lucian also available to be moved
back to base if that's a safer place.
This first mate going to reready set
king and go back
move the fort back over. Kango to the
other side and said, "I'm at seven. Good
luck cracking this battlefield." And 70
Sherman says, "I don't know if I can,
but I'm going to give it my best go."
>> I I just I can't imagine what Lucian can
have here to do anything. I think we're
going to game three.
>> So, well, theoretically,
>> all right, hear me out. Theoretically,
if you had a hand that was
>> uh Trinity Force, Trinity Force, rear
guard.
>> Yes.
>> And you had one more rune cuz that's all
you [laughter] need, right? uh then
maybe you could get there. But
unfortunately, that's not the case. The
Skyfall was already on the board. So,
Trinity Force is kind of what you're
looking for there. Uh if you were trying
to go up two points, but you need at
least a third activation as well. Uh and
we are in fact going to game three. This
is everything I hoped it would be. Like
I said, heavyweights slugging it out.
It's just might on might. Not a lot of
fancy stuff who can get there and get
the job done. And uh for this last one,
an interesting set of battlefields once
again. On the one side, sunken temple
makes a lot of sense when you have these
big beefy units. On the other side
though, candle lit Sanctum. I believe
this is a situation where Sam is
potentially hoping to find the combo
pieces. Again, that's Aryan Skyfall and
Trinity Force. uh perhaps only playing
these in the game threes, kind of
anticipating a situation where if I'm
going all the way to game three, my
opponent has some sort of tech and now I
have to uh divert my game plan to
something a little bit different from
the standard uh on curve play that we
saw in game one.
>> Yeah, gives you a couple extra looks,
let you filter through cards whenever
you conquer it. Of course, is extra nice
if you have Kai'Sa survivor cuz you get
to draw the card after you have a little
look. See, I do appreciate though, by
the way, that Colin is kind of at a
single speed as far as the battlefields
go. I was just like, you know what I
want my Battlefield to do? I want them
all to draw me cards.
>> Yeah, we've seen a lot of variations of
that uh across the legends of the day.
We've seen uh obviously Zon Warren still
incredibly popular. Uh we have seen the
conservatory show up big for the decks
that are running a lot of spells. So, I
think folks are still trying to figure
out what is the best way for me to get
the value into my hand from the
battlefields, but also ones that are
easy for me to accomplish and hopefully
less easy for my opponent to take
advantage of.
>> Yeah, I like I think set is one of the
decks that can actually afford to play
these three battlefields and do well on
all of them as far as drawing cards go,
which is kind of a tough thing to find
nowadays with Dreaming Tree being
rightfully banned, I will say, despite
being a uh I say enjoyer of that
battlefield myself.
I've used it uh one a few times in my
time while I was around in Spirit Forge.
Game number three, as you said, drama,
everything we hope the series would be.
If you are newer to Riftbound or you,
you know, maybe looking for one uh one
set to tune in today from this far, you
should just watch this one. These are
two of the best bound players we have in
the room, I have to think, given that
the uh the median finish is what,
something like
>> second from the last RQ.
>> So, I just want to say how proud of you
I am.
>> Really,
>> I said I was going to make a a real dad
of you this weekend. you are a a father
of course, but uh
>> you you made the pun. You said if you
had to watch one set, this would be it.
And of course, Colin is piloting set.
So, I just want to say I'm sorry.
>> I didn't even do it on purpose. And of
course, [laughter] that's the thing that
Cha picks up as we're off to the races.
Sam D Sherman on the board early on the
play. Legion rear guard on the table and
Colin answers with Lucian. Not bad
there. Not playing Lucian, but has
Lucian as we noted. Pretty good card
still. and does have the auctions to
make it even spicier.
>> Now, the question is, is the rear guard
going to go into something like candle
it, get the uh look first and then
decide what to do, or is it just going
to be a development and pass with some
patience? I do see the Trinity Force in
hand on the side of Sam. And I think
there's also a Skyfall there. So there
might already be uh both pieces
>> in play
>> ready to go in just a moment. And that
is indeed Skyfall and Trinity Force.
Couple extra cards there as well as Sam
Sherman as always. Very deliberate, very
thoughtful player. We saw this when he
was piloting mid-range Draven to his
victory in Vegas not too long ago.
>> Yeah. So, one of the I think really
important things about this matchup is
Sam knows Colin has access to Achan. So,
you don't want to play the pieces and
have them get stolen. Sam also knows
that sabotage exists in the other list.
So, you don't want to keep them in your
hand and have them get taken away. So,
it's kind of a pick your poison
situation. I like the go-ahhead of let's
put it on the table because maybe at a
minimum I get to make use of the might.
Uh it's also something where uh if I
play the Lucian for my champion zone
next turn, I get the free equip because
of weapon master. So I think this was
the way to go. But it is worth noting
it's not an easy decision when you know
your opponent has answers in the form of
ashan if it's on the table or sabotage
if it's in the hand. And of course we
see the action in the hand of Colin.
going to say got a little glance and
Colin does indeed have a few units in
the hand and one of them is Ashan maybe
thinking is now the time to steal this
triforce punch first another option
available candle at Sanctum being
considered that's where the hand is
getting glanced at a few times here and
we're going to go ahead and put this one
back on top cuz we've already put one on
the bottom column just making sure
that's the decision he does want to go
with and does indeed finish his
filtering
>> Ashan
>> and yeah I was going to say this is
>> it's the wrong tap Ruction.
So, it's probably not that. It is Fiora
instead.
>> Lucian goes back and say your turn. What
do you got?
>> I was about to say this is likely an
auction, but instead we're going to see
the Fiora. Uh, not tipping that the
answer is available early on.
>> Maybe saying, "Okay, show me that you
also have the Skyfall. Spend all of the
uh energy and runes to equip." All
right. So, this is this is interesting
because just hear me out. We have seen
in the past where Sam has uh not used
the Relentless Pursuit to attach the
Skyfall. Here though, I think properly
recognizing that you want to use the
weapon master on the Trinity Force
because that part will be free and then
use Relentless Pursuit potentially later
to do this. But, uh again, you're now
showing that you have the combo. Uh
you're just saying, "Look, I have the
pieces. I'm going to pass. What do you
got? Again, we know Colin has the
action. Is now the turn where it gets
played or do you continue to try to bait
this out? Sam does have zero points. It
is worth noting.
>> I think the other thing to consider, I
think maybe this is what Colin's
thinking about. It's not do I play Achan
or not? We going to send Lucian in. That
feels like the obvious thing. Get the
filtering from the sanctum. Lucian
reready. So, this point is in essence
free, especially when Sam D Sherman
doesn't have any runes available. I
think it's which one do I take because
the order your opponent sequences their
combo pieces in might tell you
something. We don't know Sam, but if Sam
has a backup piece in hand, you have to
kind of think pretty hard which piece
would they play first if they were going
to expose one
>> because now you have to think which one
do I take cuz you need to break it up
and if you guess wrong and they have an
extra in hand then you're actually
didn't do all that much. So, uh, the
answer that I would give you is almost
always I would defer to the Trinity
Force for two reasons.
>> Uh, first, Skyfall doesn't do a whole
lot by itself, whereas Trinity Force
still has some intrinsic value. That's
also true.
>> Uh, second, as long as the auction is on
the table, if you decide to, you could
pay that equip cost if you had some way
to get it off, right? If there's some
other effect, you could pay that equip
cost and move it around. You cannot pay
the Skyfalls cost because you don't have
the fur in. So I feel like Trinity Force
is almost always the answer here and
Colin agrees.
>> Yep. I think that's a astute analysis,
Tom. My other little uh addition would
be that I also think if you are trying
to figure out which half may they have a
backup of, the one they play first is
likely the one they might have another
one of cuz they did were willing to
expose it. So a buff goes on thanks to
pit rookie and that's going to protect
the Axan. And um
>> that's pretty annoying
>> to say the very least cuz now Ashan
who's holding that precious Triforce is
awfully tricky to get off the board.
>> Absolutely. It's not just that it's at
seven might because Sam in other
situations could maybe stack a bunch of
might onto a unit, use something like
challenge to deal with a unit. However,
because of the set legend and the
presence of the buff, the set legend can
just save the so you essentially have to
go through it twice. Uh these are a set
of domains that do not have access to
cards like rebuke. So you cannot answer
it directly in that fashion. Uh these
are not domains that have access to
direct removal. So there's no uh hidden
blades, Call of the Weeks, anything
where you're going to answer it
directly. Uh these are looking to either
deal damage via pseudo combat with cards
like challenge or through direct damage
with cards like Falling Star. Uh neither
of those will get the job done in this
situation.
>> No, they would not. Sunken Temple going
to give a draw. Oh, Sammy show me
deciding. I need to keep digging for
more answers or perhaps more Triforce.
Punch first I can see in the hand. I
don't think I can see another copy of
that uh precious Trinity Force though.
And uh I like how Colin's approaching
this matchup as well. Just kind of very
steady. Really feeling like the control
deck in this matchup, right? I mean
again, it is scary because Lucian can
combo you at at a moment's notice. It
feels like sometimes Rigard even going
to get in there. I think Sam decided
your value is not worth all that much
anymore. I've held you back long enough.
you are now going to get me a point and
let me look at a few extra cards cuz
Colin has navigated to a position where
it feels like has a pretty uh pretty
firm control over this board state.
>> Yeah, I think that this is just a good
recognition from Colin to say in terms
of uh deck identities, right? Colin's
list is kind of negating many of the
removal options on the side of Sam
because of the set legend ability. Colin
also knowingly with the auctionons and
the sabotages has I think more effective
disruption. So as you pointed out kind
of playing the role of the control
player just by the nature of what's in
the list. But for me it's the patience
of Colin that's really standing out just
recognizing
>> I can get to a situation where I can
make things uh incredibly hard for Sam.
And uh of course we see the sabotage
going off. Uh it was known information
as you pointed out from the sanctum and
uh we're going to see the choice of
Doran's blade confront or punch first. I
feel like punch first is the obvious one
here. But if you are worried about just
more equipment piling up, maybe the
blade
>> certainly sounds like the the best cut
of all of them. Uh of course with
Lucian's legend giving your units
assault for each equipment they have,
there is some consideration to the might
that that does generate, but the biggest
number is on punch first and so it will
be sabotage. Very swaggy of Colin to
flip that one over. For a second I was
like, how did he know? And then I
remembered thanks to Candle at Sanctum
that Sam brought to this battle.
>> It's one of those situations where you
might go judge because you forgot that
it happened. [laughter] Or you might go
judge just to say that he hurt your
feelings because that was very swaggy.
You are correct. [laughter]
>> All right. Well, Regard is going to hit
the bin as expected. Lucian going to
ready grab the point and get on out of
there. Although once again, Colin has
the opportunity to do the thing whereas
Sanctum is going to put a known card to
the top. And our card puller there from
production did briefly put up called
shot because Colin called that shot
[laughter] from the top of the deck. Uh
I heard called shot was banned. So
that's another reason to call the judge.
>> Nicely done Colin. At least uh getting
the spirit of that card onto the
broadcast somehow.
Uh I think still deciding put one on top
but is still looking at the hand looking
at the other card that Sanctum has shown
him. Just making sure that this is the
one he does want to recycle.
>> Yeah. And again, this is a very
important decision because we are in
game three of the final round of Swiss
on day one. Both players locked for day
two, but if you can go undefeated
through day one, that exponentially
increases your chances of making that
top eight cut because you continue to
make your breakers that much better. You
want to give yourself that cushion going
into the next day. I think we've talked
a lot about, you know, different
players, uh, different heroes across
the, uh, the short time we've had
Riftbound at this level of organized
play. And you know, we talk about
players like Chris Maticism and
rightfully so. Players like Allan
rightfully so. These two already kind of
forging their path through yet another
regional qualifier. Sam one column top
Ford in Vegas and they were both playing
Draven in a deck that was very, very
good. But that deck has been hit. These
players have got their qualification.
They've maybe got the glory they wanted.
They're playing some legends that maybe,
you know, aren't as good as that deck
was, maybe aren't as represented as the
top two, and still forging their path,
which I think proving that doesn't
really matter as much what deck you're
playing. If you're a good player, it is
going to show.
>> I also just love that Colin went back to
set because for me, one of the real fun
stories about Riftbound because it is a
game based on League of Legends is you
get those players that are specialists,
right? You get the players that in
League, they say, "I main Ahri, and then
they have a dumb gamer name like Charmer
[laughter] because they main Arri."
Well, the same thing can happen here in
Riftbound and Colin showing that yes, I
can play Draven when it's the best deck
in the format, but also I can go back to
my first love.
>> All right. Well, four points to Colin
for two here for Sam D Sherman. Colin
once again slowly inching out a lead.
Set is the deck that really can grind
you into dust. Very tricky, very mobile,
very annoying to play against to be
honest from time to time. And players
that Colin's met today, I imagine do not
have that much experience. I don't know
if that's necessarily true for Sam, but
I think it's certainly true of many of
Colin's opponents through today of
Swiss, but Kaiser Survivor is on the
board. Did get played last turn and is
off under the candle at Sanctum to do
the thing, filter and then draw, which
always feels good. And again, Sam
searching for answers in this game.
Still behind.
>> Yeah, this is an interesting situation
because
what are the answers? Obviously, finding
another Trinity Force just to speed up
the point gain to try to keep pace makes
sense. But in terms of getting rid of
the auction or in terms of generating
enough might to compete with the might
that Colin has been generating turn
after turn. I don't know unless it's
something from the sideboard
specifically what Sam could be looking
to find.
>> Didn't find a Trinity Force. I can tell
you cuz looking through the tops of the
Oh, actually
>> I uh
>> is this a caster cursing?
>> I may have to. [laughter]
>> Look, I only get to see so many of the
cards. All right. And I saw a sliver of
that card and identified Trinity Force
in a moment. So, I'll at least give
myself some credit as Lucian's going to
get suited up and roll on in. But to
where? I guess it's the only Battlefield
that he doesn't currently occupy and
hasn't scored this turn. That question
was easy to answer.
>> Yes. And also uh because you want to
potentially draw off of the Temple as
well.
Does look like there's a uh Relentless
Pursuit in the hand for a potential
future use. Unless I'm mistaken,
>> doesn't feel necessary right now, but
>> no, not now, but for future that's a
very important card to have in hand.
>> Does actually set up a win from four
with the combo. That is one of the
things that makes this deck so explosive
and so powerful. Do have to think
though. I mean, I was I was kind of
writing Colin's hand off because I was
like, what can you really do with run? I
guess we've said it a few times already
this set, but uh can punch first and I
think is doing the math to make sure
that does not happen to this Lucian. So
piling on the might, Doran's blade
moving in. 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 might on
this solution plus the assault. Make it
four more for 15.
>> Punch first not going to do any work
there. So instead, I think the buff will
be expended.
>> That was the real math is that the extra
Doran's blade was essentially plus three
because of the assault as well. And that
is enough to get it over the hump. And
again, rightfully Sam recognizing what
is the thing that I would potentially be
punished by here. Let's take a moment,
do the math, be patient. Again, game
three of round eight. It's been a
marathon. These players started at 10:00
a.m. Uh, it is now 9:52 p.m. So, almost
in their, you know, 12hour mark
essentially, and still making sure that
they don't make mental mistakes that
could cost them.
>> I mean, by minutes left on the round, we
are going to finish this round very
close to 10 p.m. So, it's pretty much 12
hours of round here today in Atlanta.
And I'm actually starting to get a
little nervous cuz two points scored
there thanks to the Skyfall and the
Trinity Force combination on top of the
Conquer. Lucian already ready going to
roll on back. A card drawn there from
Sunken Temple. And as we already noted
with Relentless Pursuit, Lucian with the
combo enabled is really good at getting
multiple points a turn. Four is an easy
number for Lucian at this stage if you
have an RP. And as we know, Sam has one
waiting in hand. And Colin has to be
thinking, how do I lose this game? Cuz
you have to think about it now. Yeah,
this is a point where I really got to
give a hand to Sam because Colin jumped
out with the might on the board very
early, stole your combo piece with the
auction, and not only has Sam hung in
there, but was also very aggressively
finding ways to still draw cards. that's
allowed Sam to maintain the ability to
even compete for this game by finding
the additional Trinity Force, by finding
these other equipment pieces, making use
of this Kai'Sa and the Sanctum to just
get there. Right. Again, I was saying I
don't know what the answers are that you
know you're trying to find. Well, it
turns out it was this. You're now in a
position where you're forcing Colin to
uh likely put a bunch of units on the
board and then play around whatever Sam
does. Again, we know Colin has that
punch first. We know there's a lot of
might on the board. Uh Colin could very
well make this work, but Sam is kind of
forcing the issue now, which I would say
two turns ago would have been almost
unthinkable. I think both players should
be commended for playing patient when
they needed to, when they could, and
then not being patient when they
couldn't be anymore. Both these players
have held back units, have given up
quote unquote free points in order to
navigate to a slightly better position.
And then when they must go, they do
throw units away if they have to to find
the cards they need to filter through
more to get those points and get the
game moving in the right direction. So,
an expertly navigated game all series
long between these two as Lucian rolls
on in. No one there. No one at home
after King Kum Monk ran into Kaisa and
did get the trade.
>> And uh is there a challenge?
>> No. So we have the Lucian going in. And
I think that there was a pause during
the showdown. I was about to say I think
we're going to see the Relentless
Pursuit come in to not only stop this
conquer, but threaten getting the
additional points off of the hold.
>> I see a very good card in Cullen. thumb
to the top of the pile.
>> Lucian moving in. A hidden blade. Not at
the battlefield just yet, but everyone
knows what's going to happen next. And
Lucian does go down. Two cards given
over. And that win that Sandy Sherman
could have had that backbreaking rel
pursuit just to break up this potential
point taken away thanks to Hidden Blade.
>> Yeah. And you have to wonder, would
Colin have expended resources below the
Hidden Blade threshold? Uh you and I
know, great player. Probably not. But uh
if Sam holds off, just allows the
conquerors to go. Was there a situation
where maybe Sam does get to pull it off
on the following turn? Hidden Blade is
always going to stop uh the combo if
it's up. There's just there's no counter
spells available. But if they go below
the energy threshold, then obviously
could have ran the bases, as they say,
go home for the home run. And uh you
were kind of chuckling I saw because it
was a double challenge shown from the
Sanctum. I appreciate Colin doing a
little bit of Hollywood there just, you
know, considering which of these two
cards are on even though we know they're
the same card. So just, you know,
considering making a little bit of
constonation as going to pass back at
six points ready to win by holding. I
wouldn't say that's a likely outcome in
the board state, but it is a possible
one here for Colin who has gotten
himself to the point threshold necessary
for the end game, but he's going to go
ahead commit some more runes and is set.
Kingpin coming out once more from the
top rope.
Looks like it, but don't know just yet.
Still
>> could also I was going to say be another
auction.
I thought I saw the other one picked up
and I was about to say it could also be
another auction because if you can take
the other Trinity Force now you're
forcing Sam to have the third and have a
unit
[laughter]
>> and Sam saying I know you want this
Doran's blade. They got a chuckle out of
Colin too. You'll love to see that.
>> It's just as much might as the Trinity
Force. I will remind you
>> he's going to go on over and attach to
that Lucian. Actually moves the Oh, gets
a skyfall. Wants to combo him. Yeah. So,
so this is interesting. Axan just has
weapon master. So, that moves over the
Trinity Force from the one that stole
it. And then you steal the Skyfall. So,
that actually is going to open up a
potential combo from Colin. And now it's
Sam who has to figure out how to stop
it.
>> Means you can win by uh conquering one
battlefield. Uh also means you can win
by seven just by scoring uh a point even
if you only conquer one battlefield. Uh,
obviously threatening to hold to seven
here feels pretty good, but bunch of
different ways for a set to combo, which
not something I would have expected, but
I guess enough axan can get the job
done.
>> Yeah, and again, we kind of highlighted
it a little bit earlier in the
broadcast, but the main deck gear
answers have really shined in this
event. And obviously going to the
sideboard, even more access to it. But
over and over again, we're seeing that
the equipment from Spirit Forged has
made a splash. And also, that means that
the answers for the equipment that were
introduced in Spirit Forge are also just
as impactful.
Players thinking, looks like Sam is
wondering, how do I get out of this
sticky situation? Needs to start with a
unit in play, I would imagine. But, uh,
the combo has been broken up once again.
in fact given over. Well, I guess not
given are stolen by Colin and those two
Axan. So, Confront going to kick things
off. Gets a draw, gets some ready. That
seems pretty good when you're trying to
get yourself to some battlefields. But,
as we've pointed out a few times, that
Trinity Force is only going to do its
thing on hold right now, which is not uh
not the best in a deck that wants to
combine a few pieces of equipment for
something a little bit more ambitious.
>> Yeah. And I like starting with this
confront because you get the additional
information off the draw, but also uh
you're not going to do anything unless
you can play a unit and use it
immediately.
And now we're going to see Sam develop
uh what I believe is a two drop.
Question is going to be which one? It's
going to be the Pyro.
>> Pyro
>> ready to go.
Getting close to the end here in this
one. Suit up the poro. Off we go
and charge on in. Question is where. I
guess the occupied battlefield with the
sunken temple draw. Ooh, that challenge
is really nice.
>> So you go in and then with the first
action of the showdown as the active
player. You get the first option going
to challenge
uh the ashan in the back.
>> Get the sky back.
>> Get that skyfall back. But again, the
other Trinity Force, which was stolen
from the other auction, but was moved
over because of weapon master, will
still hang out.
>> Oh, assault actually giving a bunch of
extra. I was trying to figure out if uh
the math checked out, but of course, Sam
Sherman has done it already.
>> Yeah, that that's specifically why the
challenge was played after the showdown
began. You didn't want to do it uh
without the additional might from the
assault. So, again, very heads up play.
You would expect that from a player of
Sims caliber, but also just very clear,
put a lot of reps in on Lucian and
understands the timing of something like
that.
>> Running out of runes as well. And I
think there actually is a decision here
cuz it seems like why not take this on
Contemporal Draw? You're not going to
hold up anything else. But the other
consideration may be equipping the
Skyfall. Not really for the combo
potential just for the fact that this
power needs to get a little bit bigger.
>> That is actually a fair consideration.
Uh the auction on the other side is
currently a five with the buff and
there's the illusion. Depending on what
the rune split is though, if Colin's on
an even split, for example, there's a
world where not getting a body rune
means that that Trinity Force cannot be
equipped to either of the units.
>> That's true. Also, we know there's a
punch first hang out in hand. There's
one.
>> There's there's two.
>> That feels pretty good.
>> Face breaker off the top and the mic
does that up. It's 11 I believe. So
Lucian going to go ahead and ready up.
Aan going to roll on in. Punch first and
that's the game. Colen is going to stay
undefeated on set of all legends to kick
off regional qualifier Atlanta. Eying
yet another top eight, but this time
with a very different beast. Yeah, I
think that was such a fun series to
watch because as I pointed out, uh it's
just heavy weights. [music]
>> Yeah, it is all good stuff. Big heavy
punches thrown first. Mhm. Very
important.
>> Uh a little bit of thievery with the
auctions. Uh but ultimately, [music] if
you're somebody at home who you're so
sick of seeing the rebukes, you're so
sick of the the chaos cards, the calm
cards, well, this is showing you that
not only uh can you play heroes outside
of those domains, but uh those champions
can go undefeated through day one. Or in
Sam's case, 7-1, still incredibly
respectful, kept that series very close.
Uh, I would expect big things still from
Sam in day two as well. Uh, but that was
just a ton of fun and a great way to end
day one.
>> I think it's one thing to look at two
great players like that on these decks
in particular and be like, oh, looking
good in day two. Live absolutely for the
best of maybe just live to top eight
like
>> absolutely
>> that's wild. No, no one no one had set
in their top eight for this event. I can
guarantee that much. And again, we are
number of
>> that's not true.
>> Colin had it.
>> Ah, that's true. in his top eight
because Colin very clearly came to play.
>> Certainly did. You know, I like that.
It's a kind of gumption. I appreciate
him both a commentator [laughter] and a
player. Again, not there yet. There are
eight rounds of Swiss done today. There
are five more rounds of Swiss tomorrow
and then of course we have three more
rounds after that and a little something
called the top eight where we will crown
yet another regional qualifier champion.
And uh it would be quite something to
see a repeat North American champion.
And Sam Sherman's still alive for that
as well.
>> Are we going to see it? I'm going to put
you on the spot. Are we going to see it?
>> I don't think so, but after seeing that
set play, I really won't call [laughter]
it to win. Sorry, deck's really cool.
>> Not much we can do about that.
>> All right. Well,
we've had a good day.
>> We've had a good day. It's been 12 hours
as you pointed out.
>> 12 hours.
>> Um, what are you looking forward to
tomorrow? Okay, apart from Moret, which
uh we will pretty much get at this point
cuz it'd be uh usually put the the
players that are exo on stream a little
bit and Con's record looking pretty
good. Expect to see actually both these
players at some point tomorrow on
stream.
>> Haven't seen I want to see some Azir.
>> I want I want to know what the Azir is.
What are the top Azers in this event
cooking up?
>> Yeah, haven't seen a lot of that. Uh
despite being well represented because
very popular legend, I don't believe
you've seen Ahri yet.
>> Haven't seen Ari yet. Still time.
>> Are we going to see more Victors proving
me wrong? Because I'm a a Victor hater.
>> We are Victor haters. [laughter]
>> Sorry, Victor players. Uh, you know
what? I I think I'm I'm really curious
to see actually what else what is what
is doing well on day two? What what
surprising decks are doing well on day
two? So, we kind of know the expected
game, but Ari certainly not something
we'd expect to do uh really well. So, is
there an X1 or an XO floating around? Uh
that is something I'd love to see. But
as we get through those Swiss rounds, I
really want to know what is the metag
game looking like? Who's converted? Like
we we know kind of what we started the
day with, but we going to finish with a
very different looking field and is it
what we expected? Is it not? Anything
surprising in terms of conversion rate?
Who's in the running for the best of?
There's a lot of fun things to uncover
tomorrow.
>> Yeah, there's also that conversation
about everybody's favorite dark horse
deck. Are they actually going to get it
done? Because we have uh like Rexi is a
great example. Well, that's a deck that
a lot of people say is potentially
sneaky good, but we haven't really seen
it in the results yet. So, that's
another one I think I'm looking forward
to tomorrow.
>> Well, I love hearing you. Yeah, but you
know what I like even more here from the
boss himself. We're going to go down for
a winners interview over at the desk.
>> Thanks so much guys for that pass. I am
joined here with Colin Kaiser sporting
set the boss. one of my favorite
legends, not just in Riftbound, but in
League of Legends as well. So, I've got
to ask you, Colin, you've already played
this character in the past. We actually
kind of feel like I we know you for this
character and this legend, but you took
a break from it and here you are playing
it once again, going 8 and0, day one at
the regional qualify in Atlanta. Why'd
you go back to set? Why now?
>> Honestly, it was uh kind of like an old
flame, just like you mentioned. I played
him exclusively in set one. uh did very
well in a lot of the uh thirdparty uh
tournaments s such as Charlie's and the
ppg and uh yeah I kind of missed it. I
didn't do so well in Leo. I started out
seven and one and then kind of bombed
day two. So I was like you know what
let's bust out the old uh the old
passion, the old love. And uh clearly
it's worked out well for me so far.
>> It's worked incredibly well. And I'm not
going to sit here and talk about the
debate about do you play uh set kingpin
or you know set brawler because we all
know that you do kind of favor this
kingpin variant. So many four drops as
you saw in some of those games earlier
both of you playing like tooth and nail
with your runes recycling as many you
you've played set that way every single
time. Can you explain to me like how
difficult and how much discipline it
takes to play the deck on those kind of
thin rune margins exactly where you need
even right at the end right you're like
I need two more body runes but because
of the way we've been recycling our u
our our runes you got two more coming
off the top punch first ready to go it's
so incredibly hard to play a deck like
that and have the right tools at the
right time on the right turn. Uh, it
definitely is and it's something that I
try to teach to people as much as I can,
but you know, it's all about like
foresight and thinking two to three
turns ahead. Uh, you get two runes a
turn. So, knowing each time, okay, well,
if I spend my power to play my set, I'm
going to be down one. So, then I have to
factor, oh, if you kill one of my units
and I have to save it, then I'm down an
additional one. And, uh, factoring where
they all are. I knew at that point I did
have four order runes on that last turn.
And uh but I played a hidden blade the
turn before. So I was like I played five
order runes, seven bodies. So I was like
well I know what's coming off the top.
So uh we're we'll be good on that front.
So um yeah, it's just honestly it's just
thinking turns ahead. That's uh what I
always recommend to people. And and uh
yeah, I think that's really what you
need to do for a kingpin. It's all about
using the legend ability to the most of
its ability. I want my opponent to be
committing a ton of resources to killing
my huge kingpin. it comes back and then
it's coming back around. That's why I
play like the arena bars to give it the
buff back. And uh you know after you
spend all your resources to break me,
I'm just right back there at uh square
one. So
>> speaking of using your own resources,
how about taking some of your opponents?
Ouxan coming in huge again in this
matchup. And I I have set built as well.
It's no surprise. And I've got two of
them in the sideboard based off of the
gameplay I saw today. Colin, I got to
ask you, should I just be playing a
third one somewhere? It is so important
I feel like in these equipment based
matchups or just other decks with gears
of course and there stealing the Trinity
Forces denying the ability for that
combo to come online for the Lucian deck
really went a long way. Three maybe
should I do it?
>> I mean three is what I'm on. It was
actually kind of a last second change. I
had uh Kiana in my main deck uh
yesterday when I played in the PRQ and
she didn't do so hot for me. She kind of
felt a little bit too clunky. spending
the power, as we've already talked
about, is really tough for a set deck.
Uh so I was like, you know what? I'll
just swap this out for an auction. And I
had two auctions on the board already.
So we just upped it to three. And
obviously, as you said, it kind of came
in clutch. Uh notably, I don't have any
weapons in my deck. So if my opponent
doesn't have gears, he's just a four for
four vanilla. But honestly, that's uh
kind of good enough when you're playing
buffs, you're keeping it around forever.
And uh yeah, obviously in some matchups,
then he'll win the game on the spot,
just like he did for me there. Well,
Colin, you're 8 and0. Congratulations.
You're on your way to another top cut
hopefully here soon. So, I'm excited to
see you in day two. You get some
welldeserved rest. We're going to see
you tomorrow and we're going to send it
back to the Casters.
>> Definitely. Thank you, everybody.
>> Thanks, man. Appreciate it.
>> Have a great
>> Thank you so much. Always lovely to hear
from Colin. Great player. Really nice
guy and uh playing a pretty fun legend.
>> Yeah, absolutely. You know, I loved the
advice that Colin was giving there, not
just about thinking turns ahead, but uh
just playing through the margins.
Barrett, of course, asked, "How do you
play a deck where you know that your
rune margins are always going to be
thin?" Uh we have actually seen in the
past some players struggle with that. I
think that's maybe what scares them away
from set. But, uh Colin said he tries to
teach other players. It's very clear he
has a handle on it. Uh if you are an
aspiring set player, it is something
that can be done with reps. So, [music]
just put in the work.
>> Well, there's even more to look at,
though. I know we have Kangas and Miss
Chimchim standing by with a bit more
postgame analysis at the desk.
>> Sorry, not yet. I lied. Not yet. We will
have it though. We will have it.
[laughter]
>> I think it's on us. It's on us. Let's
go. There we go. Perfect way to close
out the day. We're going to talk about
one of the crazy moments in that last
game cuz Reagan, we were watching
backstage and we were freaking out at
that game three. That was nuts. It was
super duper special. If if you want to
go ahead and get right into what
>> was the last thing that we shot a little
preview for one of the videos will go
out tomorrow. But this moment in the
game, Reagan's going to handle the uh
tea promp or teleustrator here for us.
You might notice something. Reagan,
what's that? Aan got equipped to him.
>> Right now, he's got a Trinity Force
equipped to him.
>> And whose Trinity Force is it?
>> Um, it's my favorite person in the
world.
No, no. It's actually Sam's Trinity
Force.
>> Oh,
>> cuz Aan stole it. Aan's a bit of a
thief, right?
>> This is true.
>> Now, it might surprise you, but it gets
crazier than that, everybody. Cuz you
might notice there's four runes tapped.
If we play the clip, Reagan, what do you
think's going to come down from these
four runes?
>> Well, uh, I see two oranges. Oh, I think
it's another Oshan.
>> And what do you think this Aan's going
to take? Um, I think we're going to
target the Skyfall here because we've
already got the Trinity Force. And then
if
>> you We're not going to take the Doran's
Blade. You You're not going to take
Sam's offer. He's just trying to give it
to us.
>> No, Sam. I don't think we want that.
[laughter] We're going to put a question
mark next to that because we actually
want to go ahead and make this combo on
set. And what is that combo?
>> Weapon master Exon to take the other
Exon stolen Trinity for us. Exon ability
to steal the skyfall. We have
successfully
reassembled the Lucian combo in set. A
crazy moment in Riftbound history. I've
never seen anything like this, but it
shows the strength of Axan. And Reagan,
you've been hot on Axan all tournament.
Absolutely. And as you can see here, I
have drawn three hearty porros because
we love Ashan. I've been preaching the
word of the Fiora decks, but
specifically because of that Auxon unit
in that deck. Ouxan is able to take
these gears and in a meta in a uh in a
for absolutely where gears are so much
uh used all over the place. Okay, let me
clear out these for [laughter]
gears are used all throughout Spirit
Forge. Aan loves those gears. He loves
to take them from you and he loves to
make bigger and better, greater use of
them.
>> Now, the problem is we didn't actually
get to see the Exon score with this, but
that's not the point. The point is it
happened and we got to assemble the
Lucian combo in set. We wanted to show
off how cool that was and just how
impactful Exon is. You said he's the
best unit in the in the game. Are you
standing by that?
>> I'm standing by that. And honestly, I
think that Ashan can go as far to be the
best card in Spirit Forge, but you know,
I'll just say I'll just say for right
now, we'll leave him as the best unit.
And this is this is why because Colin
was behind at a certain point. He was he
was trailing behind, but he got not one
not one, but two auctionons on the
board, and he was able to turn this game
around. This one was in danger. I'm
telling you, if you had given him
another turn, another two turns, maybe
we get all three or two treny forces.
But either way, that was a fun moment we
wanted to highlight because you don't
see that every day. That's it from us.
Back to the casters.
[laughter]
You know, somebody had to do it. I
suppose it's been a fun day. As we
mentioned, I have to say though, as the
uh the baited hook enthusiast on this
coverage team, I do feel attacked.
People keep plugging all this main deck
gear removal.
>> I mean, it's not even plugging it at
this point. If you heard mischief,
>> that's true. It's a hard
>> is the best unit in the game.
>> Pretty good unit.
>> You know who I think has something to
say about that?
>> Who?
>> Lonely Borro. [laughter]
>> Lonely Porro is a really great unit.
>> Yeah,
>> he's drawn many, many cards today.
>> The reason that Lonely Porro is the best
unit in the game is because the only
thing keeping him back is his
loneliness. If he had friends, he'd be
unstoppable. You cannot beat the power
of friendship.
>> You do know there's like a friendly part
coming in the next set, right?
>> Yeah, but friendly isn't the same as
having friends. [music]
I know because I am friendly. [laughter]
Don't have friends.
>> Well, I will say that part does draw a
card when it uh when it dies not alone
from remembering the text correctly. But
uh it's been a fun day and kind of uh
we're going to take ourselves back, I
think, before we close out the day cuz
we have quite a bit to cover and still a
tournament or a day sorry I should say
to end. Let's have a look where we
started yesterday. Here's actually this
is uh this is a fun one. This is the
preQ. This is on Friday and the day one
metag game. So the numbers on your left
are the preQ and the numbers on your
right are day one. And we're just
showing you know the different
representations of these decks.
>> Yeah. And I really like this because it
showcases the difference between when
you're kind of playing an event where
you're focused on winning without
competing for the best of versus when
the best ofves make that impact on the
meta. And I think this graphic shows it
beautifully. So Draven still the most
popular deck across both days. I think
that was expected by most folks or if
you are an Ireelia believer then maybe
you thought she would maintain that
number one spot after Leil. But uh then
we again see Ireelia in the clear number
two. Kai'Sa in the clear number three.
But after that uh actually Master Yi
holding in tight because of the
popularity likely from Leil at four. But
then after that is where you start to
see it start to uh break away because
Ari a little bit down goes from 1.9%
uh up to 4% but triples the number of
players in the field just because of the
legends popularity.
>> Yeah, you can see double the number of
ons from the PRQ to day one which you
know maybe tell you something about the
people looking for that best of card.
Rumble also increasing in numbers. It's
kind of funny to me that Yei went up. I
almost feel like some number of those
players are people that pivoted last
minute to maybe playing a different tech
in the RQ. It
>> it is also worth noting that while total
number of players went up, the percent
of the field did go down, right? More
players
>> more players coming in with some of
those other legends.
>> Look at Leona again. Going deeper here.
We had six in the preq meta, but 34 in
day one. That's a lot more sets as well,
but I have a feeling the sets are maybe
not so happy with their decision because
there's one set rampaging through the
field as we saw just in our last run.
Teemo also shooting up uh mostly to
place Charmer. Actually, a bunch of
those people picked up the deck on his
recommendation. I was one of them, but
unfortunately it's illegal for me to
play in the RQ. So, I did not
participate. I'm here instead, which is
good fun. Yasa going up, volleyball
going up. Kind of the things you'd
consider. Even Karen uh that is what
more than 5xing the numbers of Gar which
definitely makes sense in the preQ
versus day one here of the regional
qualifier. I'm very curious how many of
these decks in the lower percentages
have maybe made day two. I think that's
maybe something we'll get to find out
later though.
>> Yeah, I want to give a personal shout
[music] out to the three Garen players
that chose to play that legend in a non
best of event.
>> You need practice. You are you are about
that life. That's the way that I'm going
to put it. [laughter] You are very
clearly are loving that spin to win
gameplay.
>> Well, we have even more cool things to
look at as far as the stats go. Let's
look at some cards. The top 16 cards
from Atlanta. This is all sets or cards
main event
number one at the top. I don't think
that's particularly surprising. It's
rebuke. Well, it is a little bit
interesting just because if you were
paying attention to Leo, I believe
Ferris 4runner was actually number one
for that event. And I think folks knew
that and said, well, if there are so
many mechs running around, what's the
best way to deal with that that's also
still good in almost every other game,
it turns out it's Rebuke. So, uh, Rebuke
does reclaim that number one spot, but
Ferris 4Runner [music] continuing to be
a savage, still in the number two.
Personally, I blame the people that
revealed that card, whatever creators it
was that got to spoil that. Uh, it's
your fault.
>> Yeah, truly cursed spoiler video as
well. Hard bargain and ride the win.
Chaos eaten pretty good as far as
representation goes. And defy, I feel
like those numbers probably [music] up
from previous original qualifiers. That
card is pretty good equity wise right
now. Lots of little spells you want to
be interacting with. And honestly, other
Defi as well. And uh, also [music]
seeing Noxus hopeful there. We've said
how good that card is a number of times
on the broadcast just because it's very
[music] energyefficient for the four
might. Uh obviously got a lot of
representation from the Dravens, but
we've been seeing those Darius lists as
well. Uh we have Kais that like to run
it. It's just one of those universally
good cards. I think I said earlier in
the broadcast it's one of those staples.
It's a workhorse that it it's just a
common card. It's not flashy, but it'll
probably be around for a long time in
the meta.
>> Yeah, charm as well at 10th. I think
that card has probably gone up and
certainly has been a lot more charms
running around these days. And you have
to go all the way down to 16, believe it
or not, to find your first mind card.
Thousand tail watch a pretty good card
as it turns out has been quite the
staple since Origins. But we'll move on
cuz there's even more of these to look
through here. Guardian Angel getting
beaten out by Thousand Tail Watch is
kind of interesting one. Although I feel
like that is a card that is better
played precisely maybe than anything
else. You don't need uh a surplus of
them so much as you need one at the
right time. And uh I don't know how I
feel about Miss Chim's analysis of best
unit in the game because actually
mischievous all the way down to 27.
Although that might be quite a bit
bigger than it was in other metag games.
>> So speaking of [music] scary units that
exist in the game, Stellacicorn Herder
is there.
>> Good unit. I'm actually kind of
surprised that that is so low on the
list. [music] But it is, I think, a
situation where the lists that want to
run it are all on three copies, but
there's just not as many uh decks
outside of Aurelia that are really
taking advantage of it, except for maybe
some of those best of lists. You know,
you had mentioned that the Thousand Tail
Launcher was the first mine card we saw.
Uh it makes a lot of sense that the
second one we saw was Bellow's Breath,
which is very often paired with it.
>> And then Singularity also a pretty good
one right down two spots later. salvage
and uh salvage also going up means that
again that mean that gear hit is moving
up and Aurelia fervent what I want to
point out I don't think we would have
seen this many Aurelia typically despite
how much Aurelia is in the field but
there's just more people putting it in
decks that aren't Aurelia and she
typically only plays one and even those
decks have started adding more copies
>> yeah and we've seen Master Y they grew
in popularity and they are also playing
that Ireelia Fervent so uh again just a
good card overall uh very easy to
activate obviously The Ireelia Legend
has the best way to manipulate it, but
uh it does not [music] cost power. It
can represent a lot of might and also
the deflect is relevant. All right,
we'll have a look at uh something I'm
very fond of. We got to look at uh these
this again the most represented cards,
but this time we're going to look at
Battlefield, something we see every
single game of Riftbound. Zorn Warren at
number one taking over Targon's Peak.
Yeah, this actually speaks a lot to what
we were talking about earlier. Uh, you
had pointed out with the set deck, all
three battlefields were really just
geared around how to draw cards, and
that makes sense with set specifically
because those domains are not known for
their card draw ability, but just in
general throughout the day, we've seen a
lot of folks looking for [music] ways to
refill the hand. Yeah, I think pe people
are really feeling the loss of the
dreaming tree and this is a kind of
their go-to even [music] if a lot of
decks are able to manipulate it in both
directions.
>> It's me. I'm feeling the loss of the
dreaming tree. Aspirit's climb also
being third is actually kind of wild.
We've seen I think a lot more of that
battlefield creeping into different
decks. We even heard uh on stream that
you know it's kind of one that's pretty
good when you're going second try and
regain a little bit of that tempo and
slow the game down. So that is a lot of
that card running around the metag game.
And I think the other one I want to
point out cuz I kept seeing it all day
long and I was trying to figure it out
but people just hate Aurelia man. Viles
lair around in a ton of different decks.
>> Yeah, the last one that I want to
mention is Arena's greatest. Earlier in
the broadcast I'd said if we see that
aspirants climb start to rise in
popularity, we might see players playing
Arena's greatest. I do think that part
of this is just the aggressive decks
that are naturally running it like the
Annies. But I did actually get a chance
to talk with a player that is on Draven.
Uh they were 6 and0 at the time that I
talked to them and they said
specifically they are on both climb and
arena's greatest as Draven specifically
to play Arena's greatest when they are
going first likely offsetting the climb.
So uh people are already ahead of even
me. So, the Aspirant Arena Gamer is is
in for day two is what you're telling
me. No matter what happened in those
last two rounds, they're running around
looking to try and match up by your
battlefield with theirs as we are going
to have a look at where we finished at
the end of today cuz again, we played
eight rounds of Swiss. Have a look at
the standings. Who is still left
undefeated? My goodness, that's a bunch
of good players. So, right here at the
top, Boulevard, if you are familiar with
Legends of Ruter and that competitive
scene, was a caster there. also a very
good competitive card game player at 8
and0 in the number one slot. And you
know what I'm just going to say that was
the game I was talking [laughter] about
on the arena's greatest and aspirin
fund. So that is very good to see. Of
course we see prismaticism ism up there
as well. Colin that we just saw on the
broadcast still 8 and0. Uh but a lot of
players also still in the running here
with those seven and ones or seven in
draws.
>> I mean Allan is undefeated I will say
alongside Stardust and Koko Lopez 701. A
draw is not a loss. I will remind you
even though the record is not as good 8
and a few players we saw on stream
Ominous Milk and Haraz still at X and
well we are going to have a look through
all the way through to top 64 cuz I may
remind you this is a regional qualifier
and while it doesn't matter right now if
the cut off happened these players would
would all qualify for the regional. You
do have to finish within top 64 by the
end of tomorrow. But uh if you're
already top 64 that has to feel pretty
good.
>> Yeah. And here we see Icado as well
again from Legends of Runa. see Ricky
Kasanova, which is not to be confused
with uh Kasanova, our caster friend, but
still doing well. Uh the person I I know
I'm supposed to not be biased, but the
person I'm rooting against currently is
the I hate coffee.
>> How dare you?
>> Uh [laughter] you know what? At least uh
maybe it's doing something for them
because even though I agree with you on
principle, clearly Xen one is feeling
pretty good at the moment. We of course
have Sam Sherman in this clump as well
cuz we just saw them on stream lose
their first game. Dual winner of RQ
Houston on Annie all that time ago at 36
at 7 and1 as well. There are some real
good players still at XML moving in
today too. Absolutely. And Strosen that
we saw earlier on the broadcast uh
played beautifully and again going all
the way down currently to 64. I believe
production said uh 71s go into the 80s.
uh 80th place uh specifically, but uh
again, top 64 is where you want to be
because as you pointed out, regional
qualifier, top 64 qualifies you for that
regional event. Uh and again, these are
all players that are live. So even if
you are in that 80th place, if you are
DG Star, you just got to win tomorrow.
You can still qualify.
>> Some players we've seen at a few
different regions. Such there in 69th.
Doc Silchi is also play been on stream a
few times at 72nd.
>> Uh also noticed that Captain Jack was at
the bottom of the last stands and I I
sure hope that isn't a famous Korean
League of Legends player from a very
long time ago, but perhaps inspired uh
by the man that invented a very fancy uh
QSS for anyone that knows their very old
League history like me.
>> I am still farming for my runes that I
need to play trying [laughter] to get to
level 30 so that I can hasn't updated
the game in a while but has.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Oh,
>> thankfully has the latest Riftbound
patch and has been astute all day long.
>> Are you going to queue up and play
Twisted Treeine with me? That's my
preferred game mode because you only
need three players and as I had pointed
out do not have friends, so I like the
smaller game modes.
>> Pretty sure I'm going to go go back and
maybe play some 2v2. That is it though
for today. It has been an absolute blast
bringing you the action here for day one
of Atlanta. I'm Pry. That's Charma
Kangas and Chinchim. We're all going to
be back tomorrow as we go ahead and
close things out. It has been absolutely
incredible to see again original
qualifier stacked with names we are
getting to know better and better.
It's just been uh such a wonderful time.
Trauma
next round. What are we doing?
Round nine. Where are we going? We are
going to go back to the hotel and play
2v2. Well, what's happening tomorrow?
Atlanta, man. We'll find out tomorrow.
Atlanta has been a wonderful host city.
There has been an incredible number of
people whether they're in the main event
or side events. It's just been
spectacular. [music]
It's been wonderful here in Atlanta to
see yet another Riftbound qualifier
crown a few new champions. We have quite
a few players here on day two and we
have 64 left to qualify. But we have
even more than that. We are only going
to get down to eight players by the end
of tomorrow. Spells will be slung,
hearts will be broken, and fun will be
had across the board. Will a new legend
take the mantle? Will an old favorite
move through? Will prismaticism honestly
make yet another regional qualifier at
top eight? There are these questions and
[music] many, many, many more to answer.
Perhaps a new hero will answer the
[music] call here in Atlanta, but it's
hard to say. And the only way to find
out for sure is to watch that thing on
your screen right there. The main event
is going to be coming back in just a
[music] few moments. Atlanta, you've
been absolutely wonderful, but the best
news we've had all day long is that we
get to do it all again tomorrow.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[music]